hey everyone blockchain technology is
revolutionizing Industries across the
globe and it's changing the way we do
our career in this video on blockchain
full course by simply learn I'll guide
you through everything you need to know
about blockchain technology its
potential and how it can benefit your
career
in this full course you will learn the
fundamentals of blockchain Technology
including its architecture consensus
mechanism and the different types of
blockchain networks you'll get hands-on
experience on creating and deploying a
blockchain network on popular platforms
like ethereum and hyperledger fabric
additionally we'll cover the latest
blockchain Frameworks including solidity
programming and smart contracts
also you will learn about Bitcoin and
ethereum ethereum 2.0 and also the
difference between Bitcoin and ethereum
we'll also explore the use cases of
blockchain Technology including its
impact on finance Healthcare Supply
Chain management and more
finally we'll see how you can build your
career in blockchain and how you can
prepare for it with reference interview
questions
I will guide you through this course to
ensure a comprehensive understanding of
the concepts so don't forget to
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the Bell icon to have update from Simply
learn by the end of this video you'll be
able to comprehend how blockchain
technology works and the potential it
holds for your career for this training
with me I have our experienced
blockchain specialist together we'll
walk you through the important
blockchain Keynotes so let's start with
an exciting video on blockchain full
course before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the Bell icon to never miss an update
from Simply learn so now let's take a
look what's in it for all of us today we
will be talking about what is ethereum
the features of ethereum like
cryptocurrency smart contracts ethereum
virtual machine decentralized
application and it uses and
decentralized autonomous organization
we'll be also looking at applications of
ethereum and a demo on Smart contract
deployment on a locally running ethereum
client now what is ethereum ethereum is
a blockchain based Computing platform
that enables developers to build and
deploy these centralized applications so
basically ethereum is a platform where
we can build application editions which
are not run by a centralized Authority
you can create a decentralized
application where the participants of
that particular application are the
decision making Authority so the hair we
can see ethereum allows us to build and
deploy dap applications now what are the
typical features of ethereum ethereum
allows you to use its own cryptocurrency
called eth it allows development and
deployment of smart contracts it
provides you the underlying technology
the architecture the software which
understands smart contracts and allow
you to interact with it which is called
ethereum virtual machine then it allows
eventually to create Consolidated
applications called decentralized
applications and also it allows you to
create decentralized autonomous
organization now let's talk about
ethereum cryptocurrency ether eth is a
cryptocurrency that runs on ethereum
network basically it is the fuel which
is running the ethereum network it is
used to pay for the computation
additional resources and the transaction
fees for any transaction to be executed
on an ethereum Network like Bitcoin
ether is also a peer-to-peer currency
apart from paying for transaction ether
is also used to buy gas which is used to
pay for computation of any transaction
you make on an ethereum Network also if
you have to deploy a contract on
ethereum network you will need gas and
you would have to pay for that gas in
ethers SO gas is the execution fee paid
by a user for running a transaction in
ethereum ether can be utilized for
building decentralized applications for
building your smart contracts and making
standard peer-to-peer payments now what
is a smart contract a smart contract is
a simple computer program that
facilitates the exchange of any valuable
asset between two parties it could be
money it could be shares it could be
property or it could be any other
digital asset which you want to exchange
these contracts can be created by anyone
on the ethereum network and primarily
the contract consists of the terms and
conditions mutually agreed between the
parties between the peers and the
primary feature of a smart contract is
that once it is executed it cannot be
altered and any transaction done on top
of a smart contract is registered
permanently it is immutable so even in
future you modify the smart contract the
transactions correlated with the
original contract does not get altered
or you cannot modify them so for the
verification process smart contract is
carried out amongst the anonymous
parties of the network without the need
of a centralized Authority and that's
what makes any smart contract execution
on ethereum a decentralized execution it
provides the transfer of any asset or
currency in a transparent and a
trustworthy manner as the two entities
are totally unaware their identity is
secure on the ethereum network though
the transactions weren't successfully
done the accounts of the sender and
receiver are updated accordingly and
there's why it generates a trust between
the parties who are transacting using
the ethereum network now what happens in
traditional system of contract in
traditional systems of contract you sign
an agreement then you trust a third
party hire a third party for execution
now the problem is that in such an
engagement the data tampering is
possible now if we talk about the new
smart contract the agreement is coded in
a program now result is not verified by
a centralized Authority it is verified
by the participants on ethereum based
blockchain Network now once a contract
is executed the transaction is
registered and it cannot be altered or
tampered so it removes the risk of any
data manipulation or alteration now
let's take another example where has
given a contract of five hundred dollars
to Elsa for developing his company's
website now the developers code the
agreement of smart contract using
ethereum's programming language now the
smart contract has all the conditions
the requirements for building the
website once the code is written it is
uploaded and deployed on the ethereum
evm virtual machine evm is a runtime
compiler to execute your smart contract
once the code is deployed on the evm
every participant on the network has a
copy of the contract now now when elsea
submits the work on ethereum for
evaluation each node on the ethereum
network will evaluate and confirm
whether the result given by Elsa is done
as per the coding requirements and once
approved and verified the contract worth
500 dollars will be self-executed and
the payment will be paid to Elsa in
ethers so John's account the person who
had gone into account tracked his
account will be automatically debited
and Elsa will be credited with 500 in
ether denomination here we will now take
a look we will do a demo small demo on a
deployment of a smart contract so for in
order to execute our smart contract we
will need two set of softwares ganache
and truffle and we will show you in the
demo how to install these two softwares
on your machine now we will be giving a
demo on the following smart contract
this is a smart contract where we are
writing a simple contract of greeter
where I have a variable called greeting
which we will be initializing using a
Constructor and then in our demo we will
be showing how you can change the value
of the variable greeting using the set
greeting method and read the value using
the grid method this is the other
contract where we will be defining that
whoever is deploying the contract on the
blockchain network is always the owner
of the contract and then we have defined
find certain mandatory functions in
order to kill the contract on the
ethereum network so only the owner of
the contract can kill it now let's talk
about what is an ethereum virtual
machine it's a virtual machine is
designed to operate as a runtime
environment for compiling and deploying
ethereum based smart contracts basically
evm is the engine which understands the
language of smart contracts which are
written in solidity language for
ethereum evm is operated in a sandbox
environment basically you can deploy
your own Standalone environment which
can act as a testing and a development
environment and you can n number of
times test your smart contract deploy it
verify it and then once you are
satisfied with the performance and the
functionality of the smart contract you
can deploy it on the ethereum main net
now any programming language in the
smart contract is compiled into the byte
code which the evm understands this byte
code can be read and executed you using
an ethereum feature called ethereum
virtual machine so basically evm machine
understands the byte code so one of the
most popular languages for writing a
smart contract is solidity so once you
write your smart contract on solidity
that contract gets converted into the
byte code and gets deployed on the EV
and thereby evm guarantees security from
Cyber attack now how does evm work so
suppose a wants to pay B 10 ethers the
transaction will be sent to the evm
using a smart contract for a funds
transfer from A to B now in order to
validate the transaction the ethereum
network will perform the proof of work
consensus algorithm the minor nodes on
the ethereum will validate this
transaction whether the first the
identity of a exists or not a has the
relevant amount of balance to transfer
10 ether to B and in will validate the
transaction once validated The Ether
will be debited from A's wallet and will
be credited to B's wallet and during
this course the miners will charge a
fees in order to validate this
transaction and will earn a reward now
all the nodes on ethereum network
execute smart contract using their
respective evns now how does proof of
work works every node in the ethereum
network has the entire history of all
the transactions the entire chain it has
the history of smart contract with
basically the address at which the smart
contract is deployed the transactions
associated with the smart contract and
also it has the handle to the current
state of the smart contract now the goal
of the miners on the ethereum blockchain
network is to validate the block for
each block of transaction miners use the
computational power and resources to get
the appropriate hash value by varying
the nonce now the miners will vary the
nons and pass it through a caching
algorithm in case of ethereum it is the
ET hash algorithm this produces a hash
value which should be lesser than the
predefined target as per the proof of
work consensus if the hash value
generated is less than the target value
then only the block is considered to be
verified and the miner gets rewarded
only then now when the proof of work is
solved result is broadcasted and shared
with all the other nodes in order to
update their Ledger if other nodes
accept the hash block as valid then the
block gets added to the ethereum main
net blockchain and as a result The Miner
receives a reward which as of today
stands at three ethers plus the miner
receives the transaction fees which has
been generated for verifying the block
all the transactions which are
aggregated in the block the cumulative
transaction fees associated with all the
transactions is also rewarded to The
Miner now do you know in ethereum a
process called proof of stake is also
under development and it is an
alternative to proof of work it is meant
to be a solution to minimize the use of
expensive resources you spend for mining
using proof of work now in proof of
stake The Miner is actually the
validator can validate the transactions
based on the amount of crypto coins he
or she holds before he or she can start
the mining So based on the accumulation
or the repository of crypto coins with
the miner beforehand will give him the
higher probability of mining the block
now however proof of stake is not widely
adopted as of now as compared to proof
of work algorithm now let's understand
the concept of gas now ethereum virtual
machine has a concept of gas and why do
we need it so like we need fuel to run
car in the same way in order to run
application on ethereum network we need
gas now what is gas to perform any
transactional ethereum network a user
has to make a payment has to Shell out
ethers a in order to get the execution
done the transaction done and the
intermediary monetary value is called as
gas on ethereum network gas is a unit
that measures the computational power
required to run a smart contract or a
transaction so if you have to do a
transaction which is updating the
blockchain you would have to Shell out
gas and that gas will come with a price
in ethers now how is the gas fees
calculated in ethereum the transaction
fees is calculated in ethereum using the
below formula for every transaction
there is a gas and the correlated gas
price so the amount of gas required to
execute a transaction multiplied by the
gas price you generate the transaction
fees so gas limit on ethereum network
refers to the amount of gas which is
used for the computation and the amount
of ether a user is required to pay for
the gas now here we have a screenshot
from the ethereum name mainnet where the
cost of trans action is being shown so
if you see for this particular example
transaction the gas limit was 21 000 the
gas used by the transaction was 21 000
and the gas price was 21 GUI which is
the lowest denomination so 21 GUI into
21 000 gave you the actual transaction
fees which is
0.00441 ether which is approximately
0.21 cents as of today's ether market
value now this transaction fee goes to
the miner who has validated the
transaction to understand the gas limit
and the gas price in a better way let's
consider an example of a car suppose
your car has a mileage of 10 kilometers
and the price of petrol is one dollar
per liter then driving a car for 50
kilometers will cost you 5 liters of
petrol which will be worth five dollars
similarly to perform an operation or to
run a code on ethereum you need to
obtain certain amount of gas like the
patrol where each gas has a per unit
price called gas price now if the user
provides less amount of gas to run a
particular operation then the process
will fail and the user will be given a
message of out of gas and GUI is the
lowest denomination of ether which is
used for measuring unit of a gas price
now how is ethereum's mining different
from Bitcoin mining the hashing
algorithm is the primary difference the
Bitcoin uses sha-256 ethereum uses it
hash the average time taken on bitcoin
for mining a block is 10 minutes whereas
in ethereum it is 12 to 15 seconds as of
today the mining rewards for Bitcoin is
12.5 BTC but for ethereum this is three
ethers plus the transaction fee the
cumulated transaction fee for all the
transactions for a block now as of 23rd
July the Bitcoin value was
7667 whereas one ether turns at 466
dollars now here we we have a screenshot
of ethereum reward which has been given
to the miner of the block now as you can
see here is the breakup of the reward
three ethers plus the total accumulated
transaction fee of all the underlying
transactions in this block which is
0.0666 ethers now what is a
decentralized application now let's
compare it with our traditional
applications our traditional websites
which are currently running so for
example when you log into Twitter a web
application gets displayed which is
rendered using an HTML page now the page
will call an API to access your personal
data your information which is centrally
hosted now it's a simple process your
front end executes a backend API and the
API goes and fetches the information
from a centralized DB now if we
transform this application into a
decentralized application then now when
you will log in the same web application
will get rendered but it will be calling
a smart contract based API to fetch the
information from the blockchain network
so the API gets replaced with the smart
contract interface and the smart
contract will fetch the information from
the blockchain network which is its
backend and that blockchain network is
not a centralized DB it's a
decentralized network where the
participants of the network the miners
of the network are validating verifying
all the transactions which are happening
using the smart contract on the
blockchain network so thereby any now
any transaction or any action happening
on the Twitter kind of application which
has been transformed will now cannot be
claimed as a centralized transaction it
will be a decentralized transaction
adapt a decentralized application
consists of backend code that runs on a
distributed peer-to-peer Network it is a
software designed to work on an ethereum
Network without being controlled by a
centralized system and that is the
primary difference it provides the
direct in interaction between the end
users and the decentralized application
providers now an application qualifies
as that when it is open sourced its code
is there on GitHub and it uses a public
blockchain based token in order to run
the application a token acts as a fuel
for the decentralized application to run
dap allows the backend code and data to
be decentralized and that is the primary
architecture of any dat now let's
discuss what are decentralized
autonomous organizations Dows is a
digital organizations that wants to
operate without any need of a hair kill
management it wants to operate in a
decentralized and a democratized fashion
so basically a Dao is an organization
where the decision making should not be
in the hands of a centralized Authority
but it should be in the hands of certain
designated authorities or a group of
designated people as a part of authority
it exists on a blockchain Network where
it is governed by the protocols embedded
in a smart contract and thereby they
rely on a smart contract for decision
making all the business decisions are
driven by the smart contracts or we can
say a decentralized voting system within
the organization so any organizational
decision before being taken has to go
through the voting system which is
running on a decentralized application
so how it work people add funds to the
Dow because Dao requires funding in
order to execute and take decisions
based on that each member is given a
token on a percentage basis which
represents the percentage of shares of
that particular member in the Dow now
those tokens are used to vote in the Dao
where the proposal status is decided
based on the maximum votes so every
decision within the organization has to
go through this voting process now let's
take a look what are the applications of
ethereum in real world and where it is
getting used so as we have seen with Dao
voting systems are adopting it the
results of the polls are publicly
available where it assures a transparent
and fair democracy by eliminating voting
malpractices it is getting adopted
widely in a banking scenarios and
banking systems with ethereum's
decentralized system it is becoming very
difficult for hackers to have
unauthorized access and it also allows
payments on an ethereum based Network so
banks are also using ethereum as a
channel to make remittances and payments
shipping deploying ethereum in shipping
helps tracking of cargo and prevents
goods from being misplaced or
counterfeited so basically ethereum is
providing you of the provenance and
tracking framework for any kind of asset
required in a typical supply chain now
with ethereum's smart contract
agreements can be maintained and
executed without any alteration so any
industry which has fragmented
participants is subject to disputes and
which requires and digital contracts to
be present then ethereum can definitely
be used as a technology for developing
your smart contract and digitally
recording the agreements and the
transactions based on those agreements
so let's get started for a demo on how
to deploy an ethereum smart contract
locally so in order to deploy a smart
contract we will be first installing
ganache client which allows you to host
a local ethereum client on which you can
deploy your smart contract so as we are
working on the Windows environment when
we are downloading the ganache setup we
can also download node order to install
ruffle on our machines
now as the node has been downloaded we
will install node
so now node is successfully installed
now we are going to install ganache
locally
now we will run ganache a little later
before that we will perform certain
steps or we can run ganache and C so
once Ganesh is up and running I'll show
you the interface how it looks
so when ganache is brought up it
automatically creates 10 accounts with
pre-funded balance of 100 ethers it is
running on localhost port number
7545 now as you see there is no
transaction or anything which has
currently happened so the current block
is 0 which is the Genesis block there
are no transactions and there are no
blocks as of now so there are no
transactions in Block which have been
generated so using this ganache client
now we will be deploying our Grita
contract now as we have installed node
we will be installing truffle truffle is
the utility which allows us to compile
and deploy ethereum contracts
okay now once a truffle is installed we
need to create a directory called
greeter
now we need to run the command truffle
now once we run this command
ruffle by default creates a packet
structure which has three folders called
contracts migrations test truffle.js and
truffle config now we will be writing
our smart contract called
greeter.soul and we will compile and
deploy basically our greeter dot soul
will be under contracts folder and we
can
our contract is created and it is lying
under contracts folder now we need to
add another file under migrations folder
called as deploycontract.js
so we will aim it as deploy contract now
in this deploy contract you need to put
line of code
now in this file we are asking truffle
to deploy our newly created greeter.soul
file now in the greater contract we have
a Constructor we are initializing the
greater contract with the value High
hello and we are passing a gas value so
this gas is currently at a higher limits
and we know that this gas value the
contract will get executed but otherwise
you can also evaluate the gas value of a
contract using remix now once this file
is being saved you go to the truffle.js
and make the following entry
now here we are trailing truffle that
our Local Host ganache client is running
on localhost at Port number 7545 and
network ID can be anything though the
current ganache client is running on
Port network ID 577 but we have kept it
open that we can connect to any network
ID now after this step I need to go back
to my command prompt and say ruffle
company
now if you get this error if we are
getting this kind of error in Windows
then we need to do one quick fix
we need to go to the users directory and
rename truffle.cmg to trough so I'll go
to my e-drive users
just
now here now instead of truffle I have
to say trough
now there might be certain compilation
warnings we can ignore that now my
contract is being compiled now I need to
run the next command trough my grade
at this stage my smart contract is
deployed and now you can see
this is the step this is the place where
the contract has been called and this is
the transaction where the default value
of my variable greeter has been set to
high hello so we will see now I need to
run command trust console
to interact with my contract now as on
my trough console I can check at what
address is my contract deployed so my
contract is deployed at address 0x37
which matches with the address 0x373
now I need to check the default value
which I had said while deploying my
contract so this is my value hi hello
now I can change the value to something
else because in my Grita contract I have
a method called set greeting now
whenever when I'll be performing this
action a new block will get generated
and the block count will increase from 4
to 5 because I am making a change on the
blockchain as you can see now a new
transaction has been created this was
the gas used this is the default gas
price in ganache and block number five
is being mined now I can re-read the
value of the variable now it will return
me the latest value which is change grid
value so this demonstrates how to use a
solidity contract how to compile it
deploy it on a locally running
blockchain Network you can connect
connect multiple nodes to this ganache
client and all the nodes should be
running on the same network ID should
have the same network ID but they can be
running on a different machine so here
we can see all the other details the
block the transactions which have
happened if I perform the action again
Rock number six has been generated has
another transaction associated with it
and I can get the latest value video we
will explore ethereum Mining and we'll
go through some of the fascinating
Concepts and components revolving around
it both we will have an introduction to
ethereum
then you will understand what is it idea
mining
then we will explore why should we minor
theorem
we will look into the types of ethereum
mining
and then we will understand how the
criteria mining process work
then we should explore how exactly to
mine ethereum
then we will discuss will the proof of
thick transgression kill group of work
and then finally we will find out is
Mining ethereum Profitable
so without doing much I do let's get
started with the video
let's bring you up to speed on ethereum
ethereum is defined as a blockchain
based Computing platform that enables
its developers to build and deploy
decentralized applications
and make sure all the transactions are
cryptographically secured in the network
ether is the cryptography of ethereum
used to build decentralized applications
smart contracts and make standard
peer-to-peer payments
Eco basically acts as fuel for the
ethereum network it traps and
facilitates all the transactions
so that brings us to what is ethereum
mining
in simple word ethereum mining is a
process of creating and adding a block
of transaction to the blockchain network
of ethereum
it uses the proof of work on senses
mechanism for mining ethereum
all transactions taking place in the
ethereum network needs to get approved
by the miners
miners is a community of people using a
hashing script etash to solve
computationally hard puzzles for
successfully mining the blocks of
transactions hinderium blockchain
Network which helps secure the network
from attacks like hacking or
manipulation of identity
now let's understand why you need to
mine ethereum
the primary goal for mining ethereum is
to make money a data mining returns Act
of signaling the network into a
relatively complex but profitable
business also miners receive a certain
amount as a reward for money each block
of the ethereum blockchain network
including the transaction fees paid by
the users thus it is a mining benefit
each and everyone participating in
ethereum blockchain network
so what are the types of ethereum mining
the therm mining can be performed in
three ways to get in Solo mining
ethereum poor Mining and ethereum Cloud
mining
in ethereum Solo mining you will get
rewarded only if you solve the puzzle
and mine the Italian block first
since here you are competing with many
people and companies you have to be very
good at your work
also solo mining is only profitable when
you have plenty of resources with you
like 100 plus graphics card
and in Solo mining having so much
equipment may use a lot of electricity
and space leading to high electricity
bills and not everyone has a
considerable amount of area needed
to take a pool lining is the easiest and
fastest way to get started with Terraria
mining in this you walk along with other
people together in a single pool and if
someone from the pool gets the hash code
correctly they share the reward among
everyone in the pool
we should consider a few important
factors before joining a pool like room
size minimum payout and pool fees
full size determines the number of
blocks you find in the ethereum network
and it shares the word as the number of
miners increases the chances to get
reward also increase
minimum payout is the minimum amount of
Italian you need to mine before it gets
credited to your wallet and pool key is
the amount you need to pay to continue
using the pool
this amount is percentage based on the
amount of ethereum your mining
it's adding Cloud mining you pay someone
else with the equipment to mine ethereum
for you you pay some amount of money as
keys to them for investing their time
and resources
and in return they provide you with the
reward the gain by the mining materials
this this technique of mining ethereum
has to pros and cons too so you're not
responsible for any equipment damage you
don't have to acquire all the necessary
equipment and look for ample space to
store it
you can set back of the market and enjoy
the reward for your investment in
interior mining
cons in the Italian price drop then
there is no way you are getting your
money back the money you invested or the
fees to pay to The Miner is not
and you can't ask the other person to
change the equipment according to your
concern
the theater in Cloud mining is
considered a safer way for mining
service provider the guarantee a profit
for the resource they have purchased
now let's understand how the ethereum
mining process works
a trading mining follows a specific set
of steps to function
step one a user request for transaction
with the help of the private key office
digital monitor down
then the request is shared worldwide
with the ethereum network
next the requested transaction is added
to a list of pinning transactions that
that needs to be added to the ethereum
blockchain network
Step 2 The Miner then verifies and
validates the requested transaction and
perform a complex mathematical person on
the transactional data
step 5 once the request transaction is
verified and its choose a copy of it in
area in the process of inform work
Begins for the respective block
step 6 when the notes of the ethereum
network verify how the checksum of the
state of the miners Block matches the
checksum of the updated state of events
after execution of all transactions
step 7 only after that the block is
added to the ethereum blockchain network
set in on successfully mining the block
it rewards The Miner with some amount of
ether in their wallet the block reward
of ethereum is three ether
at step 9 the requested processing is
approved and credited to the respective
wallet or wallet
whose transaction is mined only one with
every participant of the ethereum
network verifies it
this makes me curious about how to mine
ethereum
tools you will need to be a sufficient
Miner for ethereum on your personal
computer are an attack on wallet is
stored all your currency all
GPU driver or graphics card with a
minimum of 3gb RAM
a mining software suitable according to
your Hardware like GPU
and a compatible operating system a
Windows 7 or 10 with 64 bit
before getting started with mining
Italian you need to create an ethereum
wallet to store all your info press
module T and Ledger Nano are the most
reliable and secure walls in the market
of cryptocurrency
installing GPU drivers or graphics card
after trading your digital wallet the
need to update all the hardware
that is drives in a system you can use
two types of graphics card they are AMD
graphics card and Nvidia graphics card
Claymore is considered the best
profitable mining ethereum on GPU
drivers
now we need to follow a few
set of step to get started with mining
Step 1 download the latest version of
Claymore dual Miner for the operating
system the latest version is Claymore
11.0
Step 2 click on the latest version of
Windows and download the zip file
step 3 extract the file to Claymore
11.0 to a folder on desktop for easy
access
open the folder to have a look at the
files
step 5 right click on start and then on
the edit option
step 6 edit the start.exe file and add
these lines
step 7 choose your desired pool from
these recommendations
you can also find better sources than
these according to your region
step eight tighten your full address
instead of mining pool address
step 9 say you start the pxt file within
new updates remember while saving select
type as all files
and set 10 once you save click on the
clay.bat file to begin mining ethereum
now let's expose with the proof of State
transition field group of work
the newly introduced concept of ethereum
2.0 the roadmaps plans to upgrade to
proof of State consensus algorithm in
which it will provide all existing
miners with ethereum network with a
limited time to earn a return for the
investment
this expected to be launched by the end
of 2021 or the starting or 2022
supposed to be launched by October 2020
with the history of delays regarding
this update is worth talking about
nobody through notes when ethereum 2.0
will be completed and introduced to the
crypto mining world
now when we know all about Italian night
mining this makes me wonder if Italian
mining is profitable
the profit of any crypto mining majorly
depends on the cost of electricity in
that particular area as a rule anything
below 0.12 per kilowatt consumes in an
hour is considered profitable you can
mine either and turn it into a vital
source of income by analyzing these
figures like hash rate of ethereum
blocked reward number of blocks per day
and the coin price of ethereum
do they also use an iterating calculator
to figure out the daily revenue basing
it on these factors or you can use this
formula too
the predictions are made that the
ethereum price can rise and become more
stable in the coming few years so it is
an excellent opportunity to invest in
and Save in ethereum in this video we're
going to cover all important Concepts
and components related to proof of work
first we will have a quick introduction
of blockchain and then we will
understand what is proof of work then we
will look into how it works and after
that we will explore why it is actually
needed
what are the issues faced by proof of
work and last we will look into the
blockchains working with proof of work
so without further delay let's get
started with the video but before that
let's have a quick introduction to
blockchain
the term blockchain refers to a
decentralized database that is made up
of sequential blocks that contain
recorded data the database is backed up
by a network of self-contained
participants known as nodes
now let's understand what is proof of
work
proof of work is a decentralized
consensus method that requires Network
participants to spend time solving an
arbitrary mathematical puzzle in order
to prevent the system from being hacked
it is widely used in cryptocurrency
mining for validating transactions and
Mining new tokens
it helps in the processing of
peer-to-peer transactions securely
without the need of a trusted third
party
it also requires huge amounts of energy
at scale which only increases as more
miners join the network
now let's have a look at how proof of
work works
the right to add new blocks to a
proof-of-work blockchain is provided to
individuals who are willing to expand
computational resources to solve
cryptographic issues
the participants competing to add new
blocks are referred to as minors and the
process is referred to as mining miners
are the ones who execute proof of work
miners use their computational power to
locate a valid block when a piece of
information such as a transaction needs
to be added to the blockchain this is
accomplished by locating a hash that
meets the network protocol specific
requirements in cryptography a hash is
the outcome of a hash function it
converts any format or size of data into
fixed size numbers
the protocol established a level of
mining difficulty that is
algorithmically adjusted so that the
time it takes to obtain a proper hash
averages about 10 minutes
miners can sometimes locate multiple
blocks that satisfy the protocol's
requirements at the same time and split
the chain in two
well because there can only be one
accurate chain the protocol must account
for these circumstances miners will
initially continue to mine on both
chains but once another block is
discovered on top of one of the two
prior blocks that chain becomes the
canonical chain and miners are
economically incentivized to discard the
other blocks
now one of the advantages of proof of
work blockchain in terms of security is
their resilience to civil attacks a
civil attack occurs when one player in
the network generates many false
identities in order to get an unfair
advantage over other network
participants who only have one identity
51 percent attacks occur when a single
user takes control of more than 51
percent of the Network's resources and
hence has control over the adding of new
blocks
well now we know how proof of work Works
let's dive down deeper and explore why
do we need proof of work
so majorly proof of work is required for
security and fraud prevention as well as
Trust
proof of work is intended to prevent
users from printing coins they didn't
earn or from double spending
if users could spend their coins more
than once the currency would effectively
become worthless proof of work ensures
that independent data processors or
miners can't lie about a transaction
linking a block with the proof of work
hash of its predecessor results in
tamper resistance because the hash of
each block is an ingredient in the hash
of the following block any changes in
the chain will affect the final proof of
work hash as well as all Block hashes in
between so the deeper the altered block
the more computational effort needed for
tampering
the first Miner who discovers the proof
of work answers publishes the solution
to the rest of the network and when a
new block is discovered all nodes are
notified we check the answer twice
before moving on to the next block
and PS if correct the block miners earn
the transaction fees and the block
reward
the protocol only accepts the longest
chain as valid and authentic a fake
chain is Impractical in the long run
since the minus chances of receiving the
block reward are minimal other miners
will continue to extend the valid chain
quicker than the tampered chain over
time
so moving on let's have a look at the
other side of the coin as well as
understand some of the major issues with
proof of work
first it has a negative impact on the
environment second the 51 attack can be
used against it if miners gain control
of 51 percent of the hashing power they
will be able to determine what is true
aside from the enormous cost of price
there is no mechanism in place to punish
any malicious miners
and fourth because every node must
process every transaction it does not
scale properly while shortening the
network May boost efficiency it also
reduces security
and this was all about proof of work
let's explore the best blockchain
networks working with proof of work
Bitcoin is the largest and the very
first blockchain to adopt proof of work
and work with it ethereum is next
working with proof of work though it is
aiming to switch to proof of stake which
we will talk about in a coming video
then comes Bitcoin cash which is an
extension of Bitcoin and follows the
same structure thus it also works on
proof of work and then comes Litecoin
which is also an altcoin of Bitcoin and
then comes Monero another cryptocurrency
serving similar purposes as other
cryptos so let's get started and
understand what is a smart contract
what's in it for us today let's
understand why do we need a smart
contract what is a smart contract usage
of solidity for building smart contract
advantages of smart contract blockchain
implementation of smart contracts we'll
look at certain examples of voting and
digital token and also we will take
another use case of how smart contract
help us do crowdfunding now why smart
contract now let's take a look
traditionally how contracts used to
happen if suppose two parties A and B
have to get into a contract they will
utilize the services of a third party
whom they have to trust and get the
contract executed now with the
introduction of smart contracts and the
technology which is evolving removes the
dependency on such third parties and
automates the execution of such smart
tracks so if we compare traditional
versus the new smart contract in
traditional we used to have governments
lawyers or any other third party on
which we can trust in smart contracts we
don't need any third party we don't need
any intermediate execution time
definitely there is higher execution
time in traditional contracts because as
many number of middlemen's and their
intermediary layers that many number of
days and time it takes smart contract is
just a matter of minutes it gets
executed because it is automated
programmable running on a computer and
it has some predefined condition
remittance if any remittance of either
of the parties have to happen then it's
a manual process approvals workflows
processes
and these manual processes take time
under traditional Contracting system but
in a smart contract as the conditions
are predefined pre-embedded as soon as a
condition is met the remittance happens
automatically either of the parties who
have to be credited with an amount is
credited automatically and that is the
primary advantage of using a smart
contract transparency
is not available 100 in traditional
contracts the transparency is bound
peripheral between the parties and the
entities and the intermediaries involved
as compared to Smart contract
transparency is 100 available 24x7
online anyone can go and review audit
and validate the transactions executed
by the smart contracts archiving
archiving is a big difficult problem for
traditional contracts as most of the
transactions are paper-based or the
records are maintained offline it
becomes very difficult to maintain and
identify the traceability provenance of
all the transactions which have happened
in a traditional contract whereby in a
smart contract it becomes easy as all
the transactions have happened through
the smart contract there's a hundred
percent traceability available from the
provenance point of view you can trace
the transaction from its day one the
point of origin till present day And
archiving is automatically happening the
log the audit the transaction history is
automatic vertically getting generated
security definitely is a concern in
traditional contracts as the
intermediaries and involved manual
processes involved security can be
compromised at any level at any stage
but in a smart contract the security is
maintained through cryptography mainly
through public key infrastructure the
public and private key infrastructure it
is a very secure way of maintaining
security and cryptography of the
transactions using a smart contract cost
yes traditional contracts are expensive
the cost of transaction is high as
compared to Smart contracts as the
middlemans are involved smart contract
the cost is low as we don't have any
intermediaries and only the cost of
transaction is charged by the underlying
infrastructure of the blockchain network
which is running the smart contract
signatures its manual process all the
transactions are signed manually and
verified manually but here in the smart
contracts all the transactions are
digitally signed using the private key
of the entities and can only be decoded
by the public key shared by the parties
involved in the smart contract so in a
nutshell smart contracts give us n
number of advantages the primary
advantages are listed here and these are
the advantages which enforce us to move
towards an economy and to a system where
we start using smart contracts for our
transactions to avoid any disputes to
keep the transaction costs low thereby
giving the advantage to the end consumer
now what is a smart contract let's
consider a real life example where you
are taking out a chocolate from a
vending machine you deposit a two dollar
note in a vending machine after that you
hit A1 button which is mapped against
the chocolate bar that you want to buy
as a result a lever in the vending
machine moves and pushes out the
chocolate so basically even button is
programmed to the lever in order to move
the chocolate out now a smart contract
is very similar to a vending machine it
eliminates the need of an intermediary
in case of the vending machine is
replacing a direct seller and allowing
you to make a purchase without a
middleman and it only minutes in need of
Escrow Services now smart contracts are
self-executing contract which contain
the terms and conditions of an agreement
between the parties and the peers who
are involved in the technology so the
terms and conditions of an agreement are
written in a piece of code and it is
executed on a blockchain based
decentralized platform now these
agreements facilitates exchange of any
digital asset it could be digital
currency it could be shares it could be
property or it could be anything which
you want to transact so a blockchain
based decentralized platform gives you a
democratic system where the transactions
are authorized by the majority of the
participants and the identity of the
participants is also kept Anonymous now
let's consider an example where ritual
is at the airport and her flight is
delayed but this inconvenience could
have been beneficial to Rachel as smart
contract insurance would ensure she is
given a compensation for the flight's
delay instantly so just imagine there is
a smart contract which the insurance
company has already deployed and it's
monitoring the flight's delay Rachel has
already taken that insurance for delay
in flights so as soon as that condition
is met for a delay of flight above x
amount of hours for example two hours
then in that case the insurance company
will automatically get the trigger and
ritual will be credited with that amount
for which he is insured in her account
so let's see how smart contract can be
helpful here so AXA flight delay
insurance is one of the examples of
ethereum smart contract AXA is an
insurance company the smart contract is
linked to the databases that record
flight status so that smart contract is
connected to the databases it is
fetching that information and evaluating
the delay it enables automatic
compensation when there is a delay for
two hours or more so that is the
condition when the flight delay is
Beyond two hours then the insurance
contract will get executed and Rachel
will be get paid so a smart contract is
created based on the terms and
conditions so condition compensation is
equal to flight delay is less than two
hours based on the code smart contract
holds the company's money until a
certain condition is satisfied this
smart contract is submitted to the nodes
on the blockchain network to their EVMS
for evaluation so evm is a runtime
compiler to execute smart contracts code
it is the brain it is the electronic
virtual machine which executes the smart
contract all nodes on the network
executing the code using the evm must
come to the same result because all the
EVMS would have the same copy of the
smart contract deployed so if the flight
is delayed two or more hours smart
contract will be self-executed and the
compensation amount will be given to
Rachel and that is the objective of the
smart contract without involvement of
any middleman paperwork which ritual has
to do to submit and then the insurance
company going going through the manual
process all that has been bypassed and
ritual has been compensated directly now
let's understand why do we need solidity
for developing our smart contracts now
here comes the important question which
programming language does a smart
contract use there are two widely used
programming languages for writings
ethereum smart contracts solidity and
serpent however on blockchain platforms
solidity is widely used for implementing
smart contracts and this is what we were
going to talk about in our subsequent
slides now solidity is a high level
programming language used for
implementing smart contracts it enables
to check the program at runtime rather
than compile time solidity is a touring
complete language it has all the
conditions all the while Loops for Rook
operators
Etc which are there in any matured
programming language in order to write
your code in order to write your
conditions if you have certain Loop if
you have while conditions Etc now what
are the advantages of smart contract as
we have already discussed there are no
intermediaries involved the process
executes without the need of a third
party it's an automated process they are
automated with the code which eliminates
manual effort for execution it's a high
speed highly computive smart contracts
which runs on programming code the speed
of its execution is higher than a
traditional contract as the data is
stored in the decentralized system the
chances of modifying the data is
difficult and I would say more than
impossible accuracy based on the
requirements terms and condition of a
contract is recorded accurately so as
soon as any transaction is recorded it
is registered on a blockchain network
and it is immutable transaction no one
can modify or make changes in any record
which has been added onto a blockchain
network through a smart contract now
let's take a look at certain blockchain
implementation of a smart contract using
blockchain in voting process can
eliminate voting malpractices a
centralized voting system faces a lot of
problems when it comes to tracking votes
there could be manipulated identities
they could be manipulation in counting
there could be biased decision making a
smart contract is introduced to
eliminate all these malpractices there
are certain predefined terms and
conditions which are already set in the
contract no voter can vote from a
digital identity of any other voter the
counting is full proof every vote is
registered on a blockchain network and
the accounting is happening
automatically without any interference
from a third party or dependency on a
manual process so terms and condition
each ID should be attributed to just one
vote the validation is done by the users
on the blockchain network itself so the
voting process can be in a public
blockchain or it could be in a
decentralized autonomous organization
based blockchain setup also but it is
100 transparent and every voting
transaction is recorded result world
every voters won't get recorded on The
Ledger and that information cannot be
modified it is transparently publicly
available for audit and verification now
let's take a look at one of the examples
of our voting solidity contract so here
we have our voting solidity contract it
is built in solidity and I'll just give
you a brief overview of what are the
primary functions in this so if we look
at this particular contract this
contract gives you certain basic
parameters like what should be the
minimum number of participants or
proposals which are required for voting
then what should be the minimum amount
of time for debate that needs to pass
before the vote can be executed then the
margin of votes for majority a proposal
passes if there are more than 50 of the
votes plus the margin so basically we
are defining what is the winning
condition what is the majority margin
for any word to be accepted then you
have data structure where you are
accepting the proposals right and then
subsequently we are defining data
structures for members who are
participating in the proposals who are
submitting the proposals we are fetching
the addresses of the members basically
this is the digital identity of the
members who are submitting the proposals
and Etc so this smart contracts
basically allows you to create a voting
system where you can add members we can
remove the members you can change
certain voting rules based on certain
conditions like if you want to increase
the minimum Quorum if you want to change
the debating period minutes or the
majority rule changes then this is a
function for submitting a new proposal
for which the voting has to happen so
basically this example is about if I
have to take a vote within a
decentralized autonomous Organization
for a particular decision so rather than
a central Authority taking a decision
you can have a voting mechanism within
your organization to give a majority to
your proposal if you get them Authority
The Proposal is accepted otherwise
reject then there are peripheral
functions like check proposal code then
there is a voting function the actual
vote happens and for a particular
proposal you start increasing or
decreasing the number of votes then you
execute the proposal if the majority has
been achieved now let's take a look on
how to deploy a smart contract so here
we have our voting smart contract now we
will take a look on how to deploy our
voting smart contract on the ethereum
test Network called robston this is our
voting smart contract now when you open
remix you should also have metamask
which is a chrome plugin installed this
is a utility in order to connect to the
robsten test net which is a ethereum
test Network so basically you say
robson.etherscan.io and this is the
ethereum test Network on which we will
deploy our contract so once you log in
into the metamask you will have a
account created and in that account you
should have have some test ethers
already so that you can use them to
deploy your contract so when you create
an account on robsten you can buy
certain ethers using the robsten test
faucet
so when you reach this site the option
test faucet has already taken the
address for the account for which you
are raising the request and you can
raise request of one ether now whenever
this transaction will get processed your
account balance will get incremented by
one so as I already have ethers in it I
can utilize it to deploy my contract now
in order to compile and deploy my
contract I have copy pasted it here and
if I go to my run My remix has already
communicated via injected web3 to the
metamask and take in my account which
has 7.83 ether
now I need to do some settings
now as my contract is compiled you can
see it has taken all the contracts you
can see the drop down and Congress is my
major contract now I will deploy my
contract so on the Run section you will
be able to see in the drop down the name
of the contracts which are there in my
smart contract like I had owned token
recipient then there's an interface and
there is a congress so I need to deploy
my Congress contract now in order to
deploy this contract there is a
Constructor which requires certain
inputs so I can give certain values like
what minimum number of proposals I need
800 then minimum number of debates 10
and margin of votes for majority so I
say deploy now as soon as I'll click
deploy it is going to request me for gas
because when the contract gets deployed
it will deduct certain ethers from my
account so when I'll say submit
if you notice now this transaction has
got initiated on the robsten
etherscan.io I click on it so this is
the transaction on which the contract is
getting deployed it is taking time and
the contract is getting processed on the
ethereum network now once it will get
deployed we will be able to see the
address at which the contract has got
created and deployed now as you can see
my contract has got deployed at the
address 0xcc I can load it now this is
the contract address and this is the
amount of actual ether which was spent
from my account in order to deploy the
contract
now there are certain attributes on the
option ether scan which you can go and
check you can verify and publish your
smart contract over here so that others
can also view the code and utilize your
smart contract and if you go and check
your meta mask this is the transaction
which has just been done in your account
and if you click it will take you to the
same transaction which we opened here
now after you have deployed the contract
you can interact with your contract
directly through remix just to test your
contract all the pink members are the
ones which make changes onto the
blockchain and all the blue ones are the
ones which are only performing read
operations so in order to do any read
operation you will not be requested to
spend any gas so there will be no
pop-ups for metamask requesting for gas
spending but if you do any of these pink
actions then you will be required to
spend gas as it will be requiring to
make some changes onto the block so this
was a example of a voting smart contract
and this will be available as a link for
you to take a look now all our other
contracts which we will be covering
subsequently will be deployed in a
similar Fashion on the Robson test net
now let's check another example if you
want to use Smart contract to issue your
own cryptocurrency or called digital
token you can use ethereum based smart
contract to create your own digital
tokens for performing transactions in
design and issue your own digital
currency create a tradable computerized
token that can be utilized as a currency
share or any asset which you want to
transact these tokens use a standard
coin API like in case of ethereum we
have standardizations of erc20 Etc which
allows contract to automatically access
any wallet for exchange as a result you
build a tradable token with a suffix
Supply and this particular platform
becomes a like a central bank issuing a
digital money your smart contract
becomes the bank issuing the money so
let's take this example here so this is
a implementation of a erc20 token which
is a specification by ethereum and the
primary attribute for this token is that
you need to provide a name of your token
a symbol the decimals to which you
support and the most primary is the
predefined supply so just like in an
economy you have limited supply of money
here also you have to Define what will
be the supply of your tokens and it will
be capped that will be the supply so you
need to predefine these parameters and
then you create certain data structures
within solidity to keep a tap on the
balances of the entities to which you
are giving the tokens and how much
allowance you want to keep per address
then there are certain methods which you
have to implement as per the erc20
specification like transfer transfer
from from approve and Call
Etc so all these methods in a typical
token allows you to do the transaction
send and receive your custom token among
multiple parties so this would also be
available as a link for you to take a
look now let's take another example of
our use case for crowdfunding using
smart contracts to crowdfund your
project so suppose you want to start a
business and for a business you need a
lot of funding which is required but who
would lend it money to someone whom they
don't trust how will you generate that
money for such problems smart contract
plays a major role with ethereum you can
build a smart contract that will hold a
contributor's fronts unless a given date
or a goal is met based on the result the
funds will be released to the contract
owners or will be sent back to the
contributors so basically you can create
a crowdfunding project for yourself if
you want to raise certain amount of
money and the contributors or the
investors will give you the money but
the amount will be kept on hold till the
time your project goal or date has been
met and accordingly the investor will
get you the token which you have
developed for crowdfunding in us or his
account accordingly now centralized
crowdfunding system has plenty of issues
with Management Systems so therefore a
dow a decentralized autonomous
organization is utilized for
crowdfunding the terms and conditions
are transparently set in the contract
every individual participating in the
crowd funding is given a token and the
token is credited to their ethereum
based account now every contribution
gets recorded on the blockchain because
then the token transfer has happened
from the Dow to the individual investor
that transaction get recorded on the
blockchain network so let's quickly take
a look at the contract for a crowd sale
also so a crowd sale contract provides
you the basic attributes like what is
the goal of the funding how much money
you need to raise what is the amount
raised real-time name you can keep a
track what is the deadline right and
what is the price of the token in
ethereum basically what is the your
token amount in ethereum then there
could be that you might give certain
tokens in reward then you can have
attributes for your reward and then you
have your methods in order to keep a
check that once you have received the
funds you can withdraw the funds you can
check whether you have reached the goal
for funding and then you have the
methods for transferring tokens from the
sender to your own account
particular kind of contract allows you
to maintain and keep a check on amount
of funding you have received or you want
to receive have you achieved your target
who are the investors in your token how
much percentage share belongs to your
account and how much percentage share
has been already been distributed all
amongst the investors Etc so everything
can be tracked so their smart contract
can build in such a fashion that there
are methods and utilities available in
order to run your entire crowdfunding
deploying smart contracts on a private
ethereum Network
objectives by the end of this lesson you
should be able to set up private
ethereum blockchain
write solidity programming codes
develop and deploy smart contracts on
ethereum test Network
build and ethereum-based property
transfer application
create a Marketplace application on
ethereum network
private ethereum Network
steps to develop private blockchain
all right let's understand the steps
involved in developing a private
blockchain
the setting up of private blockchain can
be done on Windows or Mac by either
downloading the virtual machine and
installing Linux operating system on it
or it can be done through AWS or Azure
cloud storage the steps and methods are
common in both the options
users using Windows operating system can
follow these steps without AWS or Azure
cloud storage
you need to install Geth for the
operating system
you need to configure a Genesis block
you need to initialize the private
Network
create new accounts create an autonomous
private blockchain
before we actually set up a private
blockchain let's understand what is a
Genesis block
Genesis block Genesis block is defined
as the start of the blockchain it is the
first block of the blockchain network
and the only block without a predecessor
the first block has a file called
genesis.json which is the file that
comprises of the settings for your
blockchain the main parameters used in
the block are config difficulty gas
limit and alloc
these are the important specifications
that are used in genesis.json
config it is the main blockchain
configuration and contains many
properties which include chain ID this
is the chain identifier it is an integer
used to protect against replay attack
replay attack includes the process of
accessing the network without an
authentication Network tapping poisoning
the network in order to get the details
and providing malware as the victim to
the computer
the other properties such as Homestead
block and EIP 155 block are added to the
configuration Network for connection to
the main Network
Homestead is the second major release of
ethereum the value 0 means that you are
using the said release
Epi 155 block
Epi stands for ethereum improvement
proposal where developers propose ideas
on how to improve ethereum and
contribute to this project
alloc this is used to allocate eth to an
address which served as pre-funded
accounts
coinbase this is also known as etherbase
it is the default primary account
initially a warning message will be
provided if the value is not set
properly difficulty this shows how
difficult it is to mine a block so for a
private blockchain it is better to set
the value to a low number to ensure
blocks are mined quickly
extra data it is set to default as per
the client version if it is not provided
explicitly
gas limit this provides the maximum
amount of gas that can be used in each
block higher the value more are the
transactions that can be used in the
block
mix hash it is set to zero if it is a
new private Network
parent hash it is set to zero it is not
needed for a new private Network
private ethereum Network all right
let's set up a private ethereum private
ethereum node follow the command I am
executing in my terminal this setup is
an Ubuntu setup
execute the following command in the
terminal to set up ethereum
the command will start reading packages
and installed in my machines it is
already installed hence the message is
showing software properties common is
already the newest version okay let's
execute the next command the following
command is to download the latest stable
ethereum repository to your sources list
there you see it has imported public key
PPA for ethereum
now we'll update and install ethereum on
machine execute the following commands
it will start fetching packages wait for
some time while it is reading packages
list
now finally type the following command
to install ethereum
now we have to create a directory
here let's say I create a directory
named private chain
I'll execute the command
mkdir private chain
this is the directory where all your
ethereum files will be stored
let's type LS to check the director we
created
now type the command
chmod 777 private chain
this is to give 777 privilege to your
directory now let's create an ethereum
account run this command GIF and make
sure you mentioned the directory in
which you just created henceforth all
your command will have the mention of
that directory through data dear command
here I run Geth hyphen data dear private
chain Dev account new
there it will create a new account you
get a message which says your account is
locked with password give it a password
and it will display the address of the
account
similarly we will create another account
great so far we have created two
accounts now use list command if you
want to see the list
there it will show you both the accounts
with respective addresses
once you have your accounts created it's
time to create your public blockchain
let's go inside the directory we created
earlier
as you know the first block is Genesis
block so to start a blockchain you need
to create a Genesis block so type emacs
genesisblock dot Json
here you're creating a Json file which
you're going to add to your Genesis
block which will be your first
transaction in the Genesis block for
Genesis file you need to have certain
attributes
the first thing it needs is knots nonce
indicates the complexity behind the
computation of block
next one is difficulty it defines the
level of difficulty in mining the block
then there is alloc here
you will mention the account address you
created and you will assign some ether
to it
mix hash this field is similar to nonce
combined with nonce it shows the
difficulty of network coinbase contains
the account address of the miner who
created this block
next is the time stamp which contains
the time of the operating system when
this block was created in this case it
will be Unix time
parent hash contains the hash of the
previous block
since this is the first block there is
no block before this hence the value is
going to be all zero
extra data is optional any 32-bit data
can be added here the last attribute is
gas limit
it is the gas limit of the block
all right let's add values to these
attributes now
since this is Genesis block I have kept
the nonce to all zeros
keep the difficulty low and in the
allocation enter the account address as
you just created and assign some ether
to those account addresses
in case you don't remember those account
addresses you can run account list
command
copy the address from the directory and
paste it in the Outlook and add some
balances to it
copy another address and add some
balance to it as well
mix hash you want to keep it simple so
just add 256 bit all zeros
coinbase will also be all zeros
likewise add values to the attributes as
I am doing it
finally save the file now you can use a
Genesis block and Seed a private
blockchain
run this command to initialize the
Genesis block if you get error message
like I've got here open the Genesis file
and correct the error and save the file
execute the command again
there you go the private blockchain is
created with the Genesis file added to
the first block that is the Genesis
block
now go to the directory you created
under this subdirectory GIF you will
find two subfolders chain data and light
chain data
this indicates that your private
blockchain network has been created
now when you mine the block you will see
dot ldb file added to the chain data
folder alright without any further delay
let's start mining
we're going to mine the blocks in the
private blockchain
run this command
there you go the mining has started
it will take some time to mine the first
block and while it is mining you will
add some ethers to your account the
account which will be used for mining
will be your first account you will find
The Ether balance will keep going up
the mining May last long this will
depend on the attributes set in the
Genesis file here's what you can do if
your system stops mining just go to the
chain data folder and you will see the
dot ldb file
great so that's how you create private
ethereum blockchain and mine the
blockchain then you can check the
balances in the account let me give you
a quick recap of the steps I had
followed Step 1 execute the following
command in the terminal to set up
ethereum
Step 2 execute the following command to
download the latest stable ethereum
repository to your sources list
step 3 execute the following command to
create new ethereum account to run smart
contracts and transactions
step 4 Create genesis.json file and
configure the file with the blockchain
parameters execute the following command
step 5. execute the following command to
initialize the Genesis file
step 6 execute the following command to
start the mining process
step 7 execute the following command to
stop the mining process
ethereum smart contracts
smart contract lifecycle here's how the
life cycle looks like the solidity code
is compiled to a byte code and is
deployed to the network of nodes
referred to as a blockchain network the
deployed code can be interacted with by
calling the contract using the
contract's address
the code can be compiled using a
compiler Like Remix IDE the compiled
code generates the byte code and
Abstract binary interface the abstract
binary interface contains all of the
arguments used in the code
a combination of bytecode and Abstract
binary interface is deployed on the
network which can then execute the same
let's look at the Smart contract
development process to start with the
smart contract
smart contract development
in order to start the process first
create The Logical program and save the
file using a DOT Sol extension
pass the solidity file to the solidity
compiler where the compiler compiles the
solidity source code and converts it
into a bytecode
the byte code is used to invoke
deployment using web3js Library function
through which the deployment takes place
onto the private ethereum blockchain
Additionally the smart contract stores
the ABI abstract binary interface and
the contract address the ABI is a DOT
Json file that describes the deployed
contract and its functions it allows us
to contextualize the contract and call
its functions the address and the ABI of
the contract are passed to initiate the
contract along with the parameters to
call the contract methods lastly its
signs and passes either to perform the
operation and gets deployed inside
private ethereum blockchain Network
so the first thing you need to learn for
the deployment is the programming
language in our course we will teach you
solidity programming language
smart contract development environment
let's set up a smart contract
development environment which will help
you create and deploy smart contracts
effectively on ethereum test Network
we are going to use simply learns Cloud
lab for this setup for those of you who
don't know about the lab let me show you
how to access it
go to simplylearns LMS and select
blockchain developer training
click on the labs tab on the left panel
of the LMS
copy or note the username and password
that is generated click on launch lab
button
on the page that appears enter the
username and password in the respective
fields and click login
there it is your Ubuntu virtual
environment is ready to be used let me
open the lab in the separate tab for a
better View
click on ganache icon on the home screen
once it gets Open click settings icon
and change the port number to 85.45
click save and restart button
ganache will get refreshed and restart
if you look up the RC server it is
running on Port 8545
now let me open the browser
the lab has pre-installed Chromium
browser
in the browser I have metamask Chrome
extension already installed
I'll just insert the password to open my
metamask plugin
there it is if you can see my metamask
is connected to Port 8545 which means my
metamask is synced to ganache
hence I can import some accounts from
ganache let me just show you how it's
done
I'll click on import account and then
I'll go to my ganache and copy the
private key of one of the 10 accounts
now back in metamask
click import account place the private
key in the field and click import
the respective account gets imported in
the metamask with a predefined 100
ethers
now we need a code editor you can use
any code editor in which you're
comfortable with
I'm going to use remix IDE here
since it is a web-based IDE I'll open it
in a browser
I'll search for remix IDE in the browser
and open the first link
there you see the remix IDE which comes
with pre-written sample solidity code
I'll just select the injected web 3
environment and hit deploy button to
deploy this sample contract
soon the metamask notification pop-up
asking for confirmation click confirm
button and the contract gets deployed on
localhost
hence you can use this setup to create
test and deploy smart contract on local
machine
let me give you a quick recap of the
steps now
Step One open ganache changes port to 85
45 and restart
Step 2 open metamask and import an
account from ganache
step 3 open remix IDE and set the
environment to injected web 3. step 4
write a contract and click deploy
step five click confirm button in the
metamask pop-up to confirm the
transaction
solidity programming
introduction to solidity solidity is a
programming language used for ethereum
smart contracts it is also referred to
as object oriented high-level language
the syntax of the solidity is similar to
JavaScript
the main purpose of solidity is to
enhance ethereum virtual machine evm
solidity is a statically typed
programming language thus every variable
in solidity needs to be explicitly
defined with the type of variable for
instance
string bull
int
Etc in solidity processes are verified
at compile time
comparison between memory and storage in
solidity
before understanding solidity it is
important to know about memory and
storage in solidity
memory
memory is a byte array which holds the
data in it till the execution of a
function
memory starts with zero size and can be
expanded to 32 bytes by accessing or
storing memory greater than the current
size memory can be shrinked to keep the
gas price as low thus it is used to hold
temporary values it is erased between
external function calls and is cheaper
to use
storage this is a persistent memory that
every account has in its storage
storage is a key Value Store where keys
and values are both 32 bytes all the
contracts State variables reside in
storage it is persistent between
function calls and quite expensive to
use
layout of a solidity smart contract
a solidity file is composed of the
following four high-level details pragma
comments import
contracts Library interface
source files can contain contract
definitions including directives and
pragma directives
pragma this is the first line of the
code within the solidity file it is a
directive that specifies the compiler
version that the solidity file uses for
example pragma solidity carrot
0.4.19 means that the code is compatible
with version
0.4.19 and lower
it is a good practice to mention the
pragma directive in the first line of
the code
comments all the programming languages
provide the facility to comment
solidity also has the same options like
single line comments multi-line comments
General value types solidity also has
variables that refers to storage
location which can contain values these
values can be changed during runtime
there are two types of variables State
variables and memory variables General
value types are passed by values
State variables variables declared in a
contract that are not within any
function are called State variables they
are the current values of the contract
solidity also provides some data types
that are used in other programming
language
arrays
arrays are referred to as data types but
to be more specific they are data
structures that are dependent on other
data types arrays are always referred to
as group of values of same data type
solidity provides Rich array constructs
which are used to store the value run
iterations sort data and search
individual or subset of elements arrays
in solidity can be fixed or dynamic
fixed arrays these arrays have a
predetermined size mentioned during its
declaration the fixed arrays cannot be
initialized using the new keyword they
can only be initialized in line an
example of the fixed array is integer
Open Bracket 5 close bracket age equals
Open Bracket integer 10 in parentheses
comma 20 comma 30 comma 40 comma 50
close bracket semicolon Dynamic arrays
these arrays do not have a predetermined
size at time of Declaration but their
size is determined at runtime an example
of a dynamic array is integer brackets
age semicolon double slash array of
integer with no fixed storage space
allocated there are some special arrays
used in solidity like byte array string
array
these arrays contain the corresponding
variable types of data
arrays example code the example on the
screen shows a sample code for the
concept of array we learned in the
previous Slide the example shows a
contract defined as array example which
contains multiple arrays of different
types as covered in the previous slide
enums
enums are value types that consist of
predefined list of constant values
they are passed by values and each copy
maintains its own value enums cannot be
declared within functions instead they
are declared within the global namesake
of the construct the predefined
constants are assigned consecutively
increasing integer value from zero enums
are one way to create a user-defined
type in solidity they are explicitly
convertible to and from all integer
types but implicit conversion is not
allowed
enum's example code
the example on the screen shows a sample
code for the concept of enums we learned
in the previous Slide the example shows
a contract defined as test which
contains an enum called action choices
with elements like go left go right go
straight and sit still
structs
a struct in solidity is a custom defined
type that can group several variables
the struct comprises of a name and
Associated properties are placed inside
the struct
the struct can comprise of similar or
different data types all placed inside
the same definition
the maximum number of variables inside a
struct is 16. however one can Define one
struct inside another struct in order to
increase the variables
mapping in solidity
mapping is referred to a hash table that
consists of key type and value type
pairs
mapping is defined like any other
variable type
mappings are declared using the mapping
keyword followed by data types for both
key and value and separated by equal to
or greater than notation
it is similar to a hash table and
dictionary
solidity does not allow iterating
through mapping a value from mapping can
be retrieved if the key is known mapping
are declared as mapping underscore key
type equal to or greater than
underscore value type
underscore key type can be any type
except for a dynamically sized array a
contract an enum and a struct
underscore value type can be any type
including mappings
example code of mapping
the example on the screen shows a sample
code for the concept of mapping we
learned in the previous Slide the
example shows a contract defined as my
contract which contains a hash map which
Maps an unsigned integer to a structure
function declaration
a function can be declared as pure in
which it promises not to read from or
modify the state the return type of the
function cannot be empty
if the function does not return the
whole contract it will be omitted
the function can also be declared with
view in which they can be used for
entirely viewing the state variables
the particular value can be returned
instead of the whole contract
the examples shown here on the slide is
of function declaration using pure and
view keywords
function calls and return types
in the example code above you can note
that the name of the contract and the
name of the function is the same this is
called a Constructor in solidity if you
wanted to ensure that a particular
function in the contract should be
executed before any other function you
can Define it using the same name as
that of the contract such a function
will be the first one to be executed
this is defined as a Constructor
this is a continuation of the previous
slide
fallback function
the fallback function is a special type
of function available only in ethereum
solidity helps in writing fallback
functions a fallback function is invoked
when no function name matches the called
function
the fallback function does not have an
identifier or function name it is
defined without a name and doesn't
accept any arguments or return any value
function modifiers modifiers are another
concept unique to solidity modifiers
help in modifying the behavior of a
function the code Remains the Same but
the execution path of the function
changes
modifiers can only be applied to
functions thus modifiers enable you to
control the behavior of your smart
contract
function modifiers example code the
example shows the use of a function
modifier
inheritance
solidity supports multiple inheritances
in the form of copying code which
includes polymorphism
inheritance is similar to any other
object oriented programming language the
new contract inherits the functionality
of the base class every function call is
virtual when inheriting from multiple
contracts only one contract gets
generated on the blockchain the code
from all base contracts gets copied into
the final contract which is created
inheritance example code the above
example shows an inheritance code where
the contract title fund is inherited
into the contract title solidity using
the is keyword
abstract contracts
some contracts cannot be compiled by
themselves because the function lacks
implementation but can be used as a base
if the contract inherence from an
abstract contract it must Implement all
functions that lack implementation else
it becomes abstract itself
abstract contracts example code the
above example shows an abstract contract
called abstract contract which is
inherited into another contract called
new contract
events
events are known as event-driven
programs events refer to certain change
in contracts that raise events and
notify each other such that they can act
and execute other functions
events help the developers and
programmers write asynchronous
applications events are the part of a
contract inheritance where a child
contract can invoke events event data is
stored along with block data events
don't have anybody to Define they work
exactly like functions events allow the
use of evm logging for calling front-end
callbacks inside the d-apps interface
for the users to listen to the events
events example code
in the example shown here on the slide I
have passed two types that represent
name and age when the event is
successfully returned in the UI these
values can be accessed
creating contracts using new operator
a contract can create a new contract
using the new keyword recursive creation
dependencies are not viable the contract
sample new is being created and when it
is initialized it creates another
contract with new keyword
globally available variables and
functions
solidity provides two types of units
ether units and time units either units
are numeric literal and may take a
suffix of Zabo Finney way or ether for
converting between the ethers sub
denominations
following are the variables and
functions that always exist in the
global namespace
erc20 tokens
erc20 tokens are tokens that are
designed and used solely on the ethereum
platform
these tokens follow certain standards so
they can be shared and exchanged for
other tokens or transferred to a crypto
wallet
these tokens are created by the ethereum
community
smart contracts are used to create ERC
20 tokens they are also used for
transactions of tokens and record
balances of tokens in the account
after a token is created these tokens
can be traded with any other ERC stands
for ethereum requests for comments and
20 stands for a unique ID number to
distinguish the standard from others
erc20 token standard the ethereum
community created these standards with
three optional rules and six mandatory
optional
token name
symbol
decimal up to 18.
mandatory
total Supply
balance of
transfer
transfer from
approve
allowance
one getting the total supply of tokens
with the usage of total Supply function
2. retrieving the token balance of
another account associated with the
underscore owner address via the balance
of address underscore owner constant
returns uint
256 balance function three sending a
specific amount of tokens to a given
address through the transfer address
underscore to uint
256 underscore value returns bull
success function
four
sending a specific amount of tokens from
one token contract address to another
token contract address via the transfer
from address underscore from
address underscore two
uint256 underscore value returns bull
success function
5. enabling a specific account to
withdraw tokens from one's account
repeatedly while predefining the upper
limit for the amount of tokens to be
withdrawn with the underscore value
parameter this can be achieved via the
approve address underscore spender
uint256 underscore value returns wool
success
the upper limit for withdrawal I.E the
underscore value parameter can be
overwritten when the function is
recalled six returning the residual
amount of tokens within the preset
amount defined by the upper limit
allowed to be spent by the underscore
spender to withdraw from the account of
the underscore owner this can be
executed via the allowance address
asterisk underscore owner asterisk
address
asterisk underscore spender asterisk
constant returns uint 256 remaining
function
create a smart contract to issue your
own digital token
in this demo we're going to develop a
tradable token with a fixed Supply that
can be utilized as a currency share or
an asset
all right let's get straight to coding
let's go to the lab and open remix IDE
in the browser
let's create a new file named
erc20 token
and as always let's begin the contract
with pragma solidity and the version
let's declare an interface named token
recipient so that any contract that
implements receive approval function
counts as a token recipient
next we're going to create a contract
named token erc20
and declare public variables of the
token
let's create mapping with all balances
next let's generate a public event on
the blockchain that will notify clients
another General event to notify client
an event that notifies clients about the
amount burnt
let's create a Constructor function
which initializes contract with initial
Supply tokens to the creator of the
contract
update total Supply with the decimal
amount
give the Creator all initial tokens
set the name for display purposes
set the symbol for display purposes
let's create an internal transfer
function that can only be called by this
contract
prevent transfer to 0x0 address use burn
open close parentheses instead
check if the sender has enough
check for overflows
save this for an assertion in the future
subtract from the sender
add the same to the recipient
asserts are used to use static analysis
to find bugs in your code they should
never fail
now we're going to create a transfer
function
send underscore value tokens to
underscore 2 from your account
underscore 2 the address of the
recipient
underscore value the amount to send
another function named transfer from is
created which transfer tokens from other
address
send underscore value tokens to
underscore 2 on behalf of underscore
from
underscore from the address of the
sender underscore 2 the address of the
recipient
underscore value the amount to send
let's set allowances for other address
allows underscore spender to spend no
more than underscore value tokens on
your behalf
underscore spender the address
authorized to spend underscore value the
max amount they can spend
let's set allowance for other address
and notify
allows underscore spender to spend no
more than underscore value tokens on
your behalf and then ping the contract
about it
underscore spender the address
authorized to spend underscore value the
max amount they can spend
underscore extra data some extra
information to send to the approved
contract
create a function names burn which
destroy the tokens
remove underscore value tokens from the
system irreversibly
underscore value the amount of money to
burn
check if the sender has enough
subtract from the sender
updates total Supply
now we'll create a function that destroy
tokens from other accounts remove
underscore value tokens from the system
irreversibly on behalf of under
allowance
subtract from the targeted balance
subtract from the sender's allowance
update total Supply
all right our contract is ready to be
deployed I'm going to deploy the
contract on robston test network if you
are using Robson 2 ensure that you have
test ether in your account
if you don't have it get some eaters
from faucet.metimask.io
there click on request one ether from
the faucet button a metamask
notification will pop up
click connect
check the account after a few hours you
will get one test ether in the address
all right let's resume back to the
deployment I'm going to use account one
and click deploy a metamask notification
will pop up asking for confirmation
click confirm and the contract gets
deployed
so that's how you can create your own
cryptocurrency on ethereum
let me quickly give you a recap of the
steps now
step one
open remix IDE to write the solidity
code
step two write the contract code in the
remix IDE
step three open metamask extension and
connect to robsten test Network
step four create an account in the
Robson test Network
step 5 create free ether from https
colon double slash faucet Dot
metamask.io
step six click run
step 7. select injected web3 robsten
under environment tab
8 click on create button
step 9 click submit in metamask
step 10 click contract deployment in
minimask extension
Step 11 review your transaction details
for the deployed contract on the
etherscan page
solidity smart contract design pattern
important smart contract design notes as
solidity is still in development there
are a number of changes and issues that
have to be considered in order to have a
perfect smart contract so as to ensure
security of your sensitive data on Smart
contract there are some important points
that have to be considered in order to
ensure the same obuscation all variables
are publicly viewable on blockchain so
anything that is private needs to be
obfuscated storage optimization
smart contract should be carefully
developed because writing to blockchain
is expensive as data is stored forever
Cron job contracts must be manually
called to handle time-based scheduling
cost of gas
almost every instruction in a smart
contract costs gas so always write a
cost-effective smart contract
smart contract design patterns
design patterns are proven to be the
go-to solution in addressing ethereum
smart contract design challenges
following are common design patterns
contract self-destruction
Factory contract
name registry
mapping iterator
withdrawal pattern in the coming slides
we will learn about each of these design
patterns in detail
smart contract design patterns this is
used for terminating the contract
entirely from the blockchain once
destroyed it is not possible to invoke
functions on the contract and
transactions will be logged in The
Ledger
before destroying the contract it is
important to consider that transactions
will fail
any funds sent to the contract will be
lost
Factory contract
Factory contract is used to create and
deploy the child contracts they are
referred to as assets
mostly the factory is used for storing
the child contracts addresses as they
can be extracted whenever necessary a
common use case for the factory contract
is selling assets and keeping track of
those assets the addresses of these
child contracts are stored in the
factory and can be extracted whenever
necessary
name registry this allows you to keep
the address in one contract instead of
tens hundreds or even thousands of
addresses they use mapping methods such
that each address can be looked up for
the particular d-app
name registry is useful when your
contract is dependent on multiple
contracts
mapping iterator there are times when
iteration takes place multiple times but
since mapping in solidity cannot be
iterated and they only store values the
mapping iterator pattern turns out to be
extremely useful
withdrawal pattern after the contract is
created and the asset is bought by the
buyer if due to some fallback problem
the contract has to be withdrawn from
the network all the tokens of the
contract has to be withdrawn and
refunded the goal of withdrawal pattern
is to keep track of balances internally
enforce each user to withdraw their
funds immediately
solidity smart contract to develop
property transfer system
in this demo we're going to create and
deploy a smart contract for
decentralized property transfer system
the scenario is such that government
agrees to put land records on the public
blockchain
each Development Authority D.A becomes
the de facto owner of the property that
exists under their constituency
legislative body
when all the above conditions are met
then d a owner can easily attach the
respective property to the rightful
owner after thorough verification all
right let's start our demo let's open
the simply learns lab for this demo
there it is the lab is ready
let's set up the development environment
now
as I have shown to you earlier I'm going
to use ganache again
then I'll open the metamask and connect
it to the port
now I'll open remix IDE to write and
deploy smart contract
let's create a new file property
underscore transfer
all right now let's begin coding
all right as I had taught you previously
in the class that every contract starts
with a version name so let's write the
first line of the code
pragma solidity carrot
0.4.18 semi-holon
then we need to give name to our
contract let's call it property transfer
D.A shall be the owner we shall be
initiating this variable's value by the
address of the user who's going to
deploy it EG let's say d a itself
let's define the total number of
property under d a at any point of time
unit 256 public total no of property
they should increase as per the
allotment to their respective owner
after verification
let's define a Constructor whose code is
run only when the contract is created
function property transfer
let's define a structure for storing
property against each address
Bool is sold
we're keeping the count as well for each
address
we shall have the properties mapped
against each address by its name and its
individual account
we shall also have another mapping on
how many property does a particular
person hold then we're going to declare
event
this shall give us the exact property
count which any address on at any point
in time
let's declare a function this function
shall be called by D A only after
verification
let's check whether the owner had the
said property or not if yes return the
index flag equals strings equal
properties owner check owner address
I dot name underscore property name if
flag equals true
break
if flag equals true return I else return
nine nine nine nine nine nine nine nine
nine
we're expecting that no individual shall
be owning this much properties
be owning this much properties let's
have a functionality to check the
equality of two strings in solidity
transfer the property to the new owner
if check owner exclamation point equals
nine nine nine nine nine nine nine nine
nine and properties owner message sender
check owner dot is sold equals false
step one remove the property from the
current owner and decrease the counter
step two assign the property to the new
owner and increase the counter
property transferred message sender
underscore 2 underscore property name
owner has been changed else flag equals
false
property transferred message dot sender
underscore two underscore property name
owner doesn't own the property return
flag check owner all right now we have
written the code for property transfer
I'm going to click run and change the
environment to web3 provider and hit
deploy button
now check the log you'll see the
transaction gets logged check
transactions in ganache which shows the
deploy of contract
now let's use a lot property function to
allot the property
copy and paste the address to which you
wish to allot property and give it a
name the property gets allotted when you
hit the button
similarly you can transfer the property
to new address using transfer property
field and check whether the property is
getting shown under the new address or
not
all right that's how you can replicate
the real estate on blockchain and make
the real estate transactions visible to
all parties Banks Brokers government
officials buyers and seller so let's
start with the coding journey to our
first ethereum smart contract
but before diving into the development
and deployment of ethereum smart
contracts it's critical to First grasp
the ethereum platform and how it
functions
so the first thing that we learn is what
is Smart contract in the first place
so smart contracts are essentially
programs that run when criteria are
fulfilled
and as told on a blockchain they are
usually used to automate the execution
of an agreement
so that all parties can be certain of
the results right away
so without the need of any
intermediaries or time waste they can
also automate a workflow starting the
following step when certain
circumstances are satisfied
so now that we know what this smart
contract let's move ahead and see how it
works
so
step one smart contracts are made up of
basic if when then phrases encoded in
code on a blockchain
step 2 when preset conditions are
satisfied and validated the activities
are carried out by a network of
computers
these measures could include sending
notifications releasing funds to the
proper persons or issuing a ticket
step 3 when the transaction is completed
the blockchain is updated
that means the transaction can't be
modified and the results are only
visible to those who have been granted
access
there can be as many stipulations as
needed
means the participants that the task
will be executed correctly participants
must agree on how transactions and
Associated data are represented on the
blockchain
agree on the if when then rules
actually govern those transactions
investigate all conceivable sections and
design framework for resolving disputes
in order to set the terms
the smart contract can then be coded by
a developer who firms that use
blockchain or business are increasingly
providing templates web interfaces and
other online tools to make smart
contract construction even more easier
and here also we will be using one such
tool to create a very first ethereum
smart contract
so now that we know all the required
knowledge about smart contract let's
start with how to create our very first
ethereum smart contract
so let's get started now let's start
with the first smart contract so the
first thing that we need to do is to
navigate to this website which is remix
dot ethereum.org so this is going to
lead us to a remix IDE
as you can see which is an integrated
development environment for solidity
programming
and it runs from the browser itself so
it does not need to be installed or
and you can access it in any operating
system
so it's a lot more convenient and you
can also use it to interact with the
ganache or test net over RPC port
so basically RPC or remote procedure
call interface is provided by the
blockchains for the execution of the
functions that you will store or that
your
install it as a criteria in your
solidity smart contracts
so here we will be using ganache to
deploy our smart contracts
so let me give you a quick introduction
to ganache basically it's a personal
blockchain that enables the building of
ethereum and Coda distributed
applications quickly
and it may be used throughout the
development site to allowing you to
develop deploy and test your
decentralized applications
you know secure and a very predictable
environment
but before uh deploying our smart
contract on ganache we will deploy a
smart contract on the default blockchain
provided by the remix itself
so let's get started with the code
so the first thing that we need to do is
to create a file with DOT Sol extension
so let's you can see here I have already
created my workspace with the name of
demo smart contract workspace
now I just need to create a file you can
click on this icon
and
you can give it a name according to your
convenience or whatever program you're
gonna
story now
smart contract
so basically dot Sol is the extension to
our smart contract since we are using
solidity programming to create our smart
contract
so I'll just
give it a name
so here I have given it a name called
democrine track dot Sol
and that is it now you can see here you
have directed to a
section where you have to actually write
your code
so basically in this video we will be
creating a smart contract
for the implementation of cryptocurrency
in its most basic form
so this smart contract will allow you to
create or Mint new coins and send them
to other blockchain addresses
so let's start with a code so the first
thing that we will write is fragma
directive
so let's
all right
fragma
solidity
zero point
Five Point
one
so this is basically a range of our
minimum margin for our solidity server
uh then we will declare the
contract
let's just write contract
so basically the code contract code
starts with the keyword the contract
followed by the name of the contract
according to your convenience so here I
am giving it a name
mint
is your
coins
and then the braces which employ the
entire contract state and its functions
so now that we have declared a contract
score let's start with the variables and
functions that we need to declare in our
smart contract as per our need
so here I am declaring our variables
so the first variable is for addresses
so first one is
Minto
and
second is balance
so these are known as state variables or
this mapping can be thought of as hash
tables that are virtually initialized so
that every potential key exists right
away and is mapped to a value with a
byte representation of all zeros
so this map will store every address
with its balance
so now that we are done with the
Declaration of our variables let's
create a Constructor that that will be
the address for creating
new coins so instructor
we will make it public
um
MS
g dot
sander
so this line ensures that only the
Creator
can Mint new coins next we will set a
condition for creating new coin and
storing them in the
hash table
so now to store our created new coins
into a hash table we'll declare a
function mint
so let's start with the code
function
address of
the receiver
and the amount
to be received
we'll also declare this public
and we just need to uh
mention our
conditions here
so this is our first condition second
we'll mention
the limit
for the maximum number of coins to be
created
or for the maximum number of
you know the amount to be received or
sent
this system
so the next function is going uh to be
sent which simply examines the
transactions feasibility so let's
declare that function as well
so uh again
let's
input our parameters
address of the receiver
and the amount
we'll make this function public as well
mention a criterias
so the first one is
so this is for you to check if there is
sufficient balance or insufficient
balance in the account
so if the transaction is possible the
function will generate a send send event
so we also need to mention
and even till
to know all the details like who has the
address of the sender and the receiver
as well as the amount
so here we have created the event
now let's get back to the criteria in
our send function
so
as I was saying uh if the transaction is
possible the function will generate a
cent event
which is a declaration for the
transactions to be
broadcasted so let's just
get done with our criteria here
um
[Music]
so the clients using ethereum can listen
to these events on the blockchain for
free The Listener receives the arguments
from
from or to
an amount as soon as the event is
emitted right
here in the
send function
sorry I forgot to mention too yeah
so
as soon as the event is emitted
or the transactions is dragged and then
the next function is executed which is
to get the balance of the address
also when the transaction is completed
the transaction is then added to the
blockchain itself with all the details
of who has sent those
coins and who has received it according
along with their addresses
so let's create one more function to
know the balance
so that will be
give it the argument
The View returns
for the return value that will be in
feature
return
balances
on the argument we just mentioned
from this function is to
get the balance of offer account
so this was our code now we need to
compile this code
see if there is any error or not so
to compile this you need to click on
this icon and just click on
compile
so here you can see that there is no
error and it's successfully compiled
so once it's compiled you need to deploy
this code
so we'll click on this uh
icon here you can see this is the by
default environment uh
environments provided by remix itself so
we will just
select the default one JavaScript
virtual machine
so like we discussed before before uh
deploying our smart contract over
ganache blockchain we will be deploying
it over the blockchain that is by
default provided by remix itself
so
here we have selected the environment
these are the accounts with the dummy
coins already stored obviously you can't
use them for your actual purposes but
these are the dummy accounts provided by
the remix
photo
analyzing your smart contracts and
keeping the track of the transactions
so you can simply select any of
these accounts according to your choice
and
as you can see there is
currently no contract
deployed here so simply we will just
click on deploy
so here you can see it's successfully uh
deployed we'll just click on this drop
down menu
and after scrolling it down we can see
all the options with the functions like
wind send balance balances and the Minto
so when you click on mentor
it will generate an address
current uses address so just copy it
uh so once you have copied you can just
click on balance
so here you can see
you're getting error because right now
you have not transacted any amount of
coincidence so we just
paste the dress here
and then provide the second argument
which is the amount
if you want to meet
just click on mint and here you can see
its success you have successfully minted
uh 500 coins so now when you
check the balances
we are still getting error sorry I
forgot to provide the address so we'll
just provide the dress and click on
balance
here you can see the function is already
called and here you can see the amount
you just minted
same as for here
click on it the amount you just minted
now to send
you can just click the dress
comma
250. so for demonstration I have
provided the address of obviously the
sender right now because I don't know
the address of the receiver but what you
can do is you can provide any other
address and just put the amount and
click on send and manual check the
balance there will be a
change in it right now there is no
change because both the dresses are
already same so this was all this was
the code and this is how you can just
compile and deploy your code on any
blockchain so now that we have checked
it over the default blockchain provided
by remix let's have a look at the
ganache one
so to use ganache you need to first uh
download it
so by clicking here you can just
download it for Windows so I have
already installed this so we just
jump to that step directly
so once you're done with the
installation of ganache you can you'll
get
uh page like this and then you have to
create a workspace so you don't need to
create a workspace here you can simply
click on quick start and it will give
you a list of accounts and all the
details of the blockchain that you can
simply connect with your IDE and
happy
to which you can simply deploy your
smart contract into so let's just wait
for it to download all the information
so now here you can see all the default
accounts provided by the balance
information
by the ganache itself
uh what we need to focus on is our PC
server so basically this is uh this is
the address
provided to every ganache account or
blockchain by defaults itself so we just
need to copy this
and click on epitome IDE
and go to the environment and select
web3 provider
so when you will click on it you will
get this pop-up and
at the end point
you have to paste the address you copied
from your ganache portal and just click
on
okay
so now you can see again uh there is no
contract deployed to it because now we
are simply connected to the custom
Network which is your ganache Network
now these are the accounts provided by
you provided to you by ganache itself
the list of accounts that you saw on the
port bottle now the same process you
need to repeat here just click on any
account of your choice select it
and
click on deploy
so here you can see it's successfully
deployed
and again we're going to repeat the same
process we will
so you can see the address is completely
different from the previous one
just copy this
paste it here
uh let's have a different amount this
time or let's put it
750.
so and just click on mint
you can see it's successfully minted and
manual
paste the address here and click on
balance you can see it's
chewing 750 same you can do for balances
it's 750.
and the same you can do with the scent
also as I'm using the same address there
will be no change in the balance
but obviously it's not popping any error
and showing it successfully done
so you can use it with somebody else's
address too first let's have a look at
the topics that we are going to cover in
this video first we will have an
understanding of what hyperledger fabric
is
following that we will have a look at
some of the benefits of hyperledger
fabric
after that we will understand the
working of hyperledger fabric
following that we will explore the
transaction flow of hyperledger fabric
and at the end we will have a look at
some of the industry use cases of
hyperledger fabric
so let's start with what is hyperledger
fabric
now the lyrics Foundation launched
hyperledger Fabric in 2015 as an open
source permission blockchain technology
now it is a general purpose modular
framework that provides distinctive
identity management and access control
features as a result it is appropriate
for a range of business applications
including trade Finance loyalty and
reward programs track and trace of
Supply chains and clearing and
settlement of financial act so
technically speaking it enables
plug-and-play compatibility for
components like membership services and
consensus
so now that we have the understanding of
hyperledger fabric let's have a look at
some of its benefits to better
understand its functionality
so first is open source the Linux
Foundation is the host of The Open
Source hyperledger fabric technology
which is a blockchain framework the
developer Community is vibrant and
expanding
second is permission
fabric Network which means that the
identities of every individuals who
participates unknown and verified this
Advantage is especially beneficial in
sectors like healthcare Supply Chain
management finance and insurance where
data cannot be accessible to
unidentified parties for instance to
protect consumer privacy and insurance
provider on an hyperledger fabric
blockchain Network can share customer
claim data with authorized parties
third is governance and access control
fabric networks are made up of channels
which are private subnets a
communication between two or more
particular network members
through these channels Network users can
conduct confidential and private
business every transaction on the
blockchain network takes place on a
channel where each person involved must
be verified and given permission to
conduct business this adds an extra
degree of access control and is
particularly helpful when members want
to restrict how much information is made
public for instance when Rivals are on
the same network
fourth is performance
because of its consensus mechanism
hyperledger fabric can support his high
transaction throughput for Enterprise
grade use cases fabric is a permission
blockchain system therefore it does not
have to deal with Byzantine fault
tolerance which might result in slower
Network transaction validation
performance
so now let's move on and have a look at
the working of fabric Network
so an open tested Enterprise
redistributed Ledger platform is
hyperledger fabric it proposes unique
privacy control so that only the
information you want to share is shared
with the permitted Network users
the business processes you want to
automate are documented in smart
contracts with self-executing Clauses
between the parties that are written in
lines of code the code and the
agreements contain therein exist across
the distributed decentralized blockchain
Network
because transactions are retraceable and
irreversible organizations can trust one
another due to this ability to quickly
make better judgments organizations can
save time money and risk
so now that we know the working of
hyperledger fabric let's understand its
transaction flow
so first when a client application sends
a transaction proposal to peers in each
Organization for approval the
transaction flow starts
second the peers confirm the identity
and legitimacy of the submitting client
to submit the transaction after that
they simulate the result of the proposed
transaction and if they match what was
anticipated they send the customer an
endorsement signature
third once it has the required number of
endorsements as specified in the
endorsement policy the client gathers
recommendation from peers and transmit
the transaction to the ordering service
and lastly in order to comply with the
endorsement policy the ordering service
verifies that a transaction has the
required number of endorsements the
accepted transaction are then
chronologically ordered bundled into
blocks and sent to peer within each
organization the ordering service sends
new blocks or transaction to Pure nodes
who subsequently do a final validation
on the transactions in that block as
soon as this is finished The Ledger
state is updated and the new block is
added the fresh deals have been
committed now so that we have covered
all the necessary details regarding
hyperledger fabric let's have a look at
some of the industrial use cases of
hyperledger fabric
the first one is Supply chains
now Supply chains are vast dispersed
network of suppliers producers and
retailers by boosting the transparency
and traceability of transaction within
the network high-pollision fabric
networks can enhance supply chain
procedures
companies who have access to The Ledger
on a fabric Network can see they seem
unchangeable data in forcing
responsibility and lowering the
possibility of counterfeiting
then comes trading now importers
exporters Banks shipping companies and
customer offices are just a few of many
institutions that must collaborate in
order for trade to take place
now financially and trading consortiums
can simply build a blockchain network
using hyperledger fabric where all the
participants can conduct business and
handle trade related documents
electronically without the need for a
central trusted Authority
in fact contrary to other processes
which require players to Exchange Trade
related documents back and forth taking
5-10 days to complete next is insurance
now the insurance sector loses billions
of dollars each year to fraud but using
hyperledge of fabric insurance companies
can use transaction data stored on The
Ledger to spot duplicate and fabricated
claims by leveraging smart contracts to
automate payment from the app fall party
back to the insurance company blockchain
can help speed up the processing of
multi-party subrogation claims Finn is
part of the management team in an
imminent sea and he has come up with
some profitable investment policies for
his company and his employees
before its implementation he needs to
pitch his idea in front of the board of
directors but the board of directors
didn't approve of his idea and that too
without any explanation for their
decision disappointed by this he started
browsing the internet looking for a
solution that could benefit everyone and
where every member gets to have their
say
and that is when he came across the
concept of Dao which is a decentralized
organization that is collectively owned
by its members and wherein decisions are
voted upon by by himself which runs on
blockchain technology
but to understand its concept in depth
we went to his friend Sam who is a
blockchain expert Finn explained to him
his situation how he came across the Dow
and why he wants to know more about it
unrealizing his excitement and curiosity
Sam decided to take him through the Dow
and how it functions he explained that
before understanding what Dao is let's
understand a bit about what blockchain
is
blockchain is a system of storing data
that makes it difficult or impossible to
change hack or manipulate the data it's
basically a digital log of transactions
that are duplicated and spread across
the blockchain's whole network of
computers and the dowel is something
that makes use of its rules and policies
for its proper functioning
he further added a dow or decentralized
Economist organization is a
blockchain-based organization that is
collectively owned and controlled by its
members they have built-in resources
that no one can access without the
group's permission
all proposals are implemented using
voting processes to make decisions upon
its rules and policies ensuring that
everyone in the organization gets a say
this whole system majorly runs on
ethereum blockchain
Sam further added that back in 2016 the
developers of the Dow believe that by
putting decision-making power in the
hands of automated technology that will
eliminate the decision-making power
driven by an individual or by Body it
was created to allow investors to send
money anonymously from anywhere globally
and they would issue tokens to those
owners letting them vote on potential
initiatives or proposals
Finn was fascinated and asked Sam how
exactly it works and how this can be the
solution for his situation
Sam explained basically smart contracts
are the backbone of doubt
smart contracts are programs that run
when certain conditions are met and are
stored on a blockchain
let's understand this stepwise
Step One is when the documentation of
the idea takes place in the similar way
in doubt a group of people write these
smart contracts to administer the
organization
once the contract goes live on the
ethereum network changes to its rules
can be proposed only by voting the
contract automatically fails if the
rules are violated
then comes step two which is a funding
period in which pitching of ideas takes
place in front of the selected members
and investors of the organization
similarly people in the Dow organization
contribute money to the Dow by
purchasing tokens that signify their
membership in the organization
and when the funding period ends it
proceeds to step three that is when the
approval and implementation process of
the idea takes place or say the Dow
starts to operate people can now make
proposals to the Dow on how to spend the
money and how the members can vote to
approve those proposals
this is how the first ever Dow was
launched by slackit
now the question arises what led the Dow
towards criticism
this is due to the infamous Dow hack
back in June 2016 hackers use Dallas
vulnerabilities to assault its treasury
the hackers were able to gain access to
3.6 million ethereum valued around 50
million dollars
this sparked a divisive debate among
down investors with some demanding for
the Dow to be permanently dismantled
initially vitalik buterin the founder of
ethereum advocated a soft Fork of the
ethereum network
which included a piece of code that
would effectively Blacklist the attacker
and prohibit them from moving the stolen
cache
but soon after the problem was detected
in its code putting it vulnerable to
assault after great debate a second
alternative a hard Fork was suggested
and subsequently implemented
the hard Fork effectively reset the
ethereum Network's history and move the
Dow's ether to a different smart
contract allowing investors to withdraw
their assets
and as a result of the hard four two
competing and now distinct ethereum
blockchains emerged those who oppose the
hardpore which wiped back the
blockchain's history back the soft Fork
version which is now known as ethereum
classic
Etc
the ethereum blockchain is the
blockchain that implemented the hard
Fork changing the blockchain's history
Ria is a phenomenal Baker who runs a
bakery in New York on seeing the great
success of her business she thought of
growing it even bigger and launching a
new franchise of her Bakery in LA
so for the funds she applied for a loan
of fifty thousand dollars from the
central bank
after completing her documentation for
the loan she comes to know that the bank
is rejecting her loan application due to
her loan borrowing limit of the amount
decided by the central Financial system
furious with this situation she talked
to a friend Lisa a finance expert to
understand how this whole centralized
Financial system of banks works and why
did her loan get rejected Lisa explained
to her that in centralized Finance Banks
and businesses use the money that you
invest or lend to make profits and their
overriding objective is to make money
third parties or Merchants like debit
credit card providers control money
transfers between the two end parties in
the financial system each charging a fee
for their services
and that is why her loan got rejected
because the loan amount exceeded the
limit decided by the bank or third
parties for her Ria was upset with the
thought of not being able to grow her
business and that is when Lisa suggested
Ria to opt for decentralized finance or
defy Ria got a little confused by the
term and asked what is decentralized
finance
Lisa answered the decentralized finance
is a piece of code that eliminates
middlemen or banks by allowing
individuals business merchants and
corporations to perform Financial
transactions using developing
Technologies
peer-to-peer Financial networks that
provide security protocols and
connectivity to the transactions are
used to accomplish this
stablecoin is a cryptocurrency backed by
an asset or tied to a fiat currency like
the dollar is that the concept's core
a was fascinated and asked how it works
and how exactly D5 could help her get
her loan approved
Lisa further added that defy uses the
consensus mechanism to eliminate
centralized Finance models by allowing
anyone or everyone to utilize Financial
Services regardless of who they are or
where they are a consensus mechanism
refers to the methods used to achieve
agreement trust and security across a
decentralized computer network
now this D5 mechanism runs in a
decentralized environment
and this is where blockchain comes into
the picture it provides the environment
where you can simply create your
decentralized programs or D apps
according to your requirement
in the blockchain network transactions
are stored in blocks and other users in
that Network can verify them if a
transaction is verified by all its
verifiers the block is closed and
encrypted and a new block has created
containing information from the previous
block thus creating a chain of blocks
and these transactions are handled by
decentralized applications or say d apps
Lisa further explained that Ria's loan
got rejected due to the lower limit by
the centralized Financial system but in
defy she can submit her loan
requirements into a decentralized
finance application DIA and an algorithm
would match her up with peers who could
help her after that she'll have to agree
to the lender's terms to get her loan
the transaction is then recorded in the
blockchain where it will be securely
stored in a ledger that will make it
impossible to hack or any kind of
malicious intervention and after that
she'll receive her required amount of
money once it is verified by the
consensus mechanism the lender can also
then begin collecting their payments at
the agreed upon intervals from her when
she makes the payment using her D app it
goes through the same blockchain process
and the money is transferred to the
lender
Rio was impressed and relieved that she
now could grow her business in a much
more secure and cheaper way all thanks
to defy
Defy is meant to conduct transactions
using cryptocurrency
because technology is still evolving
it's difficult to say how if at all
existing cryptocurrencies will be
applied this video at first we will see
some of the use cases of Merkle free
and then we will understand what is a
Markle tree
followed by what is a local route
up to which we will explore about
cryptographic hash functions in
blockchain
and then we will understand how Mercury
exactly works
after which we will discuss the benefits
of Mercury
and at last we will explore why it is it
essential to blockchain
so without much delay let's get started
with the video
but before starting let's have a quick
look at some general use cases of mobile
free
of course there are more good trees
implementations out there get a
distributed version control system is
one of the most widely used it is used
to handle projects by programmers from
all around the world
interplanetary file system a
peer-to-peer distributed protocol is
another suitable implementation
it's also open source allowing computers
to join and use a centralized file
system
Merkel trees are used to benefit of
certificate authorities as well
it's part of the technique that
generates verifiable certificate
transparency logs
the final use case we look at is
database systems like Amazon dynamodb
and Apache Cassandra
during the data replication process
local trees are used by these no SQL
distributed databases to control
discrepancies
now the very first thing we will discuss
is what is a Markle tree
Marvel trees also defined as binary hash
trees are a type of data structure
commonly used in computer science
Merkel trees are used to encrypt
blockchain data more effectively and
securely in Bitcoin and other
cryptocurrencies
it's a mathematical data structure made
up of hashes of various transactions of
various data blocks in a particular
blockchain Network
which acts as a summary of all the
transactions in a block
it also enables quick and secure content
verification across big data sets it
also helps to verify the consistency and
content of the data
now that we know about the Mercury let's
explore what is a Markle root
a Merkel root is a simple mathematical
method for confirming the facts on a
mogul tree they are used in
cryptocurrency to ensure the data block
synth through a peer-to-peer Network or
whole undamaged and unaltered moral
Roots play a crucial role in the
competition required to keep
cryptocurrencies like Bitcoin and ether
running
now that we know hash is a big part of
mercury let's dive down and have a look
at some of the cryptographic hash
functions
a hash function Maps any type of
arbitrary data of any length to a fixed
size output it is commonly used in
cryptography since it is a cryptographic
hash function
the hash functions are efficiently
known for one property so they can't be
reversed it's a one-way function that's
only meant to work in One Direction
message direct secure hash function and
ripe message direct are some of the hash
families available
now let's take an example if you use the
sha-256 hash algorithm and pass 101
blockchains as input you will get the
following output
this concludes that hash functions have
the following Key Properties
deterministic free image resistant
computationally efficient cannot be
reversed engineered and collision
resistant
now that we know about various aspects
of the Mercury let's understand how the
Mercury works
now that we have a basic understanding
of hash functions we can move on to the
working of mobile trees
Omegle tree totals all transaction in a
block and generates a digital
fingerprint of the entire set of
operations
allowing the user to verify whether a
transaction is included in the block
Merkle trees are made by hashing pairs
of nodes repeatedly
until only one hash remains this hash is
known as the Mortal root or the root
hash
they are built from the bottom using
transaction IDs which are hashes of
individual transactions each non-leaf
node is a hash of its previous hash and
every leaf node is a hash of
transactional data of each block
here's an example of a mobile free to
help you understand the concept
consider the following scenario a b c
and d of four transactions all executed
on the same block
each transaction is then hashed leaving
us with hash a hash B hash C and Hash D
now the hashes are paired together
resulting in Hash A B and hash CD
a modal root is formed by combining
these two hashes Hash a b c d
in reality a Mercury is much more
complicated especially when each
transaction ID is 64 characters long
but this should give you a good concept
of how the algorithms work and why they
are so effective
now let's explore the benefits of maple
tree
Markle trees provide four significant
advantages validate the data's Integrity
it can be used to effectively validate
the data as integrity
takes little disks space when compared
to other data structures the Mogul tree
takes up very little disk space
find me information across networks
Mogul trees can be broken down into
small pieces of data for verification
an efficient verification the data
format is efficient and verifying the
data's Integrity takes only a few
moments
now that we know the benefits of mercury
let's explore how it is essential to
blockchain
let's imagine a blockchain without
Merkel tree to get a sense of how vital
they are for blockchain technology
we focus on bitcoin because its use of
Merkel trees is not only important for
the cryptocurrency but also simple to
grasp
if Bitcoin didn't include local trees
for example every node on the mob
Network would have to retain a complete
copy of every single Bitcoin transaction
ever made you can imagine how much
information that would be
any authentication request on bitcoin
would require an enormous amount of data
to be transferred on the over the
network therefore you'll need to
validate the data on your own
to confirm that there were no
modifications a computer used for
validation would need a lot of computing
power to compare ledgers
well Mogul 3 are a solution to this
issue the hash records in accounting
thereby separating the proof of data
from the data itself proving that giving
tiny amounts of information across the
network is all that is required for a
transaction to be valid
furthermore it enables you to
demonstrate that both Ledger variations
are identical in terms of nominal
computer power and network bandwidth so
let's get started and let's see what's
in store for us today so what's in it
for you today we're going to understand
why do we need blockchain wallet what is
a blockchain wallet how do these Wallet
work what are the different types of
blockchain wallets their comparisons and
demo on the usage of these blockchain
wallets and we will try to do certain
transactions using these wallets now
before these blockchain wallets came
into existence what were the means in
order for us to do the transactions and
what were the drawbacks in the old days
the transactions with whatever medium
and channels we had the problems were
that the transactions were slow and
Banks were the central point of failure
basically any transaction which has to
go through has to go through some
intermediary channels and has to pass
through certain intermediaries like bank
which makes them a single point of
failure also there are issues in keeping
track of all accounts and balances data
get jeopardized manipulated or even get
corrupted across multiple systems where
the accounts and balances are maintained
now here comes into existence what is
called as blockchain wallet now what is
blockchain wallet a blockchain wallet is
a cryptocurrency wallet that allows
users to manage different kind of
cryptocurrencies for example Bitcoin
ethereum Etc now a blockchain wallet
helps exchanging of funds easily
transactions are secure as they are
cryptographically signed the wallet is
accessible from web or mobile devices
and the privacy and identity of the user
is maintained so therefore a blockchain
wallet provides all the features which
are necessary for a safe and secure
transfer and exchange of funds between
different parties a blockchain wallet is
a typical crypto currency wallet that
allows users to manage cryptocurrencies
it is very similar to the process of
sending or receiving money through
PayPal or any other Gateway which you
use today but now you can use
cryptocurrency instead similar to PayPal
which you're using for making
transactions with your fiat currency now
let's take a look at the ecosystem of
blockchain wallets here are certain
examples like electrum blockchain.info
Jax mycelium Samurai and Bitcoin paper
wallet these are just to name a few
blockchain wallets which are existing in
the market but there are many more based
on the requirement you have based on the
security you require and based on the
kind of wallet which suffices your need
so we will see what are the
categorizations of these kind of wallets
are now how do blockchain wallets work
let's take a look so before we move on
to how blockchain wallets work let's
understand what a private and a public
key is and how are the these Keys
related to a blockchain wallet now
whenever you create a blockchain wallet
you are also provided a private and a
public key which is associated with your
wallet now let's check an example in
order to understand this imagine a
person knowing your email address is
sending you an email so in our regular
day-to-day activity if we want to
receive an email from someone we give
him or her our email ID and expect an
email from them now what if an unknown
person is able to send emails through my
account so I am giving my email address
for receiving emails but when I am
disclosing my email ID I am not assuming
that someone will be able to send emails
through my account because then for that
he has to be aware of my email account
password so knowing your email address
will not give a person the ability to
send an email from your account you are
not giving your password to the person
to send an email you're just giving the
email address to send an email from a
particular email address an individual
has to be aware of the password
associated with it now blockchain wallet
follows a similar process using public
key and private key both together public
key is similar to your email address so
basically whenever your wallet is
generated a public key is generated you
can share that public key with anyone in
order to receive funds private key is
top secret it's similar to your password
it should not get hacked or you should
not disclose it to anyone and you use
this private key to spend your funds so
now instead of sending an email imagine
you want to transfer money to your
friend this transfer process is done
through your blockchain wallet with
blockchain wallets you can now send and
receive cryptocurrencies so as I said a
blockchain wallet has two keys a public
key and a private key public key is
shared with everyone just like an email
address private key is just like your
password which should be kept secret
with the sender so with blockchain
wallet no one will be able to send
crypto coins just like emails through
your public key until they know your
private key but if someone gets access
to your private key there is a high
possibility that your account is hacked
and you might end up losing all the
cryptocurrency deposits in your account
now let's take a look what are the
typical features of a blockchain wallet
it's easy to use it's just like any
other software or a wallet which you use
for your day-to-day transactions it is
highly secure it is just like a matter
of you securing your private key and it
allows instant transactions across
geographies barrier-free without
intermediaries and also these
transactions charges you low cost free
and these wallets help you do
transactions across multiple
cryptocurrencies so you can make
payments across cryptocurrencies which
helps you do easy currency conversions
now let's talk about what are the
different type of blockchain wallets now
basically there are two types of
blockchain wallets based on the private
Keys one is hot wallet and another is
the cold wallet hot wallets are like
normal wallets which we carry for
day-to-day transactions and these
wallets are user friendly cold wallets
gold wallets are similar to a vault
where cryptocurrencies are stored with a
high level of security now let's take a
look at the differences hot wallets are
online wallets through which
cryptocurrencies can be transferred
quickly they are available online on
internet example coinbase
blockchain.info cold wallets they are
digital offline wallets where the
transactions are signed offline and then
later disclosed online so they are not
maintained on the cloud on the internet
they are maintained offline to have high
security and the examples of cold wallet
are treasure and Ledger now in case hot
wallets private keys are stored in the
cloud for faster transfer in case of
cool wallets private keys are stored in
a separate Hardware which are
disconnected from the Internet or the
cloud or are stored in a paper-based
document hot wallet they are easy to
access available online 24 7 it can be
accessed through desktop or mobile but
has a risk of unrecoverable theft when
hacked cold wallet this method of
transaction helps in protecting the
wallet from unauthorized access from
hacking and other online vulnerabilities
now the wallets can be further
distinguished on these criterias there
can be software wallets they can be
Hardware wallets which are like kind of
USB driven and you plug into your USB
drive and your Hardware wallet can be
used or they are a typical paper-based
wallet where you print your public key
and a private key on a paper and keep it
in a secure place so let's talk about
software wallet a software wallet is an
application that is downloaded on a
device either it could be a desktop or a
mobile or it could be a web-based wallet
which can be accessed online now here
are certain examples Dax red wallet and
copay are the popular software wallets
so software wallet can be further
categorized into desktop wallet online
or we can call it web wallets or mobile
wallets now desktop wallet are like cold
wallet in which the private keys are
stored in cold servers basically the
desktop wallets in the private keys are
stored in your desktop you can unplug it
from the internet do some offline
transactions and then bring it back
online now in case the mail server is
lost then a cold server basically a
desktop is used as a backup server these
wallets can be downloaded on any
computer but can only be accessed from
the system they are installed on so you
make sure the desktop or the machine on
which you are download loaded the
desktop wallet is safe has a backup
you're maintaining the hardware you're
not letting the machine go anywhere and
it is on a secure location now these
wallets are definitely cost efficient
and one of the examples is electrum and
is one of the most popular desktop
wallet online wallets are the other kind
of hot wallets that run on the cloud
that are available on the internet now
here users have the benefit of accessing
these wallets across any device it could
be tablet desktop or you can use it from
your mobile browser the private keys are
stored online and are managed by a third
party you have to be dependent on a
third-party service so for example green
address is a Bitcoin wallet which is
available on the web has an Android app
it's available on a desktop and also is
available on iOS Apple mobile wallets
mobile wallets are like similar to
online wallets except that they are
built only for mobile phone usage and
accessibility these College are also
user friendly and they have a
user-friendly interface from which helps
you in doing transactions easily the
example is mycelium which is the best
available Mobile Wallet Hardware wallet
Hardware wallet is a type of cold
storage device typically like a USB
which stores the user's private key in a
protected Hardware device these wallets
are similar to Portable devices that can
be connected to the computer can be
plugged in as I said earlier it is less
prone to malware attacks malicious
attacks and it is hack proof examples
are Nano Ledger treasure and TT are the
top Hardware wallets available in the
market to make a transaction from your
Hardware wallet you have to ensure the
hardware wallet is plugged into your
computer system before you can do a
transaction from your Hardware wallet
paper wallet a paper wallet is an
offline process for storing
cryptocurrencies this wallet is a
printed paper consisting of both your
private key and a public key which are
accessed using a QR code now since these
wallets are says they are widely used
for storing large amount of
cryptocurrencies now example are Bitcoin
paper wallet and my ether wallet are one
of the widely used paper wallets but the
question arises how do I add
cryptocurrency in my paper wallet in
order to make a transaction with your
paper wallet paper wallet works with
your software wallets the online wallets
to transfer funds from your software
wallet to the public address shown on
your paper wallet so basically first you
park your funds in a software wallet
then you transfer the funds from your
software wallet to the public address
printed on your paper wallet now let's
do the comparison blocked in info
blockchain info is a cryptocurrency
wallet which supports Bitcoin and
ethereum it is easy to use and has a low
transaction fee it has its API is
exposed you can easily use them to order
to make your own custom wallets also
Ledger Nano Ledger Nano is a hardware
wallet which offers a high security to
your account it is available for Bitcoin
ethereum and Litecoin users it is also
possible to maintain multiple accounts
and access them anytime Bitcoin paper
wallet paper wallet helps you to print
your own tamper resistant Bitcoin wallet
it minimizes the threat of hacking Jax
Jax is a software wallet which enables a
user to exchange currencies within the
wallet it is available for Bitcoin
ethereum Litecoin and many other
cryptocurrencies with Jax a user can
view his updated balance as soon as the
processing is complete now let's take a
look at certain demos for the different
kind of wallets we have talked about so
let's first take an example of paper
wallet so
bitaddress.org provides you a paper
wallet it uses the client-side
JavaScript in order to generate a random
hash for your wallet so you keep moving
your mouse and it will generate a hash
public and private key it is recommended
that when you are doing this process you
should be disconnected from the internet
and once these keys are generated you
can print it and keep it secure and
clear the cache of your browser so as
you can see on the screen this is my
public key for receiving my Bitcoins and
this is the private key for me to spend
it I can print it and keep it handy with
me but of course the safety of these
physical documents cannot be entirely
guaranteed if a hacker discovers the
location of your paper wallet and
physically steals it then they can
access your Bitcoin Holdings so
basically it is of high importance that
you keep the paper wallet in a very very
secure location some users hide or
disguise the paper wallet it should be
protected from physical damage if the
keys fade or can no longer be scanned
then the user will never again be able
to access the Bitcoin which are parked
in that address also take care if you
are using an incorrect type of printer
that also may damage the paper wallet
now let's take a look for our second
example of online wallet here we are
taking an example of bit pay so you can
download bitpay online and create your
account over here
you can create a personal wallet you can
create a shared wallet or a joint share
wallet once you create a wallet like if
you see the example over here this is my
personal wallet and I have
3.645 test Bitcoins over here
now in order to receive test Bitcoins in
my account you can receive these test
Bitcoins from
testnet.coinfosset.eu hyphen in
now in order to receive it you just need
to
copy
your Bitcoin address
in the test net address
foreign
so the test net has given me 0.87
Bitcoin so now my balance has increased
from 3.5 to 3.64 and I can see this
transaction
see three minutes go I just received
0.872287 Bitcoin the transaction is
still in process but in a while as this
transaction is getting mined on the test
net I will receive it now as I have
received it I can even make a
transaction and send it to someone
so from my personal account I can send
Bitcoin to
someone whose Bitcoin address I have and
I have to just paste it over here
transfer to bitcoin wallet either I can
select one of my own wallets or I can
search for any other Bitcoin address
which someone has shared with me and I
can send it to that particular address
now let's take an example of our
Hardware wallet how does Hardware wallet
works with the online wallets so here we
have metamask which has a feature of
connecting with Hardware wallet so once
you have metamask installed you will see
this option of connect Hardware wallet
now metamask has provided support for
Treasure so now once you connect your
Hardware wallet the USB with your
computer you can select an account you
want to view on that particular Hardware
wallet and you can only choose one at a
time and then you can start using that
particular wallet for your decentralized
apps so basically once you have your
Hardware connected it is integrated with
your metamask and then you can start
running your decentralized apps so that
they can start using the tokens or the
currency in the particular Hardware
wallet so use your Hardware account like
you would with anything account login to
dapps and send ethereums buy and store
erc20 tokens and non-fungible tokens
like crypto kitties so if you click
connect to trezor over here
metamask will start looking out for the
connected treasure device in this video
we 've explored ethereum dabs and
some of the fascinating Concepts
revolving around it
first we will understand what adapts a
decentralized applications then we will
explore what are smart contracts then we
will look into the features of depth
after that we will figure out why use
ethereum Network for building the apps
then we will explore the difference
between web applications and
decentralized applications after which
we will understand the benefits of
dapp's development then we will have a
look at the dab tools after that we will
explore limitations of dapp's
development and at last we will explore
top 5 ethereum dabs projects
so without further delay let's get
started with the video so what are the
apps or decentralized applications
decentralized applications are
applications built on open source
peer-to-peer network of ethereum
blockchain technology which uses smart
contracts and front-end user interfaces
to create platforms that are launched
and streamlined without intermediaries
and centralized authorities
in terms of user experience it appears
to be similar to other available web
applications but they have a lot of
differences what are smart contracts
a smart contract is a form of code that
lives on the ethereum blockchain that
runs and functions exactly as programmer
quite similarly to normal contracts once
these contracts are deployed on the
network you cannot alter them which
means you can't modify or change them
that's a decentralized because they are
controlled only by the logic written
into the contract
and by not any individual or company
which also means you need to design your
contracts very sensibly and carefully
let's discuss features of dapps which
makes them so unique and popular
first is decentralized this means dapps
are independent and cannot be controlled
by any centralized Authority
second is during complete dabs can
perform any task or action provided by
required resources third is
deterministic irrespective of the
environment dabs perform the same
function everywhere and the last one is
isolated
which means they are executed in the
ethereum virtual machine a virtual
environment so that if there's any kind
of bug in the smart contract it won't
hamper the normal functioning of the
ethereum network that makes me wonder
what ethereum above all blockchain
networks is majorly used for querying
dabs there are several reasons why
ethereum is dominating the majority of
dab development first ethereum is
capable of implementing a development
interface that can reduce programming
time as well as helps and quickly launch
into projects
second the ethereum network consists of
a remarkably growing developers
Community since the platform's launch
third ethereum retains tremendous
Network effects from its Global
Coalition of Technologies
who continue to pursue the network and
actively develop user resources to
encourage adoption and at last but not
least the ability to monetize that
projects adequately stimulates the
participation of the others in the
ethereum network
but what makes dabs different from other
web applications let's have a look at
the difference between web apps and apps
in web applications architecture there
is a front-end line and a backend server
in the front end is majorly written
using HTML CSS and JavaScript and the
backend is written in dijango node or
rails
for dabs the architecture is the same
the front end is written in the same
language as of the web applications but
for backend blockchain technology like
ethereum is used
in web apps and apps they both interact
with each other with Json messages
web apps store user information at the
company headquarters on a separate
server usually however Maps consist of
data created by the users the nodes are
used to verify the exchange when a user
makes a transaction on the tab
now let's have a look at the benefits of
dapps
first is privacy that maintains the
privacy or anonymity of the user which
means you don't need to provide your any
kind of personal information to deploy
or interact with the DAP second is
complete data Integrity data stored on
the ethereum blockchain is immutable due
to cryptographic Primitives no one can
change Forge or manipulate transactions
or other data stored in the blockchain
third is verifiable behavior
smart contracts can be analyzed and are
bound to execute in directed ways
without the need to trust a central
Authority
fourth is zero downtime
once the app is deployed on the
blockchain the network as a whole will
always be able to serve its client
looking to interact with the contract of
the dab now let's tie it down and have a
look at the DAP tools Rumble UI
adaptable components and design
standards for decentralized applications
one click dab it is a fast tool for
generating depth front-end from an ABI
ether flow it is also a first rule for
ethereum developers to test their notes
and compose and debug RPC calls from the
browser so now when we know everything
about that let's understand the
limitations of dapp's development
maintaining daps can be a tough job
because goal and data published to the
blockchain network is very hard to
modify
to achieve the high levels of security
Integrity transparency and reliability
that ethereum is spies to every node of
its Network needs to run and store every
transaction which leads to huge
performance overhead
the entire ethereum network gets backed
up if a single tab is using too many
computational resources
and sometimes it may be harder to in
general and configure user-friendly
experiences sometimes the average user
might find it too difficult to set up a
tool stack necessary to interact with
the blockchain in a truly secure manner
now let me take you through five best
ethereum daps projects
an ethereum based protocol that creates
the DI stable coin and allows for
collateral backend loans to be made
without the use of a middleman uni swap
a decentralized cryptocurrency exchange
protocol chain link a blockchain Oracle
Network that is completely decentralized
acts Infinity a blockchain based trading
and battling game that lets us players
gather breed raise battle and trade
token based entities called axis and Avi
an ethereum based decentralized money
market that allows users to lend and
borrow a variety of crypto assets first
we will look into the origin of ethereum
classic
then we will understand what is ethereum
followed by why acetylene classic used
what are the goals of ethereum classic
and after that we will see the
difference between ethereum classic and
ethereum after that we will look at some
of the limitations of the ethereum
classic and at the end we will explore
what is the future of ethereum classic
so without any further Ado let's get
started with the video so let's start
with the origin of ethereum classic
a German business created Dao a
decentralized autonomous organization or
Dao initiated on ethereum in 2016.
while the project earned over 150
million dollars through crowdfunding
hackers took advantage of a flaw in its
smart contract and stole 50 million
dollars
most ethereum users including creators
with Alec buterin and Gavin's what favor
the heartfold on a major modification in
the blockchain's underlying protocol
to recover the assets resulting in the
formation of the new ethereum Gene
however certain members of the community
opposed to the form
preferring to follow the principle of
code is Law and remained on the old
chain
in naming it ethereum classic
they commonly refer to ethereum Classic
as the original ethereum coin since it
preserves the ancient core of the
ethereum blockchain as it existed before
the da over salt that brings us to the
next concern which is to understand what
what is ethereum classic
um classic is a blockchain based opal
Source decentralized distributed
cryptocurrency platform that runs smart
contracts
ethereum classic is a decentralized
governance platform that leverages smart
contracts embedded within a distributed
Ledger or blockchain Network
it splits the original ethereum
blockchain into two parts with ethereum
classic being the older of the two and
ethereum being the newer one now let's
proceed further and have a look at the
uses of Italian classic
Italian classic has three major uses the
ETC or ethereum classic like other
cryptocurrencies is primarily used to
pay for decentralized computations on
the ethereum network
Etc is used to pay for executing
transactions and smart contract
functions on the ethereum blockchain
this is referred to as gas and the fee
associated with these actions are known
as gas costs
Etc is also a native token with a
monetary policy that creates a
predictable
disinflationary emission scheduled with
the fixed market supply cap
now let's move ahead and have a look at
the goals of ethereum classic
the ethereum classic project has seen
several modifications and additions
since the split the Project's purpose is
to develop a global payment network
based on Smart contracts that can
operate with no centralized Authority
ethereum classic like other
cryptocurrencies will most likely aspire
to be a digital store of value meaning
you can see and exchange it while
maintaining its worth
a crypto's digital store of value
includes its purchasing power which may
be strictly converted to cash or used to
purchase another asset just like money
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more
now that we know all major components of
ethereum classic let's type down and
have a look at how ethereum plastic
differs from ethereum
Etc or ethereum classic is a speculative
digital asset that investors May trade
but the Italian token or eth is the more
genuine and extensively traded of the
two
with a market capitalization of 3.9
billion dollars
Etc has
116.3 million coins in circulation
while eth on the other hand has a market
capitalization of more than 304.9
billion dollars and around 115.6 million
coins in circulation
Etc trades at
33.65 whereas eth trades for more than 2
600 per coin now let's have a look at
the limitations of ethereum classic
although ethereum classic like ethereum
enables smart contracts and Target the
same Market ethereum has grown in
popularity as the more trustworthy of
the two Network despite numerous
software upgrades the scalability of
ethereum Classics payment mechanism
remains one of the Project's largest
concern in the future
furthermore security is likely to be an
issue with smart contracts especially
because ethereum classic has already
been hacked and millions of dollars
stolen so this brings us to the very
important question that is what future
ethereum classic holds for itself
because ethereum is considered the more
authentic of the two networks Italian
Classics future appears to be less
bright than ethereum specially given
ethereum classic security concerns
ethereum classic may have difficulties
and can modify its code and software to
prevent future hacks
where this was all about Italian classic
in this video we will explore ethereum
2.0 and we'll go through some of the
fascinating Concepts and components
revolving around it
first we will have a quick introduction
of what is ethereum Network
then we will look into what ethereum 2.0
is
then we will understand what led to the
origin of ethereum 2.0
then we will understand the changes in
ethereum 2.0
then we will look into the current
status of ethereum 2.0 research
and at last what future we expect for
ethereum 2.0
so without doing Much Ado let's get
started with the video
so what is the ethereum network
ethereum is defined as a blockchain
based Computing platform that enables
its developers to build and deploy
decentralized application
either is the cryptocurrency for
ethereum used to build decentralized
application smart contracts and make
standard peer-to-peer payments it tracks
and facilitates all the transactions and
makes sure they are cryptographically
secure in the network
ether basically acts as a fuel for the
ethereum network
so what is ethereum 2.0
ethereum 2.0 is a set of interrelated
upgrades that will make the ethereum
network more secure scalable and
sustainable
multiple teams from across the ethereum
ecosystem have come together to work on
these upgrades in ethereum 2.0
then what led to the religion of
ethereum 2.0
popularity ether and the ethereum
network has gotten more blocked by
transactions currently it is capable of
handling 15 to 45 transactions per
second which is comparatively impressive
but it is not enough to handle all of
Italian's users worldwide also the high
demand is affecting the driving up of
transaction fees
notes power the ethereum blockchain
network but currently its nodes are
experiencing too much volume
although the programmers working on the
upgrade have claimed that making its
nodes bigger wouldn't be practical
ethereum 2.0 intends to make the network
more scalable to handle all of the
activities on the ethereum network
that makes us wonder what are the
changes in ethereum 2.2
the two significant changes that will
come with the upgrade are adopting proof
of stay and sharding
adopting proof of stake ethereum
blockchain implementations suffer from
performance issues because they rely on
a processing power intensive process
known as proof of work to record and
validate their transactions
the problems with proof of Works design
is that it's very inefficient
ethereum 2.0 will solve these issues by
transitioning its blockchain to a more
efficient proof of stake system
it will decrease the complexities faced
by the network leading to massive
throughput gains for the whole network
sharding is a process that intends to
enhance ethereum's efficiency and
ability to scale
in the current version of ethereum
blockchain all data that is added to the
chain undergoes verification by all
participating nodes that means that the
speed of its fluids participant limits
the processing speed of the entire
network
sharding will increase the efficiency of
the network resources by breaking data
verification tasks among its set of
nodes
and each of them will be responsible for
validating and verifying just the data
allotted to them
this will increase the Network's overall
capacity and make it much faster and
efficient than its outdated version
so what is the current status of
ethereum 2.0 research
while ethereum 2.2 has been in research
and development since 2014. it has
actually been making some progress the
bacon chain went live in December 2020
introducing this taking concept but
still there is no official claim for the
completion of this transition
the next phase is minute
merging the beacon chain into the
current ethereum Network
mining ethereum tokens will officially
end in this phase and staking will
become the primary way to create new
tokens in the ethereum network
the last part of the transition is
expected to unfold in multiple phases
like adding the sharp genes to give the
ethereum blockchain network more
capacity and efficiency to handle all of
the demand and increase transactions per
second
although it has been a long road and
there is still a good deal of
uncertainty around the timing the
ethereum developers do seem to be
motivated and on their way into
completing the whole transition so what
is the future of ethereum 2.0
is executed properly this transition to
ethereum 2.0 could be a total Game
Changer it will create a modified
Network that could potentially process
one lakh transactions per second
and a much more sustainable Network
without the energy intensive mining
process and it will introduce smart
contracts worldwide increasing the
ethereum's network utility
furthermore ethereum co-founder with
Alec buterin once said that the issuance
of new Docker should be highly reduced
under ethereum 2.0 which could increase
its demand
given all these factors ethereum 2.0
seems to hold a bright future for
ethereum blockchain Network let's
proceed further and have a look at how
they both differ from each other did you
know there are more than 1600
cryptocurrencies worldwide and among
them Bitcoin and ethereum have always
been the top two most popular
cryptocurrencies in the world by market
cap
also recently ethereum as well as
Bitcoin reached its all-time peak in
worldwide Trading
according to decrypt.com any daily new
companies like me too and PayPal are
coming forward to invest in Bitcoin and
ethereum on March 7 2021 need to
confirmed that it had purchased 40
million in Bitcoin and ethereum on the
other hand PayPal is about to launch a
scheme with the public in purchase and
sell cryptocurrencies initially
featuring Bitcoin and ethereum via
Paypal digital wallet but have you all
ever wondered how they compare based on
their similarities and differences in
various aspects well before moving any
further let's have a quick look at how
Bitcoin and ethereum originated and made
a benchmark in the economic system
worldwide
Bitcoin was first introduced in 2009 by
Satoshi Nakamoto to resolve cyber
attacks double spending and eliminate
the middleman between the transaction
it led the first revolution of digital
money which enables transparent and
decentralized peer-to-peer transaction
on the other hand ethereum came into the
picture years after Bitcoin it was first
introduced in the late 2013 by vitalik
buterin after that it was very quickly
and widely adopted because it offered a
platform to build and run applications
without any downtime fraud or
interference of any third party
themselves as a Computing platform that
enables its developers to build and
deploy their decentralized application
now let's move ahead and see the
difference between them which make them
compete with each other in this economy
this video will cover individual aspects
for comparing ethereum and bitcoin's
performance and that particular field
first we will look into the introduction
of ethereum and Bitcoin
then the algorithm they follow
the programming language
mining process of ethereum and Bitcoin
monetary policy
transaction
and availability of these two
cryptocurrencies
by time Bitcoin has proved itself as a
well-known cryptocurrency however
ethereum with different functionalities
is giving a quite tough competition to
bitcoin but before moving ahead let's
have an introduction to ethereum and
Bitcoin
ethereum is a platform that builds
immutable smart contracts an application
for its users without any centralized
interference for Bitcoin it is an
alternative to Fiat money or physical
currency the main function of ethereum
is to provide its users or developers
with a platform to build smart contracts
using dapps or decentralized application
on the other side Bitcoin only intends
to be a medium of exchange of money and
value stored in its blockchain Network
now let's get started and move towards
the first comparison which is algorithm
ethereum uses the etash cryptographic
algorithm for mining blocks in the
ethereum network on the other hand
Bitcoin uses the sh-256 hashing
algorithm for mining blocks in the
Bitcoin Network
algorithm is mainly used during the
proof of work function proof of work is
a small piece of data that is difficult
to generate but easy to validate and
satisfy a certain Network requirements
sat 256 algorithm helps Bitcoin users to
protect all their sensitive data like
private Keys moving on the programming
language of ethereum and Bitcoin
ethereum uses solidity solidity is a
high level programming language used by
ethereum for implementing smart
contracts but in terms of programming
language Bitcoin keeps it simple Bitcoin
uses C plus plus as its programming
language it is a stack based programming
language used to give Bitcoin software
instructions on how to make transactions
as we have covered the algorithm and
programming language of both
cryptocurrencies now let's take a look
at the mining process of both mining is
a process in which transaction made are
validated and added to blockchain public
Ledger and blogs and the people mining
these blocks are called miners ethereum
minus mine the unvalidated transaction
using the proof of work method but it
aims to switch to proof of State because
it will make its Network more immune to
centralization energy efficient and
stronger support for the shared chain
on the other hand similar to ethereum
bitcoin miners also use the proof of
work method to mine unvalidated
transactions these method is enough to
function in Bitcoin Network worldwide
now let's proceed towards the monetary
policy of both cryptocurrencies but
let's first understand what monetary
policy is monetary policy is known as
the process of drafting announcing and
implementing the plan of actions taken
by the competing monetary authority to
control the money supply and Achieve
goals that promote sustainable economic
growth so ethereum's policy is defined
by the reward paid out by its protocol
ethereum's monetary policies are best
described as minimum issuance to secure
the network therefore there is a
constant trade-off between the
transaction speed and security but
bitcoin's monetary policy comprises of
two parts having and block frequency
halving event is when the reward of
mining Bitcoin is cut in half and it
also cuts the inflation rate and the
block reward is the number of Bitcoins
you get if you successfully mine a
blockchain block the current block
reward for ethereum is to either per
block and for Bitcoin the block reward
is 12.5 Bitcoins per block also every 14
seconds a block of ethereum is generated
and one block of Bitcoin take 10 minutes
to generate monetary policies are
considered to be fixed and
non-inflationary due to this over time
mining blocks will become more difficult
next is transactions
ethereum is a little bit faster than
Bitcoin with 30 transactions per second
and it takes just a few minutes to
confirm it on the other side bitcoin's
transaction speed is 5 transactions per
second and it can take up to 60 minutes
or more to confirm either the currency
of ethereum acts as the fuel for
ethereum networks and Bitcoin is only
used as the value for real world
transaction to compete with already
present electronic cash like credit
cards and Google pay a determine Bitcoin
require higher productivity to attain
widespread adoption now talking about
the availability of both
cryptocurrencies ethereum is not limited
but it can occasionally reduce due to
large Network upgrades however Bitcoin
is limited to 21 million coins and as of
today 18 million Bitcoin is already used
but in the end both Bitcoin and ethereum
being the top cryptocurrencies share a
few similarities like both a decent
utilized and can be used to have a
peer-to-peer transaction proof of work
also both have a large network of
independent nodes choose from over 300
in-demand skills and get access to 1 000
Plus hours of video content for free
visit skillup by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
now let's have a demo now let let's have
a look at the media outlet website
coindesk where we will see all stats
related to bitcoin and ethereum in
detail coinbase is a site specialized in
digital currencies it is used to explore
the news and price data related to
cryptocurrencies and also explains how
cryptocurrencies contribute to the
evolution of financial system worldwide
now see this graph this graph shows the
change in bitcoin price in 24 hours
duration this graph shows the gradual
change in the price of Bitcoin it
started from 64
439.29 on April 14 at 12 pm and right
now by April 15 at 6 00 am it is at 63
189 the rate of change is minus 0.46
which shows the change in the price of
Bitcoin per hour
let's have a look at this graph of
ethereum 2. the value of ethereum
started at
2388.13 dollars on April 14 at 12 pm and
the current status on April 15 is
positive with a value of
2442.37 with an increasing rate of 4.67
percent down below we have a metrics
table that shows the change between the
starting and ending value of ethereum
the total supply of a cryptocurrency in
24 hours the total number of
transactions that occur and the average
transaction fee for all these
transactions now this graph shows the
current status of cryptocurrency in USD
dollars we can also see its value
according to any centralized currency
like Euro or INR this graph shows the
concentrating change in the value of
cryptocurrencies every moment
we can also access the data of trading
from an R to its lifetime blockchain
prospects
let's have a look at objectives of this
lesson
by the end of this lesson you will be
able to identify the use cases of
blockchain in healthcare industry
I identify the use cases of blockchain
in government organization
identify the use cases of blockchain in
finance industry
other Industries worldwide
do we need blockchain
our first concern must be whether the
traditional database system can meet our
use case needs in case it does we
wouldn't need fast secure transactions
and thus we won't require a blockchain
always in The Ledger system there would
be many people involved and if they are
not ready to trust a third party and
need to keep their data private then the
best option would be to go for a
permissioned blockchain
permission blockchain would also allow
to control the permissions in blockchain
software
in case redundant copies are required to
be saved in multiple distributed
computers and do not have the need to
keep the data private we could have a
public blockchain
challenges in blockchain following are
some of the challenges in blockchain
initial cost miners use giant computer
rigs with several servers to keep the
network ticking over and that consumes a
lot of electricity which is not
affordable
second major factor is the energy
consumption proof of work consensus
mechanism is very wasteful as a
Computing algorithm the year 2017 saw a
significant increase in Bitcoin network
activity and estimates show a combined
yearly energy consumption rate of 70
terawatt hours for Bitcoin blockchain
security issues
a blockchain pulls its security profits
from the decentralized nature of its
nodes that verify transactions on the
blockchain but owing to the design of
blockchain Technology all public
blockchains are exposed to 51 attacks
blockchain privacy issues
if a blockchain is public anyone could
look at the transaction recorded on the
blockchain the information available in
the public domain runs against
long-standing Norms especially in
healthcare legal and financial sectors
which have the typical privacy
requirements
public perception the biggest
disadvantage of blockchain has been the
perception it holds in the eyes of the
people
don't see it as a part of conventional
functioning most don't believe that
blockchain technology will last for long
integration with Legacy systems
the integration barrier with Legacy
systems is also a main issue with
adopting blockchain
all the traditional systems would be
using different data formats and models
for storing data and would be working in
isolation
most of these systems are tightly packed
and would have very less models of
integration with blockchain
identifying a blockchain use case
so we need to understand what kind of
use cases could be used for blockchain
it should have a business problem that
requires blockchain technology to solve
it blockchain provides a real-time view
of the data to people who can join the
network as a participant to verify the
transactions and data a business use
case for data exchange that has trust
issues thus an identifiable business
Network needs to be chosen to establish
the trust there are often manual bunch
of business verification processes which
are established verification steps
result in additional operational cost
and time verification time delays the
consequent business processes that are
depending on this data so a blockchain
could be used where the verification
could be done by consensus algorithms
Healthcare use cases
patient data management
here's how it goes the user agrees to
share its Health Data by giving
permission the health wallet would
create an address which stores a smart
contract on blockchain when researchers
wish to access data they check the
permissions in smart contracts to check
whether the use of the health records is
allowed if yes then they access the data
record the transaction on blockchain and
make the payment to the patient's Health
wallet Health coin payments is
transformed to money which could be used
to purchase Medical Services
drug traceability
blockchain could also be used in drug
traceability when the manufacturer
manufactures the drug it marks it with a
unique code the information is stored on
blockchain and a hash is produced it
sends the drug to the wholesaler the
wholesaler then verifies the origin of
the product and this transaction is
stored on the blockchain
the wholesaler further sends the drugs
to the pharmacist and then later
verifies the origin of the product again
like all other transactions even this
transaction is stored on the blockchain
the pharmacist delivers the origin of
the product so this way the drug could
be traced effectively using blockchain
government use cases
blockchain and voting in this
application the voter logs into the user
interface to cast this vote the identity
verifier receives the ID verifies that
it is unique and authorizes the ID key
to vote on a certain ballot type
by casting votes in the form of
transactions we can create a blockchain
which keeps a track of the tallying of
votes this way everyone can agree on the
final count of votes based on a
consensus because they can count the
votes on their own and because of the
blockchain audit Trail they could easily
verify that no votes were changed or
tampered with and no dishonest votes
were added using this solution the voter
would be authorized to cast its vote by
the registrar and ID verifier
using vote key the voting booth UI
generates the ballot for the voter to
cast their vote all right that was how
blockchain can be used in voting let's
have a look at another interesting
example
tax processing
let's see how we tax processing GST
without blockchain works a GST invoice
is issued by the seller buyer pays the
bill with GST seller pays to the
supplier
information of payment is recorded on
GST portal final tax goes to the
government additional payment is
adjusted
so that's how the tax processing Works
without blockchain now we'll see how
blockchain could be implemented in such
a system
during the payment for a good or service
blockchain smart contract can calculate
the invoice based on the tax amount that
is already levied during the production
process
smart contract directly transfers the
tax amount to tax Authority the refund
if any is directly paid to the
customer's account
blockchain in land registry
citizen initiates a request to sell haul
or notary now if you go by the current
scenario the centralized database is
used which has risk of data manipulation
also since there is a paperwork involved
there are chances of risk or loss damage
and forgery but if you use a blockchain
based platform like exonym there is a
guarantee of further immutability and
the public data can be changed only by
the owner
so these were some of the use cases in
government organizations
blockchain in kyc
here's how blockchain can help in kyc
system it permits for the secure
transfer of a kyc verification stamp
from one entity to another as it is
unparalleled in distributed Version
Control of Ledger contents it offers
highly immutable and detailed audit
Trail on all actions on kyc files
centralized blockchain based kyc Banks
could also be linked to a centralized
kyc repository along with the lines of
the current kyc registry system in this
Arrangement customer data and documents
are stored in the distributed Ledger and
the bank that performs the kyc stores
all the relevant details and generates a
unique kyc number when another bank
wants to perform due to persistence on
the same customer it can use the unique
kyc number to access the central
registry and download customer details
from the blockchain
blockchain and trade Finance
by applying blockchain technology to
trade Finance technology infrastructure
companies could reduce the complexity
and increase efficiency in large scale
here's how blockchain can be implemented
in trade Finance
upon purchase the agreement of sale
between the Importer and the exporter is
shared with the import Bank using a
smart contract on the blockchain
in real time the import bank will have
capability to review purchase agreement
draft terms of credit and submit
obligation to pay to the export Bank
the export bank will review the provided
payment obligation and once approved a
smart contract will be generated on the
blockchain to cover terms and conditions
and lock-in obligations after receiving
the obligations the exporter will
digitally sign blockchain equivalent
letter of credit within the smart
contract to initiate shipments Goods
will be inspected by Third parties and
the custom agents in the exporting
country and their actions will have a
digital signature of approval on the
smart contract
during Transit Goods will be transported
from country a to Country B
upon delivery importer will digitally
acknowledge receipt of goods and Trigger
payment
using provided acknowledgment smart
contract will automate payment from
importer to exporter via a smart
contract next we have blockchain in
mortgage industry blockchain in mortgage
industry
here's how blockchain can improve the
system the process flow for mortgages is
given in the steps below one buyer
applies for property valuation to
Mortgage Solutions
two property valuation report is
validated according to business rules
using smart contracts and is submitted
to Mortgage Solutions
three Mortgage Solutions forwards the
request to the buyer
four buyer applies for a loan to the
bank
5. Bank requests the generation of a
report from title search and
municipality
six mortgage smart contract redirects
requests automatically to the respective
parties a title search report is created
and submitted back to Mortgage Solutions
B tax report is prepared and submitted
to Mortgage Solutions
seven smart contract checks the reports
and forward it to the bank eight if all
the conditions are valid the bank
approves the loan nine buyer and seller
sign the required agreements
10. Agreements are submitted to the bank
11. sales proceeds and loan is dispersed
to the seller's Bank
12. sellers Bank credits the seller's
accounts
blockchain and Loan management
the use of blockchain Technology allows
much faster approval for loan
applications and credit cards something
that is presently long-winded and
expensive for lenders to do
the use of credit scores paychecks and
bank statements might become less
important to approve a loan
thanks to the availability of smart
contracts lenders are able to authorize
transactions confirm if the
counterparties are legit and perform
routine account Administration tasks
from time to time making it cost
effective and accelerating the process
blockchain in Estonia
blockchain secures the health records in
estonia.com by taking account of every
update and keeps a record of all the
transactions of the stock market it
stores information of birth certificates
business contracts and also marriage
registrations
blockchain in energy markets blockchain
facilitates secure transactions of power
between individuals on a distributed
Network who do not have an existing
relationship
grid is based on an open source
cryptographically secured decentralized
application platform
all energy transactions are logged
prosumers generate power beyond their
needs and feed it into the grid using
blockchain
smart contracts automate agree trading
relationships commercial transactions
are auditable improving Trust
pre-trade agreement can be arrived using
blockchain
carbon credit certificates can be issued
in blockchain which incentivizes green
energy creation blockchain in media ujo
music
following are problems in media
comprehensive database of Music
copyright doesn't exist royalty amount
takes longer than usual to reach The
Music Makers
blockchain can be used in media
platforms where the royalties could be
calculated in a fast transparent and
secure manner especially using
blockchain platforms like Quorum where
thousands of transactions could be
processed in a second
even ethereum-like public blockchain
platforms could be used to make
decentralized music platforms that make
it tamper-proof and an easily auditable
database
blockchain and travel lock trip
lock trip it is a blockchain powered
marketplace where Property Owners can
rent their property globally collect
money and manage bookings without paying
any commissions to middlemen
blockchain in travel industry has also
revolutionized the way hotel booking
payments work by not giving any
commission to the hotel or third-party
vendor unlike the traditional travel
agency systems
the blockchain would be a decentralized
system and would be free to use thus
reducing the cost and additional
overheads
blockchain in supply chain let's have a
look at the traditional approach of
order placement in a traditional
approach of placing order the following
steps are involved
customer places an order on the website
a member of the sales team receives the
order and dispatches it to the shipping
Department
a member of the sales team receives the
order and dispatches it to the shipping
Department the shipping clerk picks the
order and proceeds for shipment
your order gets boxed and shipped to
your address customer gets satisfied and
submits the product review on the
website
now comes the blockchain in supply chain
introducing blockchain smart contracts
in supply chain modifies the traditional
ecosystem of Transport goods from the
wholesaler to retailer and then to the
end user
the transactions of supplier order
invoice and shipment would be stored in
the blockchain database which makes it
tamper proof and a secure way of
managing shipments
blockchain for network security Korea
Telecom
blockchain could also be used to improve
cyber security
blockchain would provide permission to
access control traceability of
transactions and also data recovery by
the usage of smart contracts
data provider can use encrypted data
transmission for one registration of
data attributes and ID information to
setting of access rights and automation
of processes which can then be
integrated with blockchain API
data exchange can take place on
blockchain this will prevent fraud and
data theft bigger blockchain networks
with more users have a substantially
lower risk of being prone to hacks
because of the complexity required to
penetrate such a network data can be
accessed by the users via a secured
Channel with data access authentication
over a wide area network that is the
reason to learn blockchain
so at the 10th position we have
entertainment for all
blockchain is the ideal technology for
eliminating middleman from the content
distribution process
for example an artist may use blockchain
to upload their song to the cloud as an
encrypted file the song can then be
requested directly by an interested
listener for a fee the Creator can just
directly distribute a copy of their
content to the consumer thanks to the
peer-to-peer networking infrastructure
for example
we now utilize Spotify and Saavn to
stream and listen to music these apps
too serve as intermediaries
now every time you listen to when Taylor
Swift's song money goes to Spotify
leaving the singer with a very small
royalty to avoid this the artist can
submit the music to the cloud as an
encrypted file using blockchain
the song can then be requested directly
by an interested listener for a little
fee
then at the ninth possession comes
transparency and improved governance
a transparent and responsible government
is the most critical aspect of any
country's ability to function almost the
majority of the country's governance is
open
meaning citizens are not involved in the
procedures but decision making
so transparency and legitimacy can be
achieved by incorporating blockchain
into governance
systems such as taxes elections welfare
health care and so on
countries such as Germany the United
Kingdom and Australia already developing
plans to include blockchain into their
governing operations in order to verify
tax compliance keep digital documents
and make welfare payments among other
things
Dubai on the other hand has already
successfully integrated blockchain into
its facial activities making it the
first government to do so
after that at the eighth position we
have cryptocurrencies and icos
if you have a genuine interest in
investing in cryptocurrency you must
have a solid understanding of the
blockchain and distributed Ledger
technology systems
this is due to the fact that blockchain
is the underlying mechanism for such
currencies hence dealing with them
necessities and the use of blockchain if
you understand how blockchain works
you can make wise Investments learning
blockchain will also help you better
understand and shortlist icos
then at the seventh position comes
cardio and cyber security
an individual can also claim greater
ownership and control over their digital
identity using the digitally encrypted
key because cyber security is one of the
most important needs in the tech
industry learning blockchain help you
understand your cyber security
profession
and one of the most compelling reason to
understand blockchain is its role in
cyber security blockchain Technologies
decent line structure make it impervious
to hacker attempts aimed at compromising
sensitive data
blockchain delivers Superior security
then traditional storage options which
rely on centralized and highly Secure
Storage
then comes at the sixth position we have
high demand for blockchain technology
since its Inception blockchain has
continued to attract attention
credibility and appeal the market need
for blockchain has increased every year
according to statistics
this indicates that blockchain will
continue to be a domain with career
possibilities and business application
in the coming years
now at the fifth position comes digital
identity
now except for our grandparents and
great grandparents there must be very
few Among Us who do not utilize digital
banking or transaction services
this digital revolution has also
provided in famous hackers with millions
of opportunities to commit cyber crime
as a result our digital identities were
put into Jeopardy
now blockchain will establish a strict
cryptographic system that will make
hacking and assessing information
difficult
additionally a person's digital identity
is preserved I.E there will be just one
online identity that may be used
wherever identity will be validated and
documented in a blockchain
and no one can commit digital fraud by
generating bogus identities
after that at the fourth position comes
New Age Technology information
blockchain provides a universal
architecture that can be easily
integrated with both old and new
technologies it can be used for voting
banking commodity trading and Supply
Chain management among other things
furthermore the blockchain smart
contracts and distributed Ledger system
concepts are idle for The Internet of
Things
now we have reached the top three
reasons in which at the third position
we have the inflection point of an error
blockchain is said to create an invasion
point of an error where many significant
players such as Citibank MasterCard CIBC
Visa SBI Standard Chartered Western
Union
Central GB Morgan and others are
believed to have integrated blockchain
technology this signifies that
blockchain will become a widely
acknowledged technology in no time
it will also open the floodgates to a
slew of new job openings as a result it
is preferable to write the trending wave
and enjoy it while it lasts
now the second position we have
diversity of job roles
the second key point to consider when
learning blockchain is the wide range of
blockchain based employment
blockchain encompasses a wide range of
sector as well as technical skills
as a result blockchain talents not only
boost an individual's Proficiency in a
certain technical function but also the
ability to produce business value a
closer look at the several major
employment titles in the blockchain
landscape might help to clear up any
misconceptions about whether or not
blockchain is worth learning
now comes the first and foremost reason
to learn blockchain
and that is promising career
since its introduction as a new concept
of running a cryptocurrency network
blockchain has grown in popularity as a
result there are an increasing number of
employment openings for blockchain
experts
blockchain professionals have titles
such as blockchain developer
cryptocurrency analyst blockchain
consultant blockchain solution architect
senior software engineer research
analyst and so on
as of 2021 a blockchain professional's
average compensation ranges from 1 lakh
875 USD to 1 lakh 85 250 USD
now blockchain will become more
mainstream in the future years offering
even more work prospects for people
to sum up blockchain has a massive
Global impact the benefits of learning
blockchain go beyond professional
potential and include opportunities to
gain new skills
so by understanding blockchain you can
get a job in a variety of professions
and build a reputation as a blockchain
cyber security expert photochromic
as we move into the web 3 and metaverse
eras online identity is becoming just as
vital as offline identity and blockchain
is inevitably playing a role
take photochromic or for example which
develops a biomedically controlled form
of self sovereign
identities on the blockchain by merging
nfts with user identity
photogromic's goal is to make
identification programmable verifiable
universally addressable and digitally
secure
photochromic addresses the current
challenges that individuals around the
world are facing as they seek ownership
of the identity and the capacity to
protect it
photochromic returns control and
ownership of a user's identity to the
person who created it
so next in the list we have femex
while blockchain and cryptocurrency are
Global Concepts there are a number of
intriguing Regional Ventures
in just two years Phoenix has amazed
over 1.5 million users making it the
most popular crypto trading platform in
the world
the company is also known for its viral
promotion such as the era of zero which
provided zero fee trading for spot
orders in 2019 and Bitcoin pizza guy
which was launched in 2020. remix
popularity will only increase in 2022
and we can anticipate more Innovative
trading and viral promotions in the
future
then we have is aioz Network
on the emerging web free scene in 2022
we will see more use of blockchain apps
project like aioz Network a web 3.0
media infrastructure will help to
achieve this
artificial intelligence is used to
optimize this network's decentralized
content distribution Network which is
powered by peer-to-peer Edge nodes
decentralized application for videos
audio live and meta was streaming can
use the blockchain infrastructure
because of these features
following that we have flare Finance
the decentralized finance field is
rapidly expanding but there is still a
need for solution that can link all of
the ecosystem together
player Finance which will be the first
D5 platform on the player Network might
soon evolve into a full-fledged D5
platform
their Finance ecosystem will connect
communities together and return the
power of Finance to the people through F
assets and why assets
moving on we have scalloped
as the use of Bitcoin becomes more
common more service like scallop are
developing to make the transition easier
scallop is a 10 product Next Generation
banking platform that includes banking
accounts wallets and nft Marketplace
scallop is a One-Stop shop for Banking
and cryptocurrency solutions scallop
allows for any form of transaction with
full banking accounts for fiat currency
cryptocurrency wallets and an inbuilt
exchange
scallop also has a native blockchain
that will go live in the coming months
and will be used to underpin its banking
environment the scallop ad will be
available in Europe on November 29th
2022.
next coming on the list we have
spacewide let me tell you this project
has my personal interest as well
so these days blockchain Technologies
are also being used in the gaming
industry take for example space y 20 25
the first three a tar defense blockchain
game themed on colonizing and protecting
march with the backstory based on Elon
Musk Mars mission
it is being built by a blockfish team
which was behind such blockchain and
gaming Services as tencent and EA Studio
as well as titles rifled Roblox death
stranding and The Sims 3 and is a fan
favorite since its launch
not only have numerous influencers
players and Community supporters been
thrilled about space by 2020 bye but so
have high profile investors like ash WSB
Draper Dragon formless capital
U Beaver insures and Magnus capital
space flight 2025 has blockfish first
three year Flagship game
might assure in a new era of chain game
Creation in 2022 and Beyond
next up is
Sushi words
non-fungible tokens and blockchain
gaming are two areas of the blockchain
business that have taken off
so she was combine all of these elements
in a blockchain based online game that
bets virtual Sushi aptars against each
other in battle and contest all of the
sushis in the sushi were ecosystem a
one-of-a-kind nfts with the potential to
appreciate and value as they compete
it has gained thousands of members since
it starts released a limited edition
collection with Renault digital artist
Laya
and is expected to develop even more in
and the last but not the least we have
extend agency
because of agencies like extend agency
there is much more order and
professionalism around product launch as
more initiatives are launched in the
more mature blockchain and crypto Market
X10 is a marketing and public relations
firm that focuses on assisting
entrepreneurs with the launch of D5 sto
and nft
Exton seeks to offer credible unusable
assessments on industry trends as much
of the crypto and blockchain sector is
based on conjecture about the next big
thing in this video we will come across
some of the very important aspects
needed to become a blockchain developer
like first of all we will understand who
is a blockchain developer
then we will understand what are the
types of blockchain developer
after that we will look into the
technical skills needed to become a
blockchain developer
and then we will understand what are the
roles and responsibilities of a
blockchain developer
then we will have a look at the
company's hiring blockchain Developers
and at last what is the average salary
of a blockchain developer in both the
USA and India
so let's get started with who is a
blockchain developer
a blockchain developer is a person who
is responsible for developing and hence
enhancing blockchain related
applications famously known as dapps
smart contracts architecture and
protocols for those who don't know what
blockchain is blockchain is a system of
recording details of transactions in a
block taking place in the blockchain
network that makes it difficult or
impossible to change or hack which means
they are immutable
a blockchain is essentially a digital
public Ledger of transactions that is
copied and distributed across the entire
network of computer systems on the
blockchain
basically blockchain developers enable
secure digital transactions by creating
systems and applications to record and
store blockchain data and prevent
external changes or hacks
that brings us to what are the types of
blockchain Developers
there are two types of blockchain
Developers
core blockchain developers and
blockchain software Developers each type
has its specific type of role let's go
through them in more detail
the code blockchain developers designed
the protocols required to run a
blockchain solution successfully which
means they are majorly responsible for
the architecture development of
blockchain
they are also responsible for Designing
consensus protocols and making high
level decisions
blockchain software developers develop
and implement the blockchain using the
designs and solutions created by the
core blockchain Developers
they are majorly responsible for
Designing and implementing smart
contracts and developing decentralized
applications or dabs
now let's understand what are the
technical skills required to become a
blockchain developer
to become a blockchain developer you
need to have a specific set of technical
skills let's take a look at them
understanding blockchain architecture
for starters you should have a complete
understanding of blockchain Technology
its architecture how it works and its
critical Concepts like hash functions
distributed Ledger technology and
consensus protocols
next data structure and coding
data structures and coding are
considered the most basic and essential
skills required to be a fine developer
it is a must-have skill to become a
blockchain developer as it enhances your
ability to play and configure blockchain
according to your requirements
development of smart contracts smart
contracts is the most vital part of
blockchain Technology the programming
language solidity is used to create
smart contracts ethereum is the best
example for smart contracts it helps you
set up the business and develop and
deploy dapps using smart contracts
and at last basic knowledge of
cryptography
blockchain secures its data by using
highly effective cryptography algorithms
cryptography helps you implement dapps
and other blockchain services
now we have covered the technical skills
required to become a blockchain
developer let's explore the rules and
responsibilities of a blockchain
developer
both core blockchain developer and
blockchain software developer have
different roles and responsibilities
first we will discuss the roles and
responsibilities of code blockchain
developer
core blockchain developer understand and
implement the features and
functionalities of blockchain
the design protocols and consensus
protocols for blockchain Networks
they create solutions for providing
security to the data stored in the
blockchain network
and they make sure that the blockchain
network functions smoothly and securely
now blockchain software developer design
and Implement smart contracts
they develop and deploy decentralized
application or dabs as per the
requirements
also they look after the integration
with other applications and services
now let's dive down and explore the
company's hiring blockchain Developers
there is a massive demand for blockchain
developers and if you know your skills
will you will surely get a good start
with your career as blockchain developer
joining a programmers community and
working on Dual projects will help you
learn grow and upskill yourself
according to 2021 science of a software
development company Ripple Labs
incorporation and American technology
company that deals with the Ripple
payment leeway Hertz a software
development company for startup and
Enterprises chroma way a blockchain
technology company open Ledger a
decentralized financial platform used to
convert Bitcoins to Smart coins and
intellect stock a company specialized in
providing software products and
Integrated Solutions are a few top
companies who hired blockchain
developers to work on blockchain
technology
now that we know about the demand of
blockchain developers worldwide let's
figure out the average salary of a
blockchain developer in both the USA and
India
in the USA the average salary of
blockchain developer is over 157
000 per year and in India it ranges from
five lakh rupees 30 lakh rupees per year
so this is all about who is a blockchain
developer so um we are going to discuss
a little bit about
um what could be the kind of steps or uh
what could be the ways that you can be a
blockchain developer and before going
into the uh discussion of what are the
ways for that first we must need to
understand who is a blockchain developer
itself because there are quite different
terms that being used like some of you
maybe have heard about smart contract
engineer or blockchain engineer or our
blockchain developer so these are
different terms that's being used
interchangeably so along with it you
must need to know the the main uh
understanding and the terms that being
used and what is the meaning of being a
blockchain developer so moving forward
we are going to discuss a kind of what
could be a type of blockchain developers
on which side you can focus and then you
are going to explore some of the steps
that how you can become and how you can
be planning your journey to become a
blockchain developer as your career so
uh we are we'll be moving forward in in
terms of also just exploring a little
bit about the market there was the
salary range that's being provided and a
kind of you can say obstacles uh that is
for someone who wants to learn
blockchain development or who wants to
learn this technology so this is a kind
of our whole agenda that what we will be
discussing in our today's session so
first of all let me first move forward
with the kind of questions that who is a
blockchain developer so initially what I
would say whenever you want to achieve
something or you whenever you you plan
to get yourself into as a part of your
career as a part of your next role first
of all you shouldn't understand some of
the questions and you should ask
yourself a few questions who what and
why you want to be uh to be that
position so uh that's a very important
first of all you do try to understand
who you want to be like who who is a
blockchain developer who is a kind of
position that you are looking for then
what are the ways to become that
specific professional in the market and
then why also you should know that why
you are looking forward to be yourself
be a part of this industry or be a part
of this domain that's quite very
important questions that you should ask
yourself not going to answer anyone but
ask yourself and satisfy yourself with
these answers the reason is that that is
going to compose your whole goal or
whole motivation for the uh for your
whole career journey in the terms let's
say if you know that why you are
planning to be a blockchain developer
what is your reason to be in this
industry what is your main motivation
you will be stayed on the whole track
and you can plan these things in a real
way or you can say in a kind of you will
have some timeline that you wanted to
achieve that you wanted to be in this
domain so make sure that you do ask
these three questions before getting
into any XYZ technology it's not just
related to blockchain it's a general
kind of three questions that I usually
make sure that I am clear enough why I'm
going into this direction so that's just
my personal opinion or a kind of my
personal uh belief that I should know
that okay why I want want it to be there
and what could be the ways and who I am
going to be so as a part of this whole
series we are
so starting from if you are just
discussing about a blockchain developer
uh it is presumed for sure that you are
well versed with the technology itself
or with the the working of this
technology why it exists why uh it came
into the picture what is this buzzword
everywhere and why this is booming a lot
so uh as a whole it's being assumed that
you should know what is the blockchain
technology so if you talk about the
technology itself the core functionality
or you can say the core features of it
you are well aware of it so implementing
and designing that whole blockchain
network is something that a blockchain
developer do as well like how you design
a whole network how you implement and
support a network also and then coming
towards creates and optimizes blockchain
protocols and the very last thing that
you go with is how you develop dapps and
smart contract applications on the
blockchain network that's very important
understand those terms if we talk about
the dapps DAP is a kind of like
distributed applications that we use
these terms quite often when it comes to
blockchain developer you may have heard
from someone like okay I'm looking for
adapt developer someone who who can
develop adapt for me it's something like
we are talking about applications that
needs to be developed on the top of
blockchain technology and it could be
any blockchain like public or private
any blockchain so that is very important
if you understand these kind of acronyms
and you really know the meanings of
these acronyms that's also very uh
that's something that matters a lot so
dapps is something that you are going to
have those applications built on top of
blockchain and that's one of the part
that blockchain developer do also and
then come towards the next part that how
do you develop these daphs using like
writing some smart contracts using any
programming languages that we'll be
exploring in in the few slides
afterwards so coming towards like how
you write a smartphone tracks what are
those kind of programming languages that
is needed for you to know and to uh to
be well versed with this so you know the
uh how you are going to make it
technically feasible for your whole
career and and to get your next role so
coming towards
um what could be the type of blockchain
developer you can be because what we'll
discuss is a quite a lot of different
things if you notice the very first part
that I mentioned was that how you can
like designing the network implementing
uh and architecting the solution that's
one part of it then we talked about
another aspect of how you can like um
security and optimizing the whole
um Gap development and then writing the
smart contracts and developing the
applications itself so if if you focus
on the sides it's being divided into two
kind of two sections one is a core
blockchain developer who actually works
into the underlying blockchain
architecture or you can say uh working
on the consensus algorithm that how
these things going to be working so that
comes under the core blockchain
developer and then another part that's
important is the blockchain software
development or you can say dap adapt
developer who is going to develop the
application that's being used or that's
being built on top of that blockchain
technology so if we talk about the whole
blockchain development cycle or you can
say the layers is you have one
blockchain hosted on which you are going
to develop your blockchain application
so first you should be clear enough what
kind of blockchain that you are going to
adopt it could be a public blockchain it
could be a private blockchain or maybe a
kind of hybrid somewhere Consortium or
hybrid blockchain and then coming
towards finding the right talent for the
type of blockchain that you are working
on then that's the next part of uh where
software developers or where you can say
developers in journal lies into so
that's the next part of blockchain
developer is that how you are going to
write the smart contracts or kind of
chain codes and how you're going to make
make those applications work on top of
blockchain so when we talk about first
thing that is core blockchain developer
they are the one who are going to work
on the core features of the blockchain
network itself so if you focus on the on
the category of the blockchain that you
will be selecting let's say if you are
going to go for the public blockchain
for ethereum or archive any application
that you wanted to host in public
blockchain so that's a kind of different
thing you know your consensus you know
everything that's already running into
the network but when it comes to a
private or enterprise-based blockchain
you have a quite different architecture
it's quite bulky it's quite vast like
you have to work around what kind of
network you wanted to build into how
many organizations will going to
participate into the network what will
be the consensus mechanisms that will be
used then how you're going to set up
like let's say if you're talking about
hyper laser fabric you have to architect
the whole thing like participation of
endorsing nodes and Cas and let's say
how it's a whole MSP is going to work
and then the consensus mechanism and how
it is going to be committed to The
Ledger after going through this whole
endorsement policy so there is quite a
lot of network part that needs to be
done in terms of private or our
enterprise-based blockchain which is not
that much required when it comes to any
public blockchain so that whole
blockchain developed for are the one who
is responsible for working on those side
of how these network is going to be
built into so if you just explore a
little bit about hyperledger fabric
Network Administration that's something
a separate role that's being required
for the organizations who develop on top
of hyperledger fabric it's not that they
expect the programmers to do the whole
networking you know who architecting at
the base layer but they expect the the
net the network part is something that
they expect someone else who are
expertise who have the required
expertise in that aspect so that where
is the core blockchain developer come
into like when you talk about
architecture or working on this
consensus algorithm and how you're going
to set up the whole blockchain network
that is one part
of the blockchain developer that you can
be now the next part that when it comes
to software development side this is
where the programming comes like how you
are going to develop your application
that is going to work on on the top of
that specific blockchain let's say if I
decided that I wanted to build uh an
application that is going to be on
hosted onto a public blockchain so it's
a public blockchain application so I
want adapt for that like I want to build
an application so definitely you don't
need to work on to that underlying core
blockchain layer setting up the network
and these kind of stuff what we usually
do is that we directly go towards
writing our smart contract logic once we
understand the whole architecture whole
flow of our solution that okay what kind
of smart contracts we are needed at what
stage we are needing that smart contract
act and what is the whole flow of
information from one end to another end
and who are the participating entities
and all these stuff
once you have a very clear idea of that
you go into developing those
applications in terms of writing your
core code core program into the core
programming side then it comes to
writing your smart contracts and first
you are going to use a test Network
let's say so you're going to host it on
a on a kind of like test Network for
ethereum or then you are going to move
into a main net so that's the kind of
things that mostly on the side of
blockchain developer that how you are
going to write your code compile it and
deploy it itself onto the blockchain
network so coming towards that what kind
of responsibilities and the usual and
the major responsibilities that needs to
be covered by a blockchain software
developer is uh smart contracts writing
the smart contracts or you are required
to develop the whole distributed
applications so the reason of mentioning
this develops the distributed
application is that just writing the
smart contracts is not something you do
only you should know that about when
what what will happen when you are going
to deploy your network and how you're
going to check up all this gas fees and
a lot of the stuff that happened there
once you deploy your smart contract onto
the blockchain network so that's where
this blockchain software development
come into and then the last part of it
that how you work on this front and back
end application so we have a kind of
some middleware
um apis on which we work let's say if we
are talking about uh specifically
ethereum based development we use a
web3.js to interact with our smart
contract and to talk to our front end
also so that is the library that you are
expected to uh write the code and know
that how you're going to interact with
these two layers and act as a middleware
and how you're going to write that
specific kind of HTML code which will
link to your smart contracts easily and
the same thing that follows if you're
talking about any other blockchain let's
say in terms of private blockchain so in
hybridledger fabric when we are
developing an application for that
middle layer specifically we have
different kind of sdks that we use
that's been provided let's say by a
fabric SDK so you you you are bound to
be used like kind of java SDK or node
SDK or any kind of new sdks that being
provided to them let's say part thing is
python is in um in line as well with
them so these are a lot of things that
also involve that how your middleware
will work to talk to a front end for
your blockchain based application that
also comes under under the blockchain
development or kind of how you're going
to work as a software developer or
um or the core technical team for your
blockchain development side
so coming to words that how do you
become a blockchain developer now that's
not a questions that I am going to give
you a rigid answers on that and that's
something that you should follow but I
believe that as I started in the earlier
um part of our video that you should
know uh answers of these questions by
yourself how you're gonna do that or
what you want it to be and who you want
it to be and what are the ways to be at
this stage so when it comes to how do
you become a blockchain developer so
there are a few things that's being
mentioned here it's it's a few things
I'm mentioning because it could be more
than that it definitely depends on the
type of role that you are looking into
or on the type of organization that you
are planning to uh planning to like join
in or targeting to be the next employer
for them so it's quite uh you can say
quite varied options that how do you
become a blockchain developer but that's
one of the you can say core answers
that's everywhere if you found uh the
ways of being a blockchain developer the
very first part that's very important is
the programming language because as we
discussed
the part of being a software developer
is that you should know a kind of
programming language of writing the code
into the blockchain uh in into this
blockchain whole network
so some of the programming languages
that's being mentioned here it's like
Java C plus plus JavaScript go Python
and c-sharp so as a whole I would say
that is very important for being a
blockchain developer is
you should be well versed about the
basic programming paradigms and
how a whole object-oriented programming
work like the base propellers of object
oriented programming the reason is
that's something quite similar when it
comes to
um those programming languages so if you
talk about any of those programming
languages it's not something that you
are expected to know all of them
definitely no one is not expert in all
of these programming language but if you
are well versed with any one of them
let's say any two of them you are
expected to write your code or
understand the main uh main you can say
um main rules of writing any programming
language because you are already well
versed with any one of or any any two of
them that's very important part that
this is the core of a programming
language that you should know now how it
works into writing a blockchain based
development it's something that you are
going to learn when it comes to any kind
of blockchain development course or any
kind of session that you will be joining
so that's something that you will be
learning as an advanced uh aspect of it
but the base if you know you are that
that's going to help you a lot in in
terms of your next Journey for the
blockchain developer so coming towards
uh the side of writing programming
language or the side of software
development on top of any blockchain
application
there is also one programming language
that started with the smart contract so
with the with the existence of ethereum
it's solidity
so solidity developers are something
that they are exclusively expert in
writing this validity uh code or
solidity smart contracts that is being
said because solidity itself is a
contract oriented language okay
but if you just get yourself into or if
you just uh if you just go through a
little bit of how it works or
um a journal view of it you will notice
a lot of thing that is very common and a
lot of Concepts that is very related to
object oriented programming like if you
talk about how you create a class in
object-oriented programming language so
that is the same thing that we follow
like how you create a contract in
objective in in solidity itself then we
have few of the uh few of the concepts
that's very much uh similar to it we
have inheritance in contracts we have
abstract classes interfaces then we have
a kind of aspect that how you
encapsulate things like the
encapsulation aspect of it so a lot of
things how you use a Constructor also so
there are a lot of common things that is
uh very much similar to what we already
we know in object oriented programming
language so for those of you who are
who are kind of confident or kind of
comfortable with any of the programming
language that we just just discussed you
will be able to understand solidity very
much easily
one of the different thing that you will
find in solidity is that
how you are going to play around with uh
with the kind of wallets with the kind
of addresses how it is maintaining uh
connecting to a wallet or maintaining a
address like say smart contract address
itself and then how it's going to hold
some ethers so there are a lot of uh
things or some of the terms are keywords
that is different when it comes to
solidity
and obviously it is expected to be
because that is something that makes it
unique
so these are the things that is
different when it comes to solidity
based programming language so if you are
comfortable enough in writing solidity
based code or you can say uh you are
well versed with any of the programming
languages that is in uh oop that's
object oriented programming you will Ace
the solidity side very easily so you can
Smart Start understanding the concepts
and writing those
um contracts and kind of remix IDE that
is a browser-based tool you don't need
to install anything and you can just
start compiling and trying out your
first smart contract very easily by just
installing a kind of like metamask
wallet or something
so there is a very core part of
blockchain development side first is the
programming language and then the very
next part that I told you already that
is fundamentals of object-oriented
programming language so we know that how
this is related to a blockchain based
development that how you write a kind of
functions how you get the details for
your users and how you use some
functions to send and receive payments
and let's say
um how you create a abstract contract or
there's a kind of how you write some
interfaces for your contract so some
very of the concepts that we already
know in object oriented programming
language it's uh quite you can say
similar to what we have in solidity
then we have a kind of flat and relation
databases or you can say that understand
the main concept that how that rdbms
work or the flat databases work in terms
of if you know this kind of file storage
or data storage you will be easily
understanding that how we are talking
about the importance of blockchain
technology itself and how important this
technology itself the reason is that if
you talk about blockchain based
technology as a whole
it's just a kind of uh data structure or
you could say a technology which works
on storing of data that how do you store
data and then the architecture or the
flow of storing the data that is how it
makes it different that how you're going
to store it like either it's in a
distributed Network either it's in a
kind of um you have a ledger that is
decentralized there is no Central
Authority so these are some of the
things if you understand uh the the main
concept of flat relation database you
will be easily understanding these kind
of things about data structures and how
it's being storing this data in terms of
um in terms of blockchain and how it is
unique to any other
databases or any other data structures
also
so one of the major things also that's
written here is that you have to have
some understanding about data structures
like let's say Stacks LinkedIn list
queues so these are some of the um data
structures that we do we have so if you
understand some of them that's very
important that it is linked to
blockchain in the way that blockchain
itself is also a chain of blocks that is
linked together like it's a kind of
linked list and every block is
containing the patch of previous block
so it is changed together so kind of it
is linked together so it is it works in
the same way that we have linked list so
that's one of the reason if you
understand those data structures the the
way how blockchain works at its core of
a data structure it's going to be very
easy for you and you will be able to
understand that how this Works in a kind
of data structure perspective
and then about some of the knowledge of
web development web app development so
that's a very um common thing that when
you talk about any kind of development
side so if you know that how um web and
mobile application works and how you
create these applications and apart from
it because the concepts that let's say
if you create a mobile applications and
you have some you want to expose some
apis to get data onto a mobile
application that's something very much
same that we we do in in blockchain
development also so these are some of
the concepts that you are being expected
to know when it comes to becoming a
blockchain development so the very last
part of this
um the these points that how do you
developer is the peer-to-peer networking
that's something that I already
mentioned in the type of how you
understand the core concept of
blockchain technology in terms of
storing the data and then it comes to
the networking side it's really
important like let's say
those of you who are coming from let's
say
um a very old and very um basics of
computer science you must have heard
about a client server architecture so
what client server architecture do we
have a server to which all the clients
report to for any of the requests for
any of the things whatever being
accepted or whatever being provided by
the server those lines receive and work
on it and and they will be able to
perform a next steps on it so client
server architecture architecture is
something that is centralized like we
don't have any relation with one client
to another client but all of those
clients are linked to one server or
let's say more than one server but those
servers are the one who is controlling
and who are the managing Authority
but when it comes to a blockchain based
system we don't have that aspect of
centralization
it is a core decentralized Network
that's being also said as peer-to-peer
networking why because all the peers
talk to each other and can see the
transactions whatever others are seeing
also so that's the core part of uh
blockchain development side if you
understand those terms if you understand
that how these things work that is one
of the major thing and then we we talk
about some of the acronyms that's very
important like let's say that is peer
P2P and one of the things that I
mentioned earlier is daps related to
distributed applications that's also
very important and very last third uh
acronym that I wanted to mention is DLT
so what is DLT DLT is a distributed
Ledger technology so if you talk about a
blockchain based uh blockchain based
technology or
you are trying to understand this
technology as a whole
you are expected to know that okay what
is DLT itself because it is a very
important questions most of the uh most
of those who are just newly entered into
this field they know the code they know
the very advanced level of blockchain
but they are not well versed with this
term that said as dld it is a very
important term if you just focus on in
this term is it's an umbrella term like
we have a lot of different Technologies
under DLT
and one of them is blockchain technology
so blockchain is a DLT okay but we have
other technologies that comes under DLT
as well let's say we have hashgraph we
have
um directed acyclic graph that is the AG
then we have
um let's say we have another
technologies that we work into we have
hedera hashgraph and blockchain and many
of those technologies that comes under
DLT it's very important to understand
that the core of DLT is The Ledger is
distributed like it's going to work in a
decentralized way in a peer-to-peer
manner but how it's going to store the
data like the storage of the data it's
different not all of those Technologies
store the data in blocks so it's not all
dlts are blockchain but at its core the
blockchain is a dld itself so that's a
very Broad and umbrella term that you
should know as a as being a potential
blockchain developer make sure that you
are clear enough about these terms and
you are well versed about where and why
you are using these terms
so these are some of the prerequisites
that we discussed that okay
how you want it to be how you do
becoming a blockchain developer what is
a blockchain developer itself I believe
at this stage of this session you are
clear enough about two of this
what you want it to be like what is a
who is a blockchain developer so who is
what you want it to be like what could
be your next role and then how do you
become a blockchain developer so these
are as a whole is just a core steps and
then you can extend your research you
can extend your plan and make your uh
you can say whole journey that how you
wanted to reach a specific goal in terms
of becoming a blockchain developer and
getting yourself into this whole
ecosystem
so let's move into the very next step
that's that says the very first step if
we have got all our prerequisites that's
clear we know what we want it to be uh
we know how we are going to be at this
stage so the very first step if you
notice of of this whole system is the
first thing that you understand the
basics of blockchain
so to whoever usually asked me this
question I would say that as a whole
that's very important to to you to
understand and to go backwards to the
point where this technology started
so for the blockchain if we talk about
the very first white paper or you can
say uh one of the white paper that that
started gaining the traction for this
blockchain based technology is Bitcoin
so what you do you go towards this uh
Bitcoin white paper and try to read it
and try to grasp the whole concept
what's being written and why it came to
an existence and how this technology
played an important role in the whole uh
in this whole system that's being
proposed in that white paper
and that stage I wouldn't expect you to
be a master of blockchain technology and
even to be clear of all the terms that's
written there
but after reading that specific white
paper you should be just clear enough
what is this technology what is the
potential of this technology and either
I am interested or not like let's say
either I am convinced with the what this
technology has done uh to this whole
payments ecosystem and everything
little bit clear enough at this side you
are very good to proceed further and
then what you do you proceed further
with about understanding the core terms
or core concept of blockchain technology
let's say we have uh different types of
blockchains public blockchain private
blockchain then we have hybrid
blockchain so coming towards
understanding the terms if you
understand the base term of blockchain
then you move forward with let's say
public blockchain that is Bitcoin and
after going towards Bitcoin you go and
check in the history the next step and
the next Revolution came into the terms
of ethereum how ethereum came into what
was the reason for that and how it
changed the whole game of this
blockchain ecosystem so there you are
going to explore a lot of thing in terms
of this blockchain based technology the
reason of that is that with ethereum
ecosystem
we had a lot of things that came into
the picture which was not there earlier
we got the way that how you can automate
your business process in terms of those
smart contracts and then using that
smart contracts the scope of this
blockchain technology extended and it is
being explored that you can use this
technology out of this payment ecosystem
or out of this financial services we
have a lot of uh you can say potential
of using it in different ways or you can
say in different use cases so there come
the the potential and the power of this
technology and if you explore a little
bit of the whole journey of ethereum you
are going to find a lot of things that's
very interesting the tokenization aspect
of it
um the mining process that how it
changed up to the latest Trend that we
have in now in 2022 so that's very
important part of the whole journey of
of learning these core of this
blockchain based technology and then
come to coming towards the base let's
say hash uh that how this cryptographic
hash is used how the system is secured
what the kind of encryption that's being
used so you can go through and play
around with some of the you can say
demos and illustrations that's been
provided using that how your data is
encrypted how you cannot change a block
and it will break the chain so a lot of
things that you can explore in at this
step and you you know okay there is some
mining that's being provided some
consensus that's happening and the
reason of that consensus also and the
next part of knowing after knowing those
kind of terms is that how you explore
these things let's say ethereum
hyperledger hashgraph or Coda art
recorder that's very important as well
and other solutions that is built on top
of layer one Solutions that's let's say
we have layered a lot of layer day
Solutions into the market now but that's
another very extended form of blockchain
so as a base what we do is that you
explore
um starting with Bitcoin white paper
then you move toward ethereum based
blockchain and then you go and explore a
little bit of hyperledger fabric and if
you are at the stage of understanding
hyperledger fabric you can look up into
the art recorder as well so a lot of
things you are going to explore in this
whole journey and you will going to
understand the basics of this blockchain
itself so if you talk about this whole
steps that we have in this whole system
in this whole systematic way
it is started from prerequisite if you
are done with prerequisites we are now
move towards step one that we have
already done that says the concepts of
blockchain and the very next stage is
that you understand economics behind
cryptocurrencies and blockchain-based
technology so that's the part that is
very important you understand the whole
um whole economics in the term of the
usage of blockchain uh blockchain
Technologies in in crypto world and a
lot of it on the side of how it works in
terms of issuing some kind of tokens and
then we have token standards how you
write these tokens and the important and
the and you can say
um how it it the price is how you're
going to increase your price for tokens
and then we have the next era that we we
know that right now we just passes this
nfts that how nfts came into the market
and what is the best use case of it so a
lot of things you are going to explore
or in terms of security
that says a hashing that says the kind
of hashing algorithm that's being used
and the digital signatures knowing that
how this core this works as a core and
then the consensus mechanism Also let's
say proof of proof of stake why it's
being used or why there is some
transaction that transition that being
happened from proof of work to proof of
stake knowing the benefits and
disadvantages for each of them it's very
important also
so that's one of the things that needed
to be uh on the side of
you can say more onto the side of
security or more to the side of
technical aspect of blockchain the other
part is that the economic side
on the economic side we have the
understanding that the miners or you can
say the validators who validate the
transaction are being in the
incentivized so it is very important for
you to understand that how you are going
to be like what's is there some
calculation that's been happening it's
something some harming is done and after
that what's going to happen if it's
finished the uh the block reward is
finished so what's going to be happen
with Bitcoin so that's some of the
questions that if you explore that's
going to have some
um you can say
some interesting facts that you will
need to explore in this whole journey
along with it it's very important that
you try to understand about private
blockchain also
if you are exploring it try to go into
going to as a whole not just go through
towards public blockchain and you don't
know the difference between private and
public so if you're talking about
private blockchain you should try to
explore a little bit what happens with
the validators who validate the
transaction in a private blockchain so
who is being rewarded what kind of
reward is being given so you can read
out some of the use cases or some of the
success stories and case studies uh
that's been published to let's say onto
the
um official website of hyperledger
fabric or Linux Foundation or official
website of ethereum
um ethereum Foundation itself so a lot
of things that you are going to find out
on their own official website and for
for further you can say latest
up-to-date uh Trends and happenings into
the industry you can watch out to some
of the videos let's say and videos and
terms uh that what's being happening and
what's being announced by their um like
say co-founders Founders or any of the
speakers who participated into the
conference because that's also very one
of the interesting part of the
conferences if you join that or if you
follow some of the blockchain latest
conferences some of the very the um
biggest you can say announcements or
biggest change that's been happening
into the ecosystem they announce usually
there into the conferences also so you
can follow up to the conference to
understand and to um you can say follow
the trends what's happening into the
industry as well so the very next step
that is how uh to understand how
cryptocurrencies work that is also very
important the reason is that when it
comes to
the blockchain based ecosystem it
started with the very first use case is
the financial use case is how you can
eliminate a middleman and do some
transaction peer-to-peer let's say LS
and Bob they don't need anyone in
between and they can do the transactions
without any one of them so that's very
much important to know that if we are
removing the middleman
who is going to do our transaction
there definitely we do have at the core
we have this blockchain based system
let's say blockchain Bitcoin who is
going to do this transaction for us and
if you if you just go backward in terms
of the middleman we are going to have
some validator or Miner who is going to
mind the Mind our transaction
things are a lot of things that are
changed when it comes to peer-to-peer
transaction uh when it compared to the
transitional and a current system of
current banking system or financial
system that we have so that's very
important to understand how this
cryptocurrency system work if you send
the money from one account to another
account let's say in terms of ethers or
not only in ethers if you are trying to
do some transactions and you are having
let's say some tokens or something then
you will be able to
um do this transaction very quickly and
you will be able to understand it very
quickly how this thing is very different
to the traditional system that we have
so that is also one of the very
important step of this uh four steps or
five steps Journey so you start with the
concepts of blockchain based technology
and then you understand the economics
behind it in which you explore the kind
of like security aspect of it the
cryptographic algorithms that's being
used and who will be rewarded and how
the reward will be done and then how you
under then you understand that how this
cryptocurrencies work and the last thing
is that you're getting on some hands-on
experience and then when it comes to now
at this stage at the fourth stage I
believe you have a clear idea about the
technology
you know the strongest strong use case
of this whole technology so far that we
have
you are well versed with the technical
terms that is being used in this whole
uh you can say in this whole technology
or what kind of consensus or encryption
or uh encryption algorithms or mining
why it's being happening and and the
whole flow okay and if you are clear
enough at this stage you are now able to
getting yourself onto some Hands-On or
into some coding aspect of it so for
this kind of writing some uh programming
and some smart contract you are now able
to start your journey as a blockchain
developer so this stage is very
important for a kind of how you are
going to select what kind of programming
languages that you want to be like what
kind of uh blockchain development you
want to be let's say it's private
blockchain public blockchain and then
you will decide that okay I want to
write a smart contract or I want to
write a let's chain code in hyperledger
fabric that's also uh the choice that
you made initially and then you write
your smart contract and you know that
okay if let's say you are writing it on
ethereum based blockchain you are going
to publish it on ethereum based uh
Network so let's say in in terms of test
Network or in terms of mainnet you can
publish it on on the ethereum based
blockchain and then let's say one of the
major thing that's written into the
whole journey what I appreciate it's not
that you do the work from your end and
you expect the things to happen like
magically from from the employer and or
from the end of hiring you
what is the best way is that if you make
something if you have coded something
even it's a very small application
try to
show off to it to others that what you
have made
by showing off means that you can
convince other that you have the right
talent that is required for this
specific programming language
anyway like it could be like either you
go for having your own GitHub profile
maintain your own GitHub
um whole GitHub portfolio that you can
provide to others so that's the kind of
all your programs they're written you
have all your files that that you can
provide to others just to know that okay
what kind of smart contracts that you
can write
but also you can write some articles out
of it let's say if you are writing a
code in solidity programming language
and you came up with an issue of how
you're going to like you explode some
different ways of error handling like
you have different functions in in
solidity right for error handling and
from your own experience you find out
some amazing way of doing error handling
in solidity that saves some gas fees and
you believe that's a a better solution
out of what you have been already being
provided over the internet
what you can do you can write a complete
whole article on it on the basis of okay
this is my personal finding in my whole
journey I found out this is the best way
and I I I encountered these issues and
to resolve this kind of problems I tried
fixing it in this this way I wrote this
code and that's how it worked
so what will happen others will know
your problem solving skills
your skills of writing a good and solid
smart contract that's very important
so never underestimate the line of code
that you have written or the application
that you have created it might be very
small for you it might be something
that's not convincing for you but for
other or let's say to others that who
are looking up to uh as a as a a
candidate for you as a candidate to you
maybe
it's going to be something that's very
big for them so try posting whatever you
have learned whatever you have made you
can also do some participation in
hackathons let's say you you can
participate and team up with others and
create some uh very you can say
convincing and solid application in a
hackathon that's also going to add on a
lot in your portfolio and that also uh
it's very valuable when it comes to
being this whole blockchain development
Journey so
it's not something that I would say only
in in blockchain uh developing Journey
but for any of the development side it's
very important
that until you create something you are
not going to learn it in that way so try
getting your hands dirty as early as you
can and then once you are at this stage
that you created a solid application you
can just go and and post it somewhere
and create and maintain your own
portfolio so that you will be able to
portray to others what you have made
okay and then that is very important
again I would say the whole blockchain
ecosystem or this whole blockchain based
technology it's evolving very fast so
the developments or the happenings in
this industry it's very quick that you
don't know that when what will happen
so the very important part is that you
keep yourself updated with whatever
being happening it's not about just
keeping yourself updated let's say who
adopted uh hyperledger fabric for their
problem or who which bank adopted R3
core die and they are working on a
solution with partnering with let's say
Swift is now working with blockchain
based technology it's just the high
level that you should know
but at the core you should be knowing
what's happening inside of this
blockchain industry itself
one of the very common and uh latest
trending news that we had in the in the
past few weeks is the merch that
happened in ethereum from proof of work
to proof of stake and how they merged
this whole layers in the ethereum
ecosystem
so the reason of understanding and
keeping an eye and keeping yourself
updated is that
this technology is evolving very fast
and even the solutions and the startup
sets being built into it it's quite uh
you can say
quite quick you you cannot expect
anything to happen maybe into the next
few weeks but there is some very uh
amazing happenings or amazing startups
that's being built upon on top of let's
say any Financial ecosystem or or for
any any industry so try to keep yourself
updated and how you do that so it's up
to you you can follow some of the latest
trending articles that's uh that's
publishing some news on blockchain or
you can also
um just find out some of the solid
connections on LinkedIn and get uh get
connected with them follow them and
treat her so that you know the latest
news what's happening there and that's
one of the reason that's important that
you visit and write some articles visit
the blogs as well and be a part of this
ecosystem
always make sure to put your input to
add your input wherever you feel you can
let's say if today after uh today you
know that okay I wanted to be a
blockchain developer and you are looking
for some of the Articles and you have a
quick thought that okay no this is how
it should be no I believe that this
ecosystem is is like growing so it's
terribly something that's very important
or something you can't put whatever you
know and whatever your thoughts into a
comment don't ever feel shy because
that's how you are becoming to a part of
this whole ecosystem
now the very important part is what we
will be discussing next because how you
become a blockchain developer we
discussed it and then comes to what kind
of obstacles do you face when it comes
to learning blockchain based technology
so coming towards the part is that how
difficult or easy this programming
language is something that's related to
what kind of issues you face okay so
first of all that's very common and I
believe it's uh most of us face this
issue that the outdated content
let's say if you are working on solidity
based uh programming language and if you
are reading and following an article but
it was written for a very old version of
solidity a compiler version but you have
followed the whole exact program and
your program is not working on that
latest version because maybe something
has changed and they've made it work in
in another way for the latest version
so this is very important the content
that you are following must be
latest it's not a very old content that
you are following or it's not something
that that you can say uh already
outdated okay so that's very one of the
obstacles that we would say into the
solidity or into the blockchain based
journey is that the tutorials you follow
or the content that's been written there
may be the issue is being resolved
already but you are following some
content some tutorial that's very old
and one of the second aspect is very
common again is the lack of quality
content
okay so the major thing is that most of
the places where you will see that okay
you will be a blockchain developer in
six weeks in two weeks you will be a
smart uh in four hours videos a lot of
videos that you will be able to see that
it's not that they will not give you the
right content they will definitely give
you but the quality content is very
important and also
after getting this content what you do
afterwards is also very important so the
investment from your side as a learner
or as a as a potential developer in this
field is still there don't just expect
things to happen in a magic way once you
follow a tutorial and you believe that
okay I created this application now I am
a master and I look forward to the
opportunities and I believe I will be
getting hired somewhere hopefully you
will be definitely but how you can make
your place in the industry is that you
try to create something and then
um make some updations on it let's say
now we have a lot of layer do Solutions
also so try to explore many of those
um
Solutions or many of those uh you can
see some of the sdks doesn't that's into
the system or some of the tools that uh
that's now just came into the in this
whole blockchain based development side
so that's also very important for you to
learn from a quality content not from
old content
now that's another very uh you can say
one of the very attractive part of
blockchain based development is the
salary of a blockchain developer so
coming towards the average uh how much a
blockchain developer earns is something
around
um if you talk about in in USD it's
different definitely so it starts from
100K per annum okay it's just a starting
I wouldn't say it's it's an average but
it's more of a start but it definitely
depends upon the size of company that
where you are looking for and where you
are aiming to let's say for a startup
it's going to be a different or a kind
of a big organization is going to offer
you a different rate
but when it comes to uh blockchain based
uh development to any other
um core Tech development let's say
dotnet or c-sharp or even just Java as
well we have a slight difference in the
range that of the salary that's being
provided so the blockchain based
developer or blockchain developer is
usually highly paid
and one of the core reason is not that
the program the technology is booming
only
but also
the supply and demanding
when you talk about the blockchain
ecosystem or blockchain based Developers
the supply itself is like very small and
the demand is like very huge so if we
talk about the demand the demand
outgrows the supply a lot so demand is
growing very rapidly but the supply of
the development or the supply of the
developers is not very high that's why
it's one of the highest paid when it
comes to any of those uh development
side of
um into this whole software development
side so which companies and how
companies are using blockchain based
technology again that's a very common
thing that's IBM Microsoft and they are
using in a different way let's say for
trade finances and we have some
countries that they are using let's say
Australia and Estonia is very famous you
can explore a little bit about estonia's
case study how they have
um revolutionized their Whole Health
ecosystem the smart card that they have
for the for the for their uh citizens or
for the residents and then we have a lot
of things that's also evolved in Dubai
also with the respond Dubai initiative
they have gone paperless uh with
initiative paperless they buy so a lot
of things that's happening in in
different regions it's not just one or
two countries most of the countries
China has also used this technology in a
lot of different ways so you can explore
with how these Technologies work in
different countries and different
companies just to have better
understanding of the potential of this
technology and if you were convinced
enough that okay
this technology is very uh booming and
the support from the government is very
high then you are
satisfied what you are doing and where
you are investing your time that's very
important and you are motivated enough
you are going on a right track you will
be able to do it very easily and very
happy
so that's a little bit of what we can
discuss in our today's session related
to how you can be a blockchain developer
who is a blockchain developer and what
are the steps to becoming a blockchain
developer so this is about our today's
session but we have different courses in
our simply learn uh course as well in
our simply learn training programs that
you can follow and that you can look up
to so you will be able to understand uh
better of what's being provided by
simply learn as for this blockchain
based technology so I wish you all a
very good luck thank you so much for uh
inspiring your time for this video in
case of any comments and questions just
feel free to post it on this simply
learn YouTube channel and the team will
be able to get back to you uh on the
queries that's being posted thanks a lot
for joining in we'll back we'll come
back for another video blockchain
interview questions my name is saurabh
and I'm part of the simply learn team so
let's get started it and understand what
kind of interview questions can come for
a blockchain interview so let's start
with certain beginner level questions
now when You Face a blockchain interview
you can get different variety of
questions so we will be covering that
what kind of questions can be asked at
each level intermediate and expert level
so one of the few questions which you
could be asked is what is the difference
between blockchain and hyperledger
blockchain is basically the underlying
concept blockchain is a decentralized
technology of immutable records called
blocks which are secured using
cryptography whereas hyperledger is a
platform or an organization that allows
people to build private blockchain so
basically blockchain is a concept is a
technology using blockchain you can
build public and private blockchains but
hyperledger is a specific technology
which allows you to build only private
blockchains now blockchain is divided
into public private and Consortium
blockchains hyperledger is specifically
a private blockchain technology with
access to blockchain data is limited to
predefined users and it is defined using
certain configurations and programming
blockchain can be used in multiple
Fields like business governments
Healthcare other different kind of
domains and Etc hyperledger is primarily
used in blockchain for enterprise-based
Solutions so wherever we are talking
about public blockchain is like usage of
blockchain on internet and hyperledger
based blockchain Solutions are solutions
which are meant for intranet within an
organization within a corporation second
how do you explain blockchain technology
to someone who doesn't know it so
basically in simple terms blockchain
technology is a distributed Ledger which
stores transaction details in the form
of immutable records non-modifiable
records which are called blocks which
are secured using cryptography so in
order to explain mean simplistically
let's consider an example of a school
where blockchain is similar to a digital
report card of a student now each block
contains students records which has a
label stating the date and time of when
the record was entered or when the
record was registered on the blockchain
now neither the teacher nor the student
can modify the details of that block
cannot modify the record of report cards
therefore the record becomes
non-modifiable immutable also the
teacher owns a private key that allows
him or her to make new records and the
student owns a public key to view and
access the report card at any time so
basically the teacher owns the right to
update the record but the student only
owns the right to view the record now
this method makes the data both actable
and secure and this is what blockchain
brings on the table these are the
primary attributes for which blockchain
is getting widely adopted to have
immutable records available for view to
the public and available for updating in
an untamperable way now what is a Merkel
tree Merkel tree is a data structure
which is used for verifying a block it
is in a form of a binary tree containing
cryptographic hashes of each block so
basically a Merkel tree is structured
similar to a binary tree each Leaf node
is a hash of a block of transactional
data so each Leaf node is basically a
transaction which is hashed and each
non-leaf node is a hash of its Leaf node
so basically Hash A A is the hash of two
blocks Hash A and hash B Merkel root or
the hash root is the final hash of all
the transaction hashes so basically
Merkel root is the hash of hash a a and
hash BB so it encompasses all the
transactions which underlying all the
non-leaf nodes what do you mean by
blocks in the blockchain technology what
is the definition of a block so
blockchain is a distributed database of
immutable records called blocks which
are secured using cryptography now as
you see there are the certain attributes
of a block which are displayed here you
have previous hash transaction details
nonce and a Target hash value so a block
is like a record of transactions each
time a block is verified it gets
recorded in chronological order on the
main blockchain so as you can see as it
is represented over here every time a
new block is verified it gets added to
the main blockchain with all those
attributes populated now once the data
is recorded it cannot be modified it
cannot be changed now another question
which would come into your interview is
how is blockchain distributed Ledger
different from a traditional Ledger it
is a very important question we need to
know the way basic difference and
justification if we have to move from a
traditional database to a blockchain
based distributed Ledger what benefit it
bring on the table so certain
differences which are very visible are
transparency blockchain distributed
Ledger is highly transparent as compared
to traditional database distributed
ledgers are irreversible once any
information is registered on a
distributed Ledger cannot be modified
whereas on a traditional Ledger it is
reversible basically distributed Ledger
is more secure it uses cryptography
every transaction is hashed and recorded
in a traditional Ledger the security can
be compromised in a distributed Ledger
there is no Central Authority it's a
distributed system the participants of
the network holds the authority to
maintain the sanity of the network and
are responsible for validating the
transactions whereas traditional ledgers
are based on the concept of centralized
Authority and control and all the
transactions that controlled by the
centralized Authority in a distributed
Ledger identities are unknown and are
hidden whereas in a traditional Ledger
identities of all the participants have
to be known before the transaction can
happen in a distributed Ledger there is
not a single point of failure as the
data is distributed information is
shared across multiple nodes even if a
single node fails the other nodes carry
the same copy of the information whereas
in a traditional Ledger in a centralized
database ledger-based system that
particular system becomes a single point
of failure if the single system crashes
the entire application or the entire
network comes to a standstill ability to
modify data know once the data or a
transaction is registered it cannot be
altered and a traditional Ledger it is
possible how validation is done so in a
distributed Ledger it is done by the
participants of the network in a
traditional Ledger it is controlled by
the centralized Authority copy of Ledger
is shared amongst all the participants
of a distributed Ledger each participant
consists the same information in The
Ledger in a traditional Ledger only a
single copy is maintained at a
centralized location it is not shared
amongst all the participants thereby
again it remains as a single point of
failure if you have any queries you can
put your comments in the comments
section of this video and we will
definitely come back to you how can you
identify a block what are the attributes
of block in order to understand it so
every block consists of four Fields it
holds the hash value of the previous
block therefore it gets Linked In A
blockchain it contains the details of
the aggregated transactions which are
aggregated in the block it has a value
called nons is a random value which is
used to vary the value of the hash in
order to generate the hash value less
than the Target and then finally you
have a hash of the block itself it is
the digital signature of this block a
unique hash for this block it is a
alphanumeric value which is used to
identify a block so that is the identity
of the block the hash address is the
unique identification of a block it is a
hex value of 64 characters that has both
letters and digit it is obtained by
using sha-256 algorithm now this is the
way it is structured the hash of the
previous block the transaction data and
the nons consolidate the header of the
block they all together are passed
through a hashing function and then the
hash value the digital signature of the
block is then generated what is
cryptography and what is its role in
blockchain blockchain uses cryptography
primarily to secure users identities and
ensure the transactions are done safely
with the hash function so all the user
identities and the transaction on a
blockchain are encrypted cryptography
uses public and private keys to encrypt
and decrypt data so basically it uses
the public and private key infra
structure in order to maintain the
encryption of the information on a
blockchain network in blockchain network
public key can be shared with all the
Bitcoin users all the blockchain uses so
public key is just like your address
which you can share it with anyone but a
private key is like your password it is
kept secret with the user so basically
blockchain uses cryptography to secure
user identities and ensure transactions
are done safely and how does it do it it
uses sha 256 algorithm which is secure
which provides a unique hash output for
every input and it is a very popular
algorithm the basic feature of sha256 is
that whatever input you pass it will
give you a standard output alphanumeric
output of 64 characters so basically it
is a one-way function you can derive an
encrypted value from the input but you
can't do vice versa now what are the
different types of blockchains which
exists there are three different types
of blockchains public blockchain private
blockchain and Consortium blockchain
public blockchain ledgers are visible to
all the users on the internet and any
user can verify and add a block of
transactions to the blockchain basically
it's publicly available anyone can
participate in the network and get
hooked up so examples are Bitcoin and
ethereum private blockchain ledgers are
visible to all the users on the internet
but only specific users in the
organization can verify an ad
transaction so it's a kind of a
permissioned blockchain though the
information can be available publicly
but the controllers and the validators
of the blockchain are within the
organizations and are predetermined the
example is block stack Consortium
blockchain here the consensus process is
controlled by only specific nodes
however ledgers are visible to all the
participants in the Consortium
blockchain example is Ripple now what
happened when you try to deploy a file
with multiple contracts in blockchain
deploying a file with multiple contracts
is not possible the compiler only
deploys the last contract from the
uploaded file and the remaining
contracts are neglected and this is the
way a smart contract is deployed on a
blockchain network now very interesting
question what is a Genesis Block it's a
very important question and could be
asked in an interview multiple times so
basically Genesis block is the first
block in the blockchain which is also
known as block zero so as you can see
the sequence number of this block is 0
and in blockchain it is the only block
that does not refer to any previous
block so the hash value of the previous
block will be all zeros because it is
the first block also it defines
parameters of the blockchain such as
level of difficulty consensus mechanisms
Etc to mind the block so basically it
defines the primary attributes of the
blockchain which is going to get
initiated from the Genesis block onwards
now let's look at some of the questions
which would come if you are at an
intermediate level now how is the hash
of a block signature generated in
blockchain to generate a digital
signature transaction details are passed
through a one-way hashing function for
example sha256 then the output value is
passed through a signature algorithm
like ecdsa with the user's private key
then the encrypted hash along with the
other information such as the hashing
algorithm is called as the digitally
signed document and is called the
digital signature so this is the entire
process of generating a digitally signed
block list down some of the extensively
used cryptographic algorithms these are
the few popular algorithms which are
extensively used sha-256 Bitcoin uses it
it has ethereum VM uses it RSA is one of
the other popular algorithm Blowfish
triple Des so it's very important to
memorize these algorithms the names of
these algorithms when asked and sh-256
and attach are used in two of the
popular public blockchain networks what
is a smart contract and lists some of
its application so smart contracts are
self-executing contracts these are
basically digital contracts which
contains the terms and conditions of an
agreement between two parties between
two peers now some of the applications
can be used in transportation where
shipment of goods can be easily tracked
using smart contracts so as there's a
movement of goods and it is exchanging
heads between different parties there
could be need of a contract and a smart
contract between the parties it is also
used in protecting copyrighted content
like music or books or the literature
which you have written so smart
contracts can protect the ownership
rights it can also will be used in
Insurance it can be used to identify
false claims and prevent forgeries
employment contract smart contracts can
be helpful to facilitate wage payments
and it can be used as a proof of
employment now another important
question what is ethm network and how
many ethereum networks are you familiar
with ethereum is a blockchain based
distributed computing platform featuring
smart contract functionality that enable
users to create and deploy their
decentralized applications called dapps
there are three types of network in
ethereum live Network the main net then
there are couple of test networks like
robsten carbon and brinkby and then you
can also create your own private network
using ethereum smart contracts are
deployed on the main Network they are
publicly available and can be used by
others also test networks allows you to
run your smart contracts on a test net
validate the gas which is being used you
can just use this test networks as the
mainnet deploy your contracts verify
your decentralized application and then
move on to the main net private Network
are those which are not connected to the
main Network which run within the
premises of the organization but carry
the features of an ethereum Network now
where do nodes run smart contract code
nodes run smart contract codes on
ethereum virtual machine it is a virtual
machine designed to operate as a runtime
environment for ethereum based smart
contracts evm is operated in a sandbox
environment or isolated from the main
net and it is a perfect testing
environment so you can download the evm
run your smart contact locally in an
isolated Manner and once you have tested
and verified it then you can deploy it
on the main now very important and a
very good question what is a dab and how
is it different from a normal
application we need to understand these
differences very thoroughly in order to
clear our interview so adapt is a
decentralized application which is
deployed using smart contract the
information on a Dap is distributed and
shared in normal application it has a
centralized database which is running on
a centralized server so you have a
single server and a single code which is
maintaining the entire application no
information is shared and it is a single
point of failure adapt has its backend
code a smart contract which runs on a
decentralized peer-to-peer Network in a
normal application it's a typical
computer software application that is
hosted on a central server so if you see
in the differences in the process you
have a front end then in the middle you
have a smart contract which is acting as
the backend code and then the entire
transaction executed on a smart contract
is shared between the blockchain
participants in the P2P Network whereas
in a normal application the front end
interacts with a centralized API which
performs basic crud operations create
read update delete on a centralized
database and it is a single copy of the
information name some leading open
source platforms for for developing
blockchain applications so ethereum is
one of the popular platforms for
building blockchain based applications
and it is widely getting adopted Aries
is also used for building
enterprise-based Solutions and also some
of the widely used platforms for
building blockchain are listed below
hyperledger multi-chain open chain are
available in the market what is the very
first thing you must specify in a
solidity file now it is necessary to
specify the version number of solidity
at the beginning of a code as it
eliminates incompatibility errors which
can arise while compiling with another
version it is a mandatory clause which
has to be there at the top of any
solidity code which you write and you
need to mention the correct version
number for which you have written the
code now what is the difference between
Bitcoin and ethereum and it's a very
important question which I also ask in
lot of interviews and it's important for
you to remember these differences so
Bitcoin the concept is purely P2P
currency based transaction but in
ethereum you can do both P2P currency
transaction plus you can deploy smart
contracts Bitcoin is primarily working
on proof of work consensus mechanism
ethereum is shifting from proof of work
to proof of stake Bitcoin uses sha 256
hashing algorithm whereas ethereum uses
it hash time taken to mine a block
currently on bitcoin is approximately 10
minutes whereas in ethereum it gets
processed in 12 to 15 seconds the reward
for mining on bitcoin as of today is
12.5 Bitcoin whereas in ethereum it is
three ethers plus the transaction fees
on bitcoin the transaction fees are
optional whereas in ethereum the fees is
calculated based on the gas which is
being consumed on a smart contract per
transaction value of Bitcoin as of 21st
August was captured at
6934 US Dollars whereas ethereum stands
at 278 dollars now what is norms and how
is it used in mining in blockchain
mining is a process to validate
transactions by solving a difficult
mathematical puzzle called proof of work
now proof of work is the process to
determine a number a nonce that is the
number along with the cryptographic hash
algorithm to produce a hash value which
is lower than a predefined Target nonce
is a random value which is used to vary
the hash values so that the final hash
value meets the hashing condition so the
nonce is the value which is being
generated by The Miner in order to guess
the hash value which should be less than
the target value and then only the miner
can claim the reward for if he is mining
a Bitcoin network of 12.5 BTC and F
ethereum network of three ethers now
let's look at some of the advanced level
questions name the steps that are
involved in a blockchain project
implementation so in a typical block
based project implementation we start
off with requirement identification we
need to understand the problem and goal
we need to identify the suitable
consensus mechanism what is the most
suitable platform which can solve the
problem and then identify the
implementation and deployment costs you
need to give an Roi to the client then
we move on to the planning stage in this
step an individual evaluates all the
requirements list them down prioritize
them and decide a suitable blockchain
platform which has to be used to
implement this particular problem then
click soft the development and
implementation of the project you design
the architecture you design the user
interfaces and start building the apis
and then comes controlling and
monitoring the project you apply the
proof of concept you start off with that
and then start building the application
on top of it and then once the basic
version of the application is available
you start identifying bugs and start
fixing them explain a real life use case
where blockchain is being used so supply
chain is the biggest adopter of
blockchain and as you can see as the raw
material moves is exchanged between
different entities in a supply chain the
traceability of that particular digital
asset which in this case is raw material
is a big case study on blockchain in
Supply Chain management smart contracts
provide permanent transparency
traceability and validation of
transaction shared by multiple supply
chain Partners so at each level each
supply chain partner has to register the
transaction when it receives a product
and then when it passes it on so
basically the purchaser when consuming
the end product can see the entire
journey of the product list and explain
the parts of evm memory so the memory of
an evm is divided into three parts
storage memory and Stack Storage values
are stored permanently on the blockchain
network and it is extremely expensive so
whenever you will try to modify a
storage based variable you would have to
pay gas for it memory variables are 10
Library modifiable storage area it can
be accessed only during the contract
execution and once the execution is
finished the data is wiped off vanished
and it's lost stack on the other way is
a temporary and a non-modifiable storage
here when the execution is completed the
content is lost so basically memory and
stack are relatively much cheaper than
storage variables now what happens if
the execution of a smart contract costs
more than the specified gas initially
your transaction will be executed but if
the execution of a smart contract costs
more than the specified gas then the
miners will stop validating your
contract the blockchain will record the
transaction as fail as highlighted and
also the user does not get a refund so
it becomes of utmost important that when
you are deploying your smart contract
you do the calculation of the gas
consumption in the most correct fashion
what does the gas usage in a transaction
depend on and how is transaction fee
calculated SO gas usage depends upon the
amount of storage you are using if you
are using storage based variables and
the cost of the transactions will be
high the gas will be high and the set of
instruction codes used in a smart
contract basically what operations you
are performing on the storage based
variables either they're costly and if
you are using huge amount of storage
variables then automatically the cost of
your smart contract will keep on
increasing so basically the transaction
fee is calculated in ethers which is
given as the gas price which you have
determined for your smart contract and
multiplied by the gas limit and this is
how your transaction fee is evaluated
now what is fork and what are some of
the types of forking so in simple terms
updating a cryptocurrency protocol or
code is called forking folk implies that
a blockchain splits into two branches
and forking is done when you want to
modify certain attributes of an existing
block Network it can happen when the
participants of the network cannot come
to an agreement with regards to either
the consensus algorithm or they want new
rules for validation so there are three
types of hard soft
and accidental Forks what is the
difference between proof of work versus
proof of stake and it's a very important
question in blockchain proof of work is
the process of solving a complex
mathematical puzzle called mining
whereas proof of stake is an alternative
to proof of work by which the blockchain
aims to achieve distributed consensus in
proof of work probability of mining a
block is based upon the amount of
computational work done by a miner
basically it consumes huge amount of
resources electricity resources and
computational resources of the miner
whereas in proof of take the probability
of validating the block relies upon the
amount of token you own beforehand so
the more the tokens you have the more
the chance you get to validator block so
basically proof of stuff has been
introduced in order to reduce the
pressure on the resources which has been
put by the proof of work consensus
algorithm miners spend a lot of
computing power for solving the
cryptographic puzzle along with the
hardware and it's a huge cost so
basically proof of stake was created as
a solution to minimize the use of
expensive resources spent in mining what
is a 51 attack in blockchain 51 attack
refers to a vulnerability where an
individual or group of people can
control the majority of the mining power
or hash rate so basically they can take
over the 50 of the blockchain network
this would allow the attackers to
prevent new transactions from being
confirmed further they can double spend
the coins now in 51 attack smaller
cryptocurrencies are primarily being
attacked which does not have a huge
Network which has a small consumer base
what a function modifiers and solidity
and mention the most widely used
modifiers in solidity function modifiers
are used to easily modify behavior of
your smart contract it can be associated
with a function and then whenever a
function is called the modifier is
called before the main function in
simple terms it can build additional
features or apply restrictions on the
function of smart contracts the most
extensively used function modifiers in
solidity are view view functions are
functions that cannot modify the state
of a smart contract they are only
read-only functions here is an example
you have a function that simply learn
name and it is having a modifier view
which only returns a value but you are
allowed to use some inbuilt solidarity
functions like MSG dot sender but in
case of pure pure functions are
functions that neither read nor write
the state of smart contracts they return
the same result determined by its input
variables so basically you can even
access the inbuilt functions of solidity
so here here you have a function called
calculate you can only use the input
variables you cannot use any of the
inbuilt functions also of solidarity now
let's take a look of an example in order
to write a crowd sales smart contract
code in solidity programming language so
here in the example you have a smart
contract where you have defined certain
smart contract variables of solidity
like address and uint now the address
function is if you want to send your
token to someone and your uint is the
funding goal in ethers basically how
much amount of ethers you want to
generate in your crowd Sale Project then
what is the duration of your project
then cost of each token in ethers then
address of token used as reward so these
are the primary attributes which you
have defined then you have your public
functions which are defined over here
the beneficiary if successfully sent to
the funding goal the deadline of your
crowd sale and the price now now here is
your default function which is defined
in a solidity contract which does not
have any function name and is called by
default in your smart contract if anyone
invokes a method in your smart contract
which does not exist in this function
you are making sure that all the amount
which has been passed to the smart
contract is passed to your address
basically you are the originator of your
crowd sale function crowd sales smart
contract so you should be receiving the
amount then in your crowd sales smart
contract you can have a method which is
called as safe withdrawal and you have
appended it with a modifier called after
deadline so which basically checks that
you can only do a withdrawal after the
deadline has been achieved and in this
function you are checking the balance
then you are withdrawing that amount
from the sender and transferring it to
your own account as the sender has sent
that amount to you so you do the best
validations whether the sender has that
balance and then you do that transfer to
your account we have come to the end of
this video on blockchain full course I
hope you found it useful and
entertaining if you like this video then
do give it a thumbs up and share it with
your friends please ask away any
questions about the topics covered in
this video in the comment box below our
experts will assist you in addressing
your problems and solving them thank you
for watching stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here